ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
NUMBER SIX TO ORDER. LET ME
JUST START READ OFF THE USUAL-
JUST THE USUAL FIFTY PROTOCOLS
REGARDING OUR HEARING. WE ARE
HAVING A PHYSICALLY DISTANT
HEARING IN ROOM FORTY TWO- OH
TWO HI THIS IS THE LARGEST
HEARING ROOMS EVEN THOUGH THE
LARGEST TEAM ROOM WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS WERE
FOLLOWING VERY STRICT. PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS. I WILL
SAY THIS AGAIN WHEN PUBLIC
COMMENT BEGINS A BIT OF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WISHES TO
SPEAK THEY WILL BECOME GREATER
HANDER THEY CAN APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE UP HERE IN THE FRONT
OF THE ROOM. EVERYBODY WILL
HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU ARE DEFINITELY
ALLOWED TO EXIT THE HEARING
ROOM ONCE YOU'VE MADE A PUBLIC
COMMENT IF YOU SO CHOOSE. WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF PALLETS ON THE
AGENDA THE ALL APPEARING
REMOTELY. VIA THE WEB- BECAUSE
THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING MEMBERS MAY HAVE
REQUESTED IN ADVANCE TO APPEAR
REMOTELY EITHER IN THEIR
CAPITOL OFFICE OR IN THEIR
DISTRICT OFFICE AND THOSE
MEMBERS. WHO'VE RECEIVED
PERMISSION CAN APPEAR REMOTELY
THERE WILL BE NO VOTE IN
COMMITTEE TODAY. WE ARE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT OVER
THE PHONE AS WELL THE NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN IN THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO
SHOULD BE ABLE TO SEE THAT IF
YOU ARE STREAMING THIS. HEARING
LIVE OR WATCHING IT ON A SIMPLY
TV. HAVE ANY PROBLEMS GETTING A
HOLD OF US PLEASE CALL THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2099 TODAY'S HEARING
COVER THREE VERY TIME IS. ONE
IS ON VACCINE JUST. TO IS ON
CLOVER NINETEEN EXPENDITURES
AND THREE IS THE AVAILABILITY.
OF FEDERAL FUNDS WE WILL HAVE
THREE PANELS TODAY TO EVALUATE
EACH ISSUE. AND ASKED ABOUT-
AFTER EACH PANEL WE CAN HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR THE PARTICULAR
PANELISTS- IN THEIR ORDER.
AGAIN THERE'S NO MORE IMPORTANT
ISSUE RIGHT NOW THE INDEXING
DISTRIBUTION- VERY PROBABLY
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW IS A
MINISTER TWELVE POINT SIX
MILLION. VACCINES IN WITH THAT
CAPACITY AND SUPPLY GROWING
EACH AND EVERY SINGLE DAY. WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN HIT
HARDER THAN OTHERS AND WE'VE-
REALLY BEEN FOCUSED ON HOW TO
GET VACCINES INTO THOSE- HOT
SPOTS INTO INTO THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS MAKING SURE THAT
WE CAN MAKE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS THERE. IN TERMS OF THE
JUNE TWO THE- HAS. THEIR
COVERED BY EXPO PER. THE REPORT
HAS A NEW. ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS OF
EXPENDITURES- AND THEY HAVE
ALSO. PROPOSED NEW CONTROL
SECTION LANGUAGE TO CONTINUE
THEIR AUTHORITY TO SPEND
EMERGENCY FUNDS INTO THE NEXT
BUDGET YEAR. IN TERMS OF
FEDERAL FUNDS THERE A ONE POINT
NINE TRILLION AND FIVE TRILLION
DOLLAR AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
WILL PROVIDE BILLIONS OF
FEDERAL AID TO CALIFORNIA- WE
ARE ASKING ALEJO INDEPENDENT
FINANCE TO HELP. INTERPRET HOW
MUCH AND IN WHAT WAYS WE CAN
SPEND THAT MONEY SO THAT WILL
BE ISSUE NUMBER THREE. SO LET'S
BEGIN WITH ISSUE NUMBER ONE AND
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION. SECRETARY
RICHARDSON ARE YOU THERE. AND I
THINK IF YOU'RE THERE YOU CAN
JUST START TALKING AND YOU'LL
COME ON THE SCREEN I AM HERE.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR
AND SEE USE PERFECT. ALL RIGHT
GREAT. FEEL FREE TO LET ME KNOW
WHEN YOU'RE READY FOR ME TO
BEGIN OKAY WE ARE READY. WELL
GOOD AFTERNOON- AS YOU
MENTIONED I'M SECRETARIAL UNDER
RICHARDSON OF THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY AND I'M VERY
PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON OUR
EFFORTS TO PROVIDE. OCTOBER
NINETEEN VACCINATIONS TO
CALIFORNIANS AS QUICKLY AND
ACCURATELY AS POSSIBLE- I'LL
JUST MENTION TO THE COMMITTEE
THAT DUE TO THE URGENCY OF OUR
WORK. I DO HAVE A LIMITED
AMOUNT OF TIME TODAY BUT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS I'M HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP ON. ON ANYTHING YOU
MAY NEED THAT I MAY NOT
ADDRESSED IN MY REMARKS- I'M
VERY HONORED THAT THE GOVERNOR
ASKED ME TO JOIN THE STATE'S
VACCINE TEAM. TO ASSIST WITH
OPERATIONS AND FIND WAYS TO
INCREASE THE SPEED AN EQUITABLE
DELIVERY. OF COVERED BY
NINETEEN VACCINES. I WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH SECRETARY MARK
GALLI. DR NADINE BURKE HARRIS-
DR OCTAGON AND DOCTOR KLEIN ON
VACCINATION PLANNING
ELIGIBILITY. ALLOCATION EQUITY
AND ACCESS. SINCE JANUARY WHEN
THE GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED HIS
INTENTION TO BUILD A STATEWIDE.
PROVIDER NETWORK IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR IN THIS CASE A
BLUE SHIELD OF CALIFORNIA- I
HAVE BEEN HARD AT WORK. HELPING
TO CREATE THAT NETWORK. TO
SCALE UP THE STATE'S CAPACITY
TO ADMINISTER VACCINES. IN
TANDEM WITH THE GOOD WORK BEING
DONE IN COUNTIES ACROSS THE
STATE. WELL THERE WAS
TREMENDOUS WORK DONE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL TO BUILD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO DELIVER
VACCINATIONS. THE SHEER VOLUME
OF WORK REQUIRES US TO
SUPPLEMENT THE STATE'S
CAPACITY. TO DELIVER THOSE
VACCINES SO THAT WE CAN KEEP.
PACE WITH THE EXPECTED SUPPLY.
WE ALLOCATING. TO REACH PRIORE
BROUGH. SUCH AS TEACHER. AND
FARMWORKERS SO THAT WE CAN
BEGIN MOVING DOWN THE
ELIGIBILITY TEARS. RECOGNIZING
THAT VACCINATIONS WERE GOING
DISPROPORTIONATELY TO THE MOST
ADVANTAGE COMMUNITIES IN THE
STATE. WE WORKED AS A TEAM
ACROSS THE ADMINISTRATION TO
DEVELOP A PLAN TO MOVE MORE OF
THE VACCINE SUPPLY TO THE
COMMUNITIES HARDEST HIT IN THE
PANDEMIC. THIS IS INTENDED TO
REBALANCE THE ADMINISTRATION OF
VACCINES SO THAT THE DOES REACH
CALIFORNIA'S MORE EQUITABLY. AS
YOU KNOW OUR PRESIDENT BIDEN
HAS INDICATED THERE WILL BE
ENOUGH VACCINE SUPPLY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS BY THE END OF MAY
AND HE IS CHALLENGES TO BE
READY TO DELIVER IT. TO ALL
AMERICAN ADULTS WITHOUT REGARD.
TO ELIGIBILITY RULES STARTING
ON MAY FIRST THAT MEANS WE NEED
TO BE READY- WE NEED TO BE
READY TO RECEIVE PROIN
SHIPMENTS OF VACCINE. THROUGH
MARCH THE VACCINE SUPPLIES HAVE
BEEN ALMOST FLAT AS THE ABILITY
TO ADMINISTER SUPPLIES GREW THE
SHORTAGE FAIL MORE ACUTE AND
THERE HAVE BEEN FRUSTRATIONS BY
THOSE WHO ARE SO READY TO GIVE
SHOTS IN ARMS- AND WISH THAT
THEY COULD GET MORE SUPPLY.
UNFORTUNATELY LIKE EVERY STATE
IN THE NATION- WE HAVE BEEN
GETTING LESS VACCINE THAN WE
NEED BUT IN APRIL WE EXPECT
THAT TO CHANGE. BASED ON
MEETINGS WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WE ARE EXPECTING A
SHARP INCREASE IN VACCINES
STARTING JUST IN THE FIRST WEEK
OF APRIL. I'M HAPPY TO REPORT
TODAY THAT WE WILL BE READY TO
GET THOSE VACCINES INTO ARMS.
WE'VE BUILT A STATEWIDE VACCINE
NETWORK WITH BLUE SHIELD THAT
WILL BE CAPABLE OF
ADMINISTERING AT LEAST FOUR
MILLION DOSES OF VACCINE PER
WEEK. JUST IN THE LAST SEVEN
DAYS HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
ADMINISTERED. OVER TWO MILLION
DOSES. I HUNDRED AND SIX APRIL
ARE THE NETWORK. IN SIX ONE.
QUALIFIED OR COMMITTEE HEALTH.
THIRTY SIX HOSPITAL SEVEN
MEDICAL GROUPS AND THIRTY THREE
PHARMACIES AS WELL AS OUR MULTI
COUNTY HEALTH SYSTEMS WHICH
INCLUDE. UC'S YOU SEE SUTTER
DIGNITY KAISER ADVENTIST
PROVIDENCE AMONG OTHERS. NEW
PROVIDERS ARE BEING ADDED DAILY
AND BY APRIL AND THREE MAY EASE
PROVIDERS WILL OFFER
VACCINATIONS AT THOUSANDS OF
SITES ACROSS THE STATE. TO KEEP
PACE WITH THE DRAMATICALLY
INCREASING VACCINE SUPPLY AND
AUGMENT THE GOOD WORK OF OUR
COUNTY PARTNERS. IN ADDITION WE
ARE CONTINUING TO FORMALIZE
AGREEMENTS WITH THE LEADERSHIP
OF CALIFORNIA SIXTY ONE LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS. SO THAT
WE CAN WORK SIDE BY SIDE TO GET
THE JOB DONE WITH AS LITTLE
DISRUPTION AS POSSIBLE TO THE
GOOD WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING.
ALL OF US SHARE THE SAME GOAL
GET VACCINATIONS AND ARMS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE TO SAVE AS
MANY LIVES AS WE CAN. AND GET
BACK TO A MEASURE OF NORMALCY
IN OUR STATE. I AM GRATEFUL FOR
THE SUPPORT OF SO MANY IN THE
LEGISLATURE AS WE CONTENT TO BE
WORK AT A FURIOUS PACE.
LITERALLY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
LATE INTO THE EVENING EVERY
NIGHT SINCE JANUARY TO
ACCOMPLISH THE MONUMENTAL TASK
OF ENSURING THAT OVER TWENTY
FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS OVER
THE AGE OF SIXTEEN. CAN GET
VACCINATED AND THAT NO
COMMUNITIES ARE LEFT BEHIND. AS
WE VACCINATE WE WILL BE
MONITORING OUR PROGRESS WITH
TIMELY DATA TO INFORM WHERE
ADJUSTMENTS NEED TO BE MADE. TO
ACHIEVE OUR STATEWIDE GOALS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO UPDATE YOU ON
OUR PROGRESS. THANK YOU MA'AM.
LET'S GO TO- THIS NELLIE DID
PUBLIC. CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN
HEAR YOU CAN JUST START
SPEAKING GREATER EGO THANK YOU
OKAY GOOD MORNING OUR SERMON
KING AND MEMBERS MY NAME SUSAN
VALLEY I'M THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OVER POLICY AND
PROGRAMS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. OVER THE PAST
FOURTEEN MONTHS I'VE BEEN CO
LEADING THE PUBLIC HEALTH THE
MEDICAL RESPONSE FOR A COVERT
NINETEEN TODAY I WANT TO FOCUS
MY COMMENTS ON THE EFFORTS
UNDER WAY TO ENSURE THE AFFABLE
DISTRIBUTION AND ADMINISTRATION
OF COVER NINETEEN VACCINE.
THROUGHOUT THE VACCINE
ALLOCATION AN ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESS WE HAVE A PRIORITIZE
THE NEEDS OF THOSE MOST AT RISK
OF EXPOSURE TO THE DISEASE AND
OR SEVERE OUTCOMES WITH RESPECT
IS SEVERE DISEASE THERE ARE
DISPARITIES AS YOU KNOW BASED.
ON RACE ETHNICITY AND AGE. D.
FROM CALIFORNIA. THAT SEVERAL
ARE HIGHER OF THIS DISEASE
SEVERE OUT. DUE TO KOVEN. I'M
AN AGAIN THESE JUST BEAR.
DISPARITIES REFLECT IN WHAT THE
BLACK AND NATIVE HAWAIIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER. WE'RE DOING
OUR BEST TO VACCINATE ALL
CALIFORNIANS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE BUT ALSO RECOGNIZE THE
NEED TO VACCINATE FIRST THOSE
WHO ARE AT HIGHEST RISK OF
HOSPITALIZATION AND DEATH. IN
ORDER TO ACHIEVE EQUITY IN OUR
VACCINE ADMINISTRATION THE
STATE IS FOCUSED ON SEVERAL
STRATEGIES EQUITABLE ALLOCATION
OF VACCINE TO THOSE MOUNT THOSE
MOST SEVERELY IMPACTED IT.
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA STATE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
GUIDANCE TO LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS DEVELOPMENT OF
LOCAL EQUITY PLANS INCLUDING
EQUITY IN THE LOCAL TRANSITION
PLANS TO THE STATE WIDE
VACCINATION NOT WORK. UNDER THE
TV A AUGMENTATION OF
VACCINATION EFFORTS- OUTREACH
EDUCATION ENLISTING THE HELP OF
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND ESTABLISHING METRICS AND
PERFORMANCE MEASURES. THIS I
HOPE DEMONSTRATES CALIFORNIA'S
CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO EQUITY
AS WAS DONE WITH TESTING AND
THE CORPORATION OF THE
HEALTHEQUITY METRIC INTO THE
BLUE PRINT FRAME WORK. AND
PRIORITIZING INCLUDE OUR
RESOURCES TO INCREASE TESTING
ACROSS THE STATE. YOU WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE ALLOCATION
FORMULA THE STATE IS
IMPLEMENTED THIS THAT DIRECTS
INCREASE SHARES A VACCINE TO
THOSE AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED. BY
THE PANDEMIC AND AS A STATE
WIDE LOOK BY ZIP CODE AND BY
THAT HEALTHY PLACES INDEX
QUARTILES- IN WHICH THOSE AND-
ZIP CODES FALLING. THE LAW-
MOST IN CORE TIME I'LL GET
EXTRA 2% OF THE STATE I'LL-
WE'VE ALSO SUPPORTED SOME IN
THIS. FOR KEEP AND- MAX FOR IS
A IS TRANCE. WORKERS TEACHER
AND OTHER GROUPS EITHER HAVE A
HIGH RISK OF EXPOSURE OR HIGH
RISK OF SEVERE DISEASE. THE
STATE'S PRIORITIZATION
ELIGIBILITY GUIDANCE. ALSO
SUPPORTS ALLOCATING AND TIONAL.
TO IN. INTO KEEP EXT HOME. AND
PEOPLE WITH HIGH RISK MATT. OR
JUST A CAN. THESE ARE DESPERATE-
MADE UP OF LOW IN FOLKS AND
KEEP OF COLOR. WE ALSO HAVE A
SYSTEM IN PLACE FOR PROVIDER
PRIORITIZATION THE STATE IS
TAKING STEPS TO IDENTIFY AND
SUPPORT PROVIDERS THAT
SUCCESSFULLY ADMINISTER
VACCINES TO THOSE PEOPLE RIGHT
RESIDING IN THIS LOWEST. H. P.
I. QUARTILE WE'RE ALSO ALLOWING
YOUR THROUGH THE MY TURN SYSTEM
ALLOCATION OF EMPLOYMENT EITHER
BY ISSUING CO YOU TOO CAN BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHERS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE ACCESS
TO APPOINTMENTS AND ALSO TO DO
THINGS LIKE CLOSE CLINICS AND
WE'RE CONTINUING TO MEET WITH.
OUR LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS
AND PROVIDERS TO CREATE NEW
FEATURES WITHIN MY TERM TO
ALLOW FOR BETTER MANAGEMENT I
HAVE- BAXEEN. WE AS YOU KNOW
HAVE LOW AT. POP WORKING IRAQ
DRAFT GUIDE WORKER TO YOU
ESTABLISH THE ALLEGED CRITERIA.
BEGINNING WITH CARE WHERE AND I
WAS INCOME SETTINGS EXPANDING
JOINT AGE BASED APPROACH
LOOKING AT SIXTY FIVE PLUS THEN
EXPANDING TO SECTORS OF HIGH
RISK INCLUDING FOOD AND AG
EDUCATION EMERGENCY SERVICE
WORKERS EXPANDING THEN TO THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR AND THEN
TO THAT SIXTEEN TO SIXTY FIVE
YEAR OLDS WITH UNDERLYING.
HEALTH CONDITIONS OR
DISABILITIES AND SO CONTINUING
TO UPDATE OUR ELIGIBILITY BASED
ON AVAILABLE VACCINE AND THOSE
MOST AT RISK TO EXPOSURE SEVERE
DISEASE WE HAVE ALSO WORKED
WITH OUR LOCAL HEALTH PARTNERS
TO ESTABLISH LOCAL HEALTH
EQUITY PLANS. AROUND
VACCINATION AND THESE L. H.
DAYS HAVE- LOOKED AT THE GOAL
OF THEIR PLAN TO INCREASE
VACCINE EQUITY IDENTIFY EQUITY
GAPS INFORM BETTER COORDINATION
BETWEEN THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
EPA- THE PROVIDERS AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
THERE AND EMBARKING ON A NUMBER
OF STRATEGIES AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
IN. INCREASED EQUITY AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL ALLOCATION OF
VACCINE TO THE PROVIDERS
HELPING THAT TVA TO IDENTIFY
THEM WORKING WITH OUR FQHCS THE
GROUND- LOCATING VACCINATION
POINTS OF DISTRIBUTION IN
LOWER- PORTELA I'M ZIP CODES.
I'M BY BOX PRAYER POPPY UP THE
WORK. IN LISTING THOSE CAN
LEADERS THAT KIND OF PRIORITY
PA. TO GAP AND AT EDUCATION
VENUES DIRECTLY AND OUTREACH.
THE STATE WILL CAN TO OUR LOCAL
HOW JURIST. IN FOR FILLING
RECENT WORK THAT THEY- SO JUST
AND SUPPLY- AND TECH EXPERT.
THAT THEY MAY NEED WE HAVE
EQUITY REGIONAL MANAGERS WHO
WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE TBA TO ENSURE
THAT OUR LOCAL AND TRANSITION
PLANS REFLECT THE DISCUSSIONS.
WITH OUR LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS AND MAKING SURE
THAT- ANY RE. ABOUT THEIR NEED
ON THE GROUND ARE DA. IN THOSE.
I'M HAVE SOME IT WE HAVE ALL
THE LOCAL. EFFORTS AS OF YOU
KNOW WE HAVE PUFFINESS TO GREAT
ACCESS AND IN THEIR SUCH AS THE
OAKLAND LOS. THIS INCLUDE STATE
LET EFFORTS TO PROVIDE MORE
SITES FROM THESE MAY SITE STILL
PRIORITY CAN MEAN OF COLOR
COMMUNITY OF COLOR. WE HAVE THE
OPTIMUM SITE CLINICS AND MOBILE.
THE STAFF THROUGHOUT THE STATE
TO ENSURE ACT TO BACK IN THE
CENTRAL. SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND ACROSS THE STATE WE HAVE
ASSISTED WITH STAFFING
RESOURCES AS WELL AS SUPPLIES
SUCH AS FREEZER AN ANCILLARY
KITS TO BE DIRECTED TO AREAS OF
NEED TO ENSURE ABILITY TO
VACCINATE WE CONTINUE WITHOUT
REGION EDUCATION AND WORK WITH
OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WE ARE ON OUR
STATE PUBLIC INFORMATION
CAMPAIGN TO ADDRESS MAXINE HAT
HESITANCY IS UNDER WAY. THE
CAMPAIGN CENTRAL MESSAGES ARE
FOCUSED ON PROVIDING
EDUCATIONAL SCIENCE BASED FACTS
ABOUT THE VACCINE FOR EXAMPLE
THAT THE VACCINES ARE SAFE AND
HIGHLY EFFECTIVE AND THEY'RE
FREE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
MESSAGES ALSO HELP TO FOCUS
CALIFORNIA'S TO NAVIGATE
ELIGIBILITY AND THE PROCESS FOR
GETTING A VACCINE. THE CAMPAIGN
IS ALSO ADDRESSING THE BARRIERS
BARRIERS AROUND ACTING
HESITANCY YOU'RE A COMPELLING
AND CULTURALLY CONGRUENT
ADVERTISING CAMPAIGN THAT HELPS
PEOPLE OVERCOME THEIR CONCERNS
AND CONNECTED THAT BACKSEAT
LEADING TO AN UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE VACCINES ARE THE BEST
TO ATTENDING THE PANDEMIC.
DEPUTIZING WILL RUN PRIMARILY
ON ETHNIC AND MULTICULTURAL
MEDIA OUTLETS ACROSS PLATFORMS
LIKE TV RADIO DIGITAL
NEWSPAPERS AND BILLBOARDS THE
CAME CAMPAIGN FEATURES ADDS A
MORE THAN A DOZEN LANGUAGES IN
ALL MEDIA MARKETS OF
CALIFORNIA. OVER THE NEXT TWO
WEEKS- WE'VE LAUNCHED- RADIO IN
SIX LANGUAGES NEW DIGITAL TOOL
KIT FOR HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ON
THE WEEK OF THIS WEEK WE ARE
DOING OP ADS FROM CALIFORNIA
DOCTORS REGARDING THE SAFETY
AND EFFICACY OF THE J. AND J.
VACCINE AND WE'RE DOING PAID.
SEARCH AND SOCIAL MEDIA GOES
LIVE. ON THAT WERE WENT LIVE ON
THE FIFTH FIFTEEN. AND THE ON
THE WE HAVE TWENTY SO- WILL BE
DOING SPOT AND ALLU. NEW LOCK
I'M THE TYPE TO THE LAST TO A-
FOR VACCINE OFFIT EIGHT .COM
LAUNCH. CBO WORK AT BOTH THE
AND LEVEL TO MAKE SURE THAT
MESSAGES GETTING LOUD IN CLEAR
TO ENTER PEOPLE TO WHERE THEY
GET BACK. WE'VE ESTABLISHED
PERFORMANCE MEASURES OUR
PROVIDERS TERMS OF COLLECTING
THAT DATA INCLUDING DEMOGRAPHIC
DATA SUCH AS RACE AND ETHNICITY
AND ZIP CODE- SO THAT WE REALLY
KNOW WHO WE ARE VACCINATING
IT'S ONE THING TO DO OUTREACH
AND TO HOLD CLINICS IN. A
PARTICULAR LOCATION IT'S
ANOTHER TO MEASURE EXACTLY
WHO'S GETTING THE VACCINE. ARE
WE ARE I'M ASKING THAT
PROVIDERS COORDINATE WITH OUR
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT EQUITY
PLANS. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ALL WORKING IN SYNC TO REDRESS
THE POPULATION NEEDS WE ARE
MEASURING THE H. B. I.
QUARTILES IN THE REACH OF THOSE
ELIGIBLE POPULATIONS. WE HAVE
ALSO SET UP PERFORMANCE
MEASURES FOR THE GPA AND FOR
CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE WE CREATED
A VACCINE EQUITY METRIC TO
MONITOR THE DOSE IS
ADMINISTERED TO THE H. P. I.
QUARTILES. AND HAVE POSTED THIS
ON OUR PUBLIC DASHBOARD IN
ORDER TO HOLD OUR WHOLE STATE
ACCOUNTABLE INCENTIVIZE
VACCINATIONS OF OUR HIGHEST
PRIORITY POPULATIONS WE SET
BENCHMARKS BASED ON THE NUMBER
OF DOSES ADMINISTERED IN H. B.
I. QUARTILE ONE. OUR LEAST
ADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ONCE WE
REACH TO IMPORTANT THRESHOLDS
WE CAN MODIFY THE THRESHOLDS
BETWEEN OUR BLUEPRINT FOR STATE
PARK ON THE METEOR. TO ALLOW
FOR SOME OF THE SAME ACTIVITIES
AT THE SITE HIGHER RATE.
ULTIMATELY THE DATA NOT MORE
THE STATE TO SHIFT IN OUR- AS
NEED TO INSURE THAT WE MET ME
OUR EQUITY. I'LL STOP AND I
KNOW I THROUGH A LOT OUT THERE
BUT I HOPE IT. SHOWS THAT WE
ARE COMMITTED TO. NOT ONLY. ALL
CALIFORNIA MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE VACCINATING THOSE MOST AT
RISK OF SEVERE- DISEASE OR
HOSPITALIZATION THANK YOU AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
GREAT THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA GO
TO MISCONDUCT. WITH L. A. L. I
THANK YOU MISTER. US ANY PICK
FROM THE ELADIO. L. IT WAS
HONEST TAKING ANY. THEY MEMBERS
MAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU WAS
GONNA TRY OVER THE MEN SEE
MISTER CARLY. I JUST A QUICK
QUESTION ME- IT'S BEEN AND YOU
MEANT THE HEALTH. PLACE IN THAT.
AND- I WONDER HOW IT WAS THAT
THIS WOULD BE THE YARD FOR
EQUITY BECAUSE I KNOW THIS HAS
TWENTY FACT OR SOME LIKE THAT
SO NUMBER KIND OF INTERESTING-
NOT EXACTLY EXPECT SUCH AS
AVOID ALCOHOL AVAILABLE- IS ONE
OF THE FACT. WERE YOU HAVE MORE
BARS AS I CONSIDERED BETTER SO.
HOW IS IT IS THIS THE WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO THE MEASURE. WE
WERE WITH OUR LOCAL HEALTH
JURIST. AS WELL AS AN- YEAH AT.
WE DID MOST OF THIS WORK EARLY
ON. WHEN WE WERE LOOKING AT.
THE PRINT EQUITY METRIC AND- AT-
YOU KNOW HOW WE COULD. DEFINE
THAT MATCH AND SO WE DID WORK
CLOSELY. OUR PART AT THE- LEVEL
TO DETER. WHAT THOUGHT WERE BE
THE BEST I'M- AG. KIND OF-
INDEX THAT WE COULD USE THAT
WOULD CROSS. THE STATE AND
BRINGING THEM. ACCOUNT MANY
FACTORS AND SO I THINK. WE DID
THAT EARLY WORK AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO SHARE SOME OF THAT- I CAN
HAVE OUR EQUITY TEAM SORT OF.
LAY OUT THE REASONS WHY THIS
WAS CHOSEN. AND HAPPY TO GET
BACK TO WITH THAT. THANK YOU
MISS FONG. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- MAYBE YOU CAN- WALK WITH
YOUR SEASON- THE I WANT I GUESS
TALKING TO PUBLIC HEALTH A
DIRECTORS I GUESS FROM MY OWN
WHAT I'M HEARING IS THEY WOULD
LIKE TO. HAVE SOME ABILITY THAT
PLANNED OUT FURTHER OUT IS
THERE A WAY TO PROVIDE THEM
WITH LIKE A- I GO TO A THREE
WEEK OUTLOOK IN TERMS OF
VACCINES- IMMEDIATE UPDATE WHAT
WE'RE RECEIVING AS A STATE I'M
I'M ASSUMING ISN'T HASN'T
CHANGED FROM WEEK TO WEEK MADE
IT'S GOING UP. WHICH IS
POSITIVE BUT IS IT IS IT IS IT
IS THEIR ABILITY TO PROVIDE
SOME LIKE. BASELINE LIKE EVERY
WEEK YOU'RE GOING TO GET AT
LEAST THIS TIME WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO DO THAT- AND WE'LL DO
MORE- NOW WE ARE GETTING BETTER
INFORMATION FROM THE CDC SO
THAT WE CAN- AND AS YOU KNOW
EVER PROBABLY HAVE HEARD WE
HAVE KEPT THAT LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS LEVEL FOR ABOUT
THE PAST SEVERAL WEEKS AND WE
I'M- CONTINUE TO WANT TO GIVE
THEM TWO TO THREE WEEKS OUT AND
TO GIVE THEM A PROJECTION. AS
WE ALL BUILD TOWARDS WHAT WE
THINK IS GOING TO BE A BIG
GRANT BUT I'VE AND VACCINE AND
SO WE WILL BE GETTING THAT OUT
I KNOW THAT THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR SHARED IT WITH
THE LOCAL STEERING COMMITTEE
I'M EARLIER THIS WEEK AND WILL
HELP TO NOT ONLY GIVE THEM SORT
OF TIME BETTER INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT THEY CAN EXPECT IN
THEIR JURISDICTION. BUT ALSO
WHAT THEY CAN EXPECT OVERALL IN
THE STATE COMING IN OVER THE
NEXT THREE SIX EIGHT WEEKS SO
THAT WE HAVE A BETTER PLANNING-
ASSUMPTIONS TO WORK FROM OKAY
SO THAT'S IN THE IT'S IN THE
WORKS I MEAN I JUST I'M THE- A
LOT OF. HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE
TRYING TO HELP EXPECT TO PASS
BUT EXPECTED THE GOING TO RIGHT
SO. IF THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
MISTER LIKE. KERN COUNTY FIFTY
FOUR FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND. BUT
THEY GONNA GET. A. B. SEVEN
THOUSAND DOSES AND UP OFF A
WEEK THEY WERE WANNA. PUT
THINGS IN MY- TWENTY THAT WOULD
BE. GREAT OF MY PLANKS. AND
THAT'S AS YOU GO BE- WOULD BE.
IN TERMS THE DATA- HAS THAT
IMPROVE. I THAT WAS A
CONVERSATION HAD AND- YESTERDAY.
ABOUT A 80% OF THE DAY BEING.
AND THAT. AND EVEN BETTER THAN
THAT. SOME FOLKS WERE.
INTENSELY PUTTING ALL AND
REPORT SOME OF THE- IN TERMS OF
RACE ETHNICITY. SO I THINK WE
WERE PLEASANTLY SURPRISED I
MEAN WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
TRY TO DO EVEN BETTER. BUT
WE'RE AT ABOUT. 80% OF THE DATA
BEING COLLECTED. OKAY AND JUST
AND JUST BE CLEAR AND I FOR
FROM FOR MY PURPOSES WHEN I
LOOK ATTHE DASH. THAT IS ALL
DOES IT. FROM THE CONCLUDE THE
FEDERAL STATE PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE PHARMACIES. IN THE MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL ENTITIES AND
THEN- WHATEVER. AND OF COURSE
ALL THE ALLOCATIONS GOING PER
TO THE COUNTIES THAT THAT'S ALL
IN THIS. IN THE DASHBOARD. I'M
I'LL HAVE TO DOUBLE CHECK THE
FEDERAL PHARMACY PROGRAM IT
WOULD INCLUDE A LONG TERM CARE
PIECE BUT I'M NOT SURE THEY
HAVE A NEW PROGRAM ON THE
FEDERAL PHARMACY SIDE AND I'LL
HAVE TO DOUBLE CHECK TO SEE IF
WE- HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GET THAT
DATA AND PUT IT INTO THE
DASHBOARD. WE'LL GET BACK TO
YOU ON THAT BUT OTHERWISE YES
IT'S ALL OTHER DOSES. OKAY SO
THEN MAYBE LET ME ASK THE
QUESTION RIVERS WHAT WHAT IS
THE DASHBOARD TELL ME AND WHAT
I MEAN WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT DID
THAT WHAT DATE IS IN THE
DASHBOARD THEN IF I'M LOOKING
AT IT. AND I'M SEEING- YOU KNOW
CURRENT ABOUT A HUNDRED NINETY
FOUR THOUSAND- FIVE ONE THREE
THREE DOSES HELLO ANGELES HAS
THREE MILLION AS A WHAT'SIN
THAT WHAT'S IN THAT. THOSE
NUMBERS. WHAT'S INCLUDED I'M AT
WORK. DIFFERENT SPORTS THAT WE
HAVE A- THERE SO WANT TO BE
SURE THE- WERE TEN. ABOUT THE
SAME ONE. IT DOES SHOW. THAT
THAT HAVE BEEN RECEIVED. AND
DOSES AND MANY. BY RESIDENTS
OF- THE PERSON VACCINATED. OKAY
I'M WELL I'M LOOKING AT THE
DASHBOARD IN THE ANALYSIS THE
THAT PICKUP IN NINETEEN DASH.
THAT PROVIDES UP TO WHAT'S
WHAT'S IN THAT DASHBOARD. WHAT
WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT GOES AND
WHAT DATA GOES INTO THAT THOSE
NUMBERS. IT IS THE DATA ABOUT
WHAT HAS BEEN DELIVERED TO YOU
EACH I'M JURISDICTION AND WHAT
HAS BEEN ADMINISTERED BY EACH
JURISDICTION BASED ON THE
RESIDENTS OF THE INDIVIDUAL AND
THAT DATA IS ALL SUBMITTED BY.
THE COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
SECTIONS IS THAT CORRECT. NO
IT'S ACTUALLY SUBMITTED BY
WHOEVER PROVIDES THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THAT AND SO
SOME OF IT IS WHAT'S DELIVERED
WHICH IS IN THE DATA SYSTEM AND
THEN AS WELL I'M VACCINES ARE
ADMINISTERED THAT IS REPORTED.
BACKSEAT OKAY I THINK THAT'S
BECAUSE I THAT I GUESS IT'S A
KIND OF A CONTINUING- CONCERN
IS IT I JUST I GUESS FROM MY
STANDPOINT I JUST WANNA KNOW
HOW MANY IS COMING INTO HOW
MANY DOES THE COMING A KERN
COUNTY AND HOW MANY GETTING MR-
IS GOING TO SAN FRANCISCO HOW
MANY OF THE MEASURE THAT'S WHAT
WE NEED TO KNOW AND THEY WERE
MISSING POTS OR OF. SIXTEEN IN
TERMS OF WHAT'S BEING
DELIVERED- MINISTERED AND
THAT'S PROBLEMATIC FOR US TO
KIND OF PUT ESPECIALLY FOR THE
PUBLIC TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING SO- YEAH AND OUR DATA
IS GETTING BETTER AND BETTER AS
WE TRY TO YOU BRING AND YOU
KNOW LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
M. C. E. IS THAT WE'RE GETTING
DOES SAYS ARE NOW BROKEN OUT BY
COUNTY. SO THAT REALLY CAN. AND
WE SHARE YOUR INTEREST AND I
THINK MANY SHARE THE INTEREST
OF WHAT'S COMING IN EACH COUNTY
AND HOW MANY PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTY ARE GETTING. AND YOU.
GETTING ACTUAL DOES THIS AND SO
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT
AND IF YOU HAVE. SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS ABOUT A COUNTY WE CAN
PROBABLY DO IT A LITTLE DEEPER
DIVE FOR YOU SO THIS BLUE
SHIELD HAVE A ITS OWN DASHBOARD
TO. THAT IS DONE I THINK THAT'S
BORDER ARE YOU SAID YOU
MULTIPLE DASHBOARDS I'M ONLY
I'M ONLY USE THIS ONE SO IS
THERE A THERE'S ANOTHER ONE.
ONE ON THE COBIT NINETEENTH
WEBSITE AND ONE ON AND ONE OF
THEM IS REALLY ABOUT HOW MUCH
INVENTORY PEOPLE HAVE ON SITE-
SO THAT WE CAN BETTER. LOOK AT
WHAT'S BEEN DELIVERED AND WHAT
THEY SAY THEY HAVE ON SITE. SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ALLOCATING TO THE RIGHT
PROVIDERS ON THE GROUND. OKAY I
THINK MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT. WE CAN WORK WITH YOU ON
IN TERMS OF LIKE CLARIFYING
THAT I THINK THAT. CAN BE A
LITTLE CONFUSING AT LEAST FOR
ME IF THERE'S A- IF THERE'S
MULTIPLE DASH. AND PEOPLE
GETTING MULTIPLE. I THINK THAT.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT PROVIDING
THE PUBLIC ACCURATE AND TIMELY
INFORMATION ESPECIALLY ON THE
MAXINE'S AS USUAL. THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT SO- I WOULD VERY MUCH
LIKE- IF YOU COULD PROVIDE AT
LEAST FOR KERN COUNTY BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF OTHER MEMBERS
WANT. TO BREAK IT OUT THAT WAY
IF. YOU COULD TELL ME. HOW MANY
DOSES ARE COMING IN THE CURRENT
AND HOW MANY DOSES ARE BEING
ADMINISTERED TO BE VERY HELPFUL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'LL
FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR OFFICE ON
THE- THANK YOU- ALL OF. THIS
GROUP DID YOU HAVE QUESTIONS.
YES THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND- APOLOGIES- FOR
CATCHING UP TO THE HEARING I
WAS IN A PROBE UP PREPARATIONS
JUST NOW- I WOULD REALLY LIKE
TO. AND AGAIN APOLOGIES OF THIS
HAS BEEN ADDRESSED BUT- I
REALLY WANT TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF VACCINE EQUITY WITH
THE LATINO COMMUNITY LATINO
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND FROM MY
WORKERS HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
ACROSS THE STATE AND-
PARTICULARLY IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WHERE WE HAVE SEEN. A
REAL LACK OF EQUITY WHEN IT
COMES TO VACCINE THAT HAS
CONTINUED TO BE A PART OF HE
CONVERSATION AND- YOU KNOW MANY
OF THE REASONS CONTINUE TO BE
LACK OF A SMARTPHONE LACK OF
INTERNET ACCESS BY A LACK OF
RELIABLE TRANSPORTATION MANY
LATINO ESSENTIAL WORKERS USE
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION TO GET
TO. THE LARGER SITES IN IN A
AND DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LARGER SITES LIKE DODGER
STADIUM MARC ARE CAL STATE LA
WHICH ARE BOTH IN MY COMMUNITY
AND THERE'S BEEN A HUGE
DISCREPANCIES WITH SOME CODES
THAT WERE USED NOT BY THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY BUT OTHER COMMUNITIES
COMING INTO EAST LOS ANGELES
ANY SIDE COMMUNITIES TO GET THE
VACCINE. SO I'M I'M WONDERING
WHAT ARE THE STEPS NECESSARY
THAT WE NEED TO TAKE TO ENSURE
THAT FOLKS THAT HAVE LANGUAGE
BARRIERS LACK OF INTERNET LACK
OF SMARTPHONES LACK RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION WHO USE PUBLIC
TRANSIT. TO BE ABLE TO GET THE
VACCINE. SO I THINK THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF EFFORTS UNDER WAY I
TALKED ABOUT MANY OF THEM- IN
MY- OPENING REMARKS BUT JUST TO
RECAP A LITTLE BIT. I THINK ONE
IS THAT EVERY COUNTY HAS NOW
CREATED A VACCINE EQUITY POUND
PLAN INCLUDING LOS ANGELES AND
IT DOES DEAL WITH THINGS LIKE
TRANSPORTATION. ACCESS BEING
ABLE TO YOU I'M HAVE CLINICS
THAT HAVE OTHER WAYS TO MAKE
APPOINTMENTS SO MY TURN HAS
FEATURES SUCH AS A PHONE NUMBER
YOU CAN CALL- I KNOW L. A.
COUNTY IS WORKING TO SET UP.
MANY MORE CLINICS IN IN
DIFFERENT AREAS SO THAT THEY
HAVE MOBILE CLINICS THEY HAVE
WAYS OF. EXPANDING OUT THERE
REACH I'M AND WE HAVE YOU KNOW
A GREAT DEAL OF WORK BEING DONE
ON OUR REGION EDUCATION THROUGH
OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. THAT COUNTIES
HAVE RECEIVED DOLLARS- FROM DOT
IBM LAB CAPACITY GRANT AS WELL
AS THEIR IMMUNIZATION. GRANT TO
HELP TO PAY FOR THESE. I'M CBO
IS TO HELP TO PAY FOR
TRANSPORTATION AND THINGS LIKE
THAT SO I THINK THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF THINGS UNDER WAY
WE'VE ALSO BEEN. PUTTING ON
SOME MAJOR SITES AND LA IS
INCLUDED IN THAT EFFORT TO TRY
TO REACH OUT AND PROVIDE ACCESS
TO THOSE. TWO POPULATIONS THAT
ARE HARDER TO REACH. I'M TRYING
TO THINK OF GOING THROUGH MY
NOTES TO GET AS MANY OF THE-
ISSUES UNDER WAY I KNOW THAT WE
ARE WORKING WITH PROVIDERS AS
WELL TO OFFER SOME OF THOSE
INCENTIVES AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE. ON GOOD
TRANSPORTATION FOR PEOPLE OR
THAT WE ARE PLACING MOBILE
CLINICS AND THINGS LIKE THAT IN
PLACES WHERE PEOPLE MAY NOT
HAVE- ON THAT GOOD ACCESS
WITHOUT YOU KNOW USING.
MULTIPLE FORMS OF PUBLIC PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION TO GET TO THE
SITE SO WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYBODY HAS
LOCATIONS WITHIN A RADIUS OF-
THESE POPULATION SO THAT
THEY'RE NOT HAVING TO TRAVEL
VERY FAR. HAS WHAT HAS BEEN THE
OF JUST TO FOLLOW UP MISTER
CHAIR THAT'S OKAY- WHAT HAS
BEEN THE REASON WHY WE HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO PARTNER SOONER.
WITH ENTITIES LIKE A LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS- WHICH ARE
TRUSTED CENTERS IN COMMUNITIES
WHERE WE KNOW. THAT ESSENTIAL
WORKERS SEND THEIR CHILDREN'S
TO ESPECIALLY AS WE CONSIDER.
RE OPENING OF SCHOOLS I
REPRESENT L. A. U. S. T. WE
HAVE BEEN IN. CONSTANT
COMMUNICATION IN TERMS OF. HOW
CAN WE GET VACCINES INTO
PEOPLE'S ARMS WHEN ONE THERE IS
ISSUES OF TRUST THERE'S ISSUES
OF TRANSPORTATION ACCESS THAT
CETERA. AND I'M JUST CURIOUS AS
TO WHY WE HAVE NOT LOOKED AT
WHY THE STATE HAS NOT LOOKED AT
OPPORTUNITIES. WHERE THE
COMMUNITY CLINICS OR WITH LOCAL
SCHOOLS TO BE USED AS TRUSTED
CENTERS WHERE OUR COMMUNITY CAN
CAN GO NOT ONLY. GET TESTED BUT
ALSO GET THE VACCINE. SO WE'LL
START WITH THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK IN ONGOING WORK WITH
COMMUNITY CLINICS MANY OF OUR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE
PARTNERED FROM THE GET GO WITH-
THESE CLINICS. I HAD THINK THAT
IS BALANCED BY THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE NOT HAD MUCH IN THE WAY M.
VACCINE- YEAH WE HAVEN'T HAD
THAT MUCH VACCINE AND SO WE'VE
TRIED TO YOU. KNOW MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN GET ENOUGH VACCINE
IN THE HANDS OF PROVIDERS SO
THAT THEY CAN HOLD THESE
CLINICS AND THAT- SO WE'RE JUST
NOW EXPANDING NOT AS WE SEE. AN
INCREASE IN THE VACCINE COMING-
WE GOT THROUGH THE T. P. A. AS
WELL AS BUILDING ON WHAT THE
LOCAL EFFORTS HAVE BEEN WE HAVE
A REAL NETWORK OF THE- AND- THE
COMMUNITY CLINICS ACROSS THE
STATE THAT WILL BE BROUGHT IN.
I'M I THINK THERE ARE I'M CBO'S
AND THERE ARE. NONE IN SOME
JURISDICTIONS AND RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS I
THINK THE AND THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IN THEIR EQUITY
PLANS DEFINITELY RECOGNIZE THAT
YOU KNOW SCHOOLS ARE TRUSTED
SITE FOR VACCINATION AND SO I
THINK WITH MORE OF THESE MOBILE
CLINICS COMING ONLINE I THINK
THAT IS A BIGGER POSSIBILITY.
IN TERMS OF REMEMBER THAT THE
EARLY VACCINES SUCH AS FIZER IS
VERY HARD TO MANAGE- GIVEN THE
COLD CHAIN REQUIREMENTS THEY'VE
JUST LOOSENED SOME OF THAT OUT
EVEN ON THE FIZER SIDE AND SO.
I THINK IT WILL BECOME A LITTLE
BIT EASIER WITH THE MADERA AND
NOW WITH THE CHANGE A VACCINE
TO ADMINISTER THEM IN. MULTIPLE
SITES AND LOCATIONS. I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT- LIVING IN ONE OF
THE COMMUNITIES THAT HAS BEEN.
INCREDIBLY IMPACTED BY COLLUDED
WITH RESIDENTS RECEIVING BEING
POSITIVE WITH COLD ED DYING
FROM COLD ED NOT HAVING ASKS
ACCESS TO THE TESTING CENTERS
THE FACT THAT SEVERAL MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE MYSELF
INCLUDED HAVE CONTINUED TO
ADVOCATE FOR EQUITY. VERY EARLY
ON IN THE PANDEMIC WHEN THEY
CAME TO TESTING WE ALREADY KNEW
THAT. IT WAS NOT EQUITABLE. AND
THEN WHEN THE VACCINE ROLLED
OUT IT WAS EVEN MORE
HIGHLIGHTED DISPROPORTIONATE
WAY IN WHICH- THE VACCINE
ROLLOUT DID NOT WORK AND HAS
NOT WORKED FOR CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES AND- MY
EXPECTATION. IS THAT WE NEED TO
WORK TOGETHER TO ENSURE THAT
YOU UNDERSTAND AND KNOW THE
IMPACT ON THE GROUND IN A WAY
THAT IS REAL PRAGMATIC. THE WAY
THAT IT IMPACTS PEOPLE AND THAT
WE WORK TOGETHER TO ENSURE THAT
EVEN WITH THE MOBILE CLINICS-
THERE'S TIME IN EQUITY INVOLVED
I WILL I WILL I WILL TELL YOU I
WENT TO- A MOBILE CLINIC SITE
IN MY DISTRICT ANY
GOVERNMENTAL. IT WAS ONE OF THE
FAMOUS SITES FOR ONE DAY IT WAS
THERE FOR ONE DAY AND IT WAS
NOT ENOUGH. VACCINES FOR THE
COMMUNITY. AND THERE WERE A
SENIOR CITIZENS THAT WERE
TURNED AWAY SENIOR CITIZENS
THAT HAD TAKEN THE BUS TO GET
THERE THAT ONLY SPOKE SPANISH
THAT NEEDED HELP AND
ASSISTANCE. AND IT WAS A IT WAS
A- DEVASTATING TO SEE. THAT MY
COMMUNITY AND MY ALLEY THOSE
AND ONLY THOSE WERE NOT GETTING
THE HELP SO ONE A ONE DAY
MOBILE SITE. IN A COMMUNITY
LIKE BOYLE HEIGHTS IS NOT
SUFFICIENT AND SO WE NEED A
LARGER PLAN OF DISTRIBUTION. TO
ENSURE THAT. WE'RE NOT TURNING
AWAY OUR ELDERLY COMMUNITY
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T
SIGNED UP ON MY TURN. OUR
COMMUNITIES NEED A DIFFERENT
TYPE OF CARE AND A DIFFERENT
TYPE OF AXIS THAT COMMUNITY
CLINICS CAN BE INCREDIBLY
HELPFUL WITH. AND WE HAVE BEEN
PUSHING AND PUSHING AND IT'S
BEEN A LONGDELAY TO ENSURE
THAT THAT ACTUALLY HAPPENS. AND
SO AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN IN A
IN A ROLL OUT PLAN. I REALLY DO
HOPE THAT YOU CONSIDER OUR
OFFICES IN THE WORK IN THE
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
TELL YOU AND INFORM YOU WHAT IS
NEEDED IN OUR COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE WE ARE SEEN AT. AND
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN AS THE
COUNTIES ARE ALSO INVOLVED IN
THE COUNTIES HAVE A DIFFERENT
PLAN AND COMMUNITY CLINICS HAVE
A DIFFERENT PLAN AND THOSE THAT
HAVE BEEN INVITED TO
PARTICIPATE. AND NOT ALL OF
THEM ARE REALLY IN THE ROLLOUT
PLAN JUST YET AND SO I HOPE
THAT THESE CONVERSATIONS ARE
FRUITFUL AND PROMISING AND
THAT. WE ALL NEED TO WORK
TOGETHER TO ENSURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES WHICH
AGAIN I WILL SAY. HAVE LANGUAGE
AXIS ISSUES. THE INTERNET
ACCESS AT LACKING OF INTERNET
ACCESS LACKING OF A SMARTPHONE
LACKING OF PERSONAL-
TRANSPORTATION AND RELY ON
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION AND THEN
WE TAKE THOSE ISSUES VERY
SERIOUSLY SO THAT PEOPLE ARE
ABLE TO WALK TO A TRUSTED
CENTER IN THEIR OWN
NEIGHBORHOOD CAN BE ABLE TO
VACCINATE EVERYONE IN THE
FAMILY BECAUSE THE LATINO
COMMUNITY LIVES WITHIN MULTI
GENERATIONAL FAMILIES AND ONE
HOUSEHOLD AND THAT'S WHY I
CALLED IT HAS BEEN SUCH A OF AN
IMPACT TOO MANY COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE OF THE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS FRONTLINE WORKERS- THAT
LIVE IN ONE ONE HOUSEHOLD- AND
SO A DIFFERENT PLAN IS NEEDED
WE NEED TO REIMAGINE THE WAY
THAT THE CODE BAXEEN ROLLOUT IS
GOING TO WORKING COMMUNITIES.
THAT DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO GET
INTO A CAR AND GO TO A LARGE
SITE OR DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO A
SMARTPHONE TO GET ON MY TURN
AND I AND I JUST I PLEAD WITH
YOU TO PLEASE UNDERSTAND THAT
IN AND WORK CLOSELY TO ENSURE
THAT ARE CONFINED THAT THE
LATINO COMMUNITY ISN'T LEFT
BEHIND AND THAT WE DON'T
CONTINUE TO DIE A
DISPROPORTIONATE RATES WHICH
HAS BEEN THE CASE PROVEN NOT
ONLY IN CALIFORNIA BUT ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. THANK YOU FOR
THOSE COMMENTS AND WE DO SHARE
A COMMITMENT WITH YOU TO- DO
MORE FOR THESE COMMUNITIES WE
HAVE LOOKED AT TRANSPORTATION
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
COMMUNITY CLINICS AS WE THINK.
THAT THOSE ARE PROBABLY ONE OF
THE KEY AND PASSED AND- PLACES
ON THE GROUND TO LOOK AT- HOW
TO GET THE HARDER TO REACH
POPULATIONS VACCINATED WE- YOU
KNOW IN TERMS OF. INCREASING
VACCINE WE PLAN TO YOU YOU KNOW
REALLY FOCUS ON THOSE IN THAT
AGE PACKED LOWEST H. B. I.
QUARTILE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE GROUPS ARE GETTING-
VACCINATE IT WILL BE YOU KNOW
WITH THAT. A PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
COMMITMENT TO OPEN UP TO ALL
POPULATIONS BY MAY FIRST WE'RE
GOING TO DO AIMED A BIG EFFORT
TO TRY TO FOCUS ON THESE GROUPS
EVEN BEFORE THEN SO THAT. WE DO
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE TO SATURATE
THESE COMMUNITIES WITH MAXINE
I'M AND THE LOCAL EQUITY PLANS
HAVE MANY OF THOSE- THINGS THAT
DRESSED IN TERMS OF ADDITIONAL
WORK WITH CBO'S ADDITIONAL WORK
WITH. AND SOME OF THESE
PARTNERS N THE GROUND SUCH AS
F. Q. H. THESE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT ONLY DOING
OUTREACH BUT WE'RE ACTUALLY
GETTING PEOPLE IN TO GET BACK
SENATE AT AND- WE ARE LOOKING
AT THINGS LIKE FAMILY
VACCINATION AND- I'M REALLY.
TRYING TO REACH OUT AND THINK-
BEYOND SORT OF JUST THE
ELIGIBILITY GROUPS ON HOW CAN
WE I'M HOW CAN PROVIDERS USE
THEIR JUDGMENT AND GETTING SOME
OF THESE FOLKS. VACCINATED-
TOGETHER. AS MISS RICHARDSON
STILL ON THE PANEL. SECRETARY
RICHARDSON. I'M HERE THANK YOU
SECRETARY I REMEMBER THE CALL
THAT WE HAD WITH THE LATINO
CAUCUS THAT YOU WERE A PART OF
AND I WANT TO I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND AGAIN I JUST I
WANT TO JUST REITERATE. THAT
YOUR SUPPORT. IN HIGHLY
IMPACTED HOT ZONES. OUT WITHIN
MY COMMUNITY AND ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO ENSURE
THAT. LATINOS WHO HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
COAL BED. ARE AT YOUR TOP
PRIORITY. TO ENSURE THAT THEY
RECEIVE THE VACCINE NOT ONLY
AND URBAN COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE
BUT IN RURAL COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING FARMWORKERS WHICH I
KNOW THERE'S A NEW ROLLOUT
COMING OUT AND HAS BEEN COMING
OUT. OF THE FOR THEM AS WELL
BUT FAMILY VACCINE. ACCORDING
IS THE ANSWER TO ENSURE THAT
ARE LATINOS DON'T CONTINUE TO
BE DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED.
BY THIS VIRUS AS WE MAKE WAYS
INTO RE OPENING OUR ECONOMY IN
WAYS THAT ARE SAFE. WHILE AT
THE SAME TIME ESSENTIAL WORKERS
CONTINUE TO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
THE VACCINE. DEFINITELY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND TO
MISS FINALES- COMMENTS THAT SHE
MADE DEFINITELY WORKING WITH
OUR- A COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
ARE FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS ARE PUBLIC HOSPITALS
ARE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION FROM A TORTOISE
AND ALL OF OUR- WORKERS
INCLUDING LABOR- DEFINITELY
PARTNER WITH THEM AS A PRIORITY
AND SO. APPRECIATE ALL THAT YOU
HAVE POINTED OUT AND
HIGHLIGHTED- AND WE WILL
DEFINITELY KEEP THAT IS OUR
FOCUS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO
POP WITH MY COLLEAGUES
QUESTIONS JUST SO I UNDERSTAND
THE CLARIFICATION FROM THE
SPINELLI OR THIS COULD BE FROM
THE SECRETARY- IT SOUNDS LIKE
EVERY COUNTY HAS THEIR EQUITY
PLAN- BUT THIS IS THE COUNTY IN
CHARGE OF EXECUTING THAT EQUITY
PLAN WAR IS BLUESHIELD IN
CHARGER WHOSE. WHO'S SOME IN
CHARGE TO ENSURE THAT THAT
EQUITY PLAN GETS. EXECUTED
CIRCA THE LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTION IS SORT OF THE
FOCAL POINT FOR THE LOCAL
EQUITY PLAN BUT WORKING IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE GPA WITH
THE PROVIDERS WITH THE
COMMUNITY AND THE EQUITY PLANS
DO SHOW HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
WORK WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THEY'VE
IDENTIFIED THE KEY PROVIDERS
THAT WOULD BE IN THE NETWORK SO
IT REALLY IS A ACROSS THE
BOARD. AND BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
WORK UNLESS EVERYONE WHO HAS A
PIECE OF IT IS WORKING AND
SWIMMING IN THE SAME DIRECTION.
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
AUTHORITY TO TELL BLUESHIELD OR
KAISER OR CVS OR WALGREENS WHAT
TO DO TO THEIR- I'M SO THAT
COMES THROUGH THE TO BE A
AGREEMENT TO AND SOME OF THE
PERFORMANCE MEASURES THAT ARE
BEING SET UP BY THE TVA TO
ALLOW THEM TO ALLOCATE IN THE
RIGHT PLACES I'M AND SO I THINK
IT WORKS SUCH THAT ALL OF THAT
COMING TOGETHER AND-
ENCOURAGING THEM TO WORK WITH
THE LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTION
ENCOURAGING THEM TO YOU. YEAH
THE WAY THAT THE MY TURN SYSTEM
IS SET UP THEY CAN'T JUST BLOCK
OFF TO THEIR OWN MEMBERS IT IS
ON OPEN CLINICS SO THAT WE CAN
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE ON DO YOU SIGN
UP FOR ANY CLINIC THAT'S IT
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTIONS
OTHER TOOLS BEING INVOKED TO
MAKE THAT WORK I'M BUT I THINK
THE M. ALTERNATELY IT'S HOW YOU
ALLOCATE THE VACCINE AND FOR
THOSE THAT AREN'T WORKING WITH
THE LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTION
EQUITY PLAN. WHO AREN'T
VACCINATING PEOPLE IN THESE
POPULATIONS THEY WERE LASSEN
LAST BACK ALLOCATION OF ACSI
THANK YOU WE WILL BE POSSIBLE
TO DIG INTO ONE OF THE COUNTIES
JUST SO WE HAVE THE MEAN I KNOW
YEAH I KNOW YOU NEEDED TO TALK
BROADLY AROUND FIFTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT COUNTIES PERHAPS. CAN
WE TALK ABOUT ONE PARTICULAR
COUNTY. SURE I DON'T HAVE THE
DETAILS FOR ANY PARTICULAR
COUNTY RIGHT OUT MY HAND BUT
AND WE CAN CERTAINLY. PROVIDE
THAT DO DO YOU HAVE A STAFF
PERSON AVAILABLE WHO COULD TO
BE ONLINE. BUT I DO WANT TO GET
THEM ONLINE RIGHT NOW. IF
THEY'RE AVAILABLE. I'M IS THERE
A PARTICULAR COUNTY THAT YOU'RE
INTERESTED AND WE TALK ABOUT
HOW WE CAN REACH SAMBAR DINO.
AND LET ME CHECK IT PROBABLY
I'M NOT SURE I CAN GET SOMEONE
IN THE NEXT TWO MINUTES BUT- WE
CAN CERTAINLY SHARE ABOUT
EQUITY PLAN WITH YOU I'LL BE
HERE FOR A LITTLE WHILE SO
DON'T HAVE TO BE ON. OKAY WHAT
WE DON'T KNOW JUST KEEP GOING
FOR A LOT OF. I'LL BE CLEAR AS
WELL MISTER. THANK YOU- AND SO-
I NOTICED IS NOW TO POINT SIX
MILLION THAT'S AND- BEEN A
MINISTER. HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN. COMPLETELY VACCINATED.
COMING UP MONDAY DAILY REPORT
FROM TODAY BEING ON ONE SECOND
I WILL TELL YOU THAT NUMBER. SO
COMPLETELY VACCINATED IS FOUR
MILLION FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN THOUSAND SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE WHO HAVE BEEN RECEIVED
BOTH DOSES. OKAY FOR THIS IS
FOUR MILLION PEOPLE ARE. FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION YES. OKAY
YOU CAN THEIR EIGHT POINT EIGHT
MILLION WHO HAVE RECEIVED AT
LEAST ONE DOSE OKAY IT'S A
EIGHT POINT EIGHT MILLION HAVE
CAR WINDOWS. IN IN ROUGHLY DO
WE KNOW HOW MANY ADULTS WE
HAVEN'T CALIFORNIA'S LIKE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. ABOUT
TWENTY SIX MILLION AS OUR
ESTIMATE. GROUP PERFECT. SOUL-
CONSUMING IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS
WILL BE ABLE TO GET ALL A POINT
EIGHT VACCINATED THAT BE BUILT
NEAR TWELVE MILLION VACCINATED
TO LEAVING ABOUT- FOURTEEN
MILLION MORE PEOPLE TO GET
VACCINATED I KNOW SECRETARY
RICHARDSON TALKED ABOUT BEING
ABLE TO DO TWO MILLION- WE DID
TWO MILLION VACCINATIONS LAST
WEEK WITH THE GOAL OF HAVING
FOUR MILLION DOSES PER WEEK DO
YOU DO YOU KNOW WHAT WE WILL BE
ROUGHLY ABLE TO HIT THAT ARE
YOU KNOW LIKE HOW MANY WEEKS
WILL BUILD THE HIT THAT. FOUR
MILLION YEAH THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. I AM I WOULD
IMAGINE THAT IT WOULD BE
SOMETIME IN MAY IN APRIL- EARLY
APRIL WOULD BE OUR AIM BUT
SOMETIMES DEPENDING ON THE
NUMBER OF DOSES THAT WE RECEIVE
IN CALIFORNIA- SO PURSUING THE
NEXT. TWO OR THREE THE NEXT.
THREE TO SIX WEEKS WITH FOR-
YEAH NOT AS ART. SO IT SEEMS AT
THAT PARTICULAR CASE WE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO GET- ALMOST EVERY
ADULT VACCINATED- BY THE END OF
APRIL OR DEFINITELY BY THE END
OF MAY IT LOOKS SOUNDS LIKE.
THAT'S TO ME THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE GET SUPPLY AND- CAN
CONTINUE TO DISTRIBUTE. RIGHT
AND I THINK THERE'D BE A LOT OF
UNKNOWNS THERE WITH THE SUPPLY
BUT IF THAT IF THAT WHAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS SAYING IN
TERMS OF THE DOSES WE CERTAINLY
ARE AIMING TO GET PEOPLE-
VACCINATED BY THE END OF JUNE
I'VE NOT THE END OF MAY BUT IT
WILL DEPEND BUT I THINK
PROBABLY THE END OF JUNE THAT'S
MORE REALISTIC. IN A NEW THING
THAT JUST BECAUSE YOU THINK- AS
OBVIOUSLY THE- AS WE HAVE AS WE
VACCINATE MORE MORE PEOPLE THE-
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE. LEAST
LIKELY TO GET VACCINATED WILL
BE. MORE RIGHT THERE SOME
HESITANCY THERE ARE SOME THINGS
THAT WE HAVE TO OVERCOME AND
WE'RE DOING AN EDUCATION
CAMPAIGN WE'RE DOING A LOT OF
THINGS TO TRY TO. MAKE THAT
HAPPEN BUT- YEAH THAT COULD
TAKE US A LITTLE BIT OF TIME.
GIVEN THE SENSE WHEN CHILDREN
MAY BE ABLE TO GET. VACCINATED
OR WHEN THOSE. TESTS WILL BE
DONE. I THINK THEY'RE JUST
STARTING TRIALS WITH. YOU KNOW
OLDER CHILDREN RIGHT NOW. I AM
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE EARLY
NEXT YEAR BEFORE WE'RE GOING TO
REALLY BE- YEAH. ACCEDING
CHILDREN. THANK YOU. AND- LET'S
SEE IN TERMS OF THE- THAT
EQUITY. I'M JUST I'M JUST GONNA
REMIND THE AUDIENCE TERM AGAIN
WE'RE TRYING WE'RE TRYING TO
HAVE A HEARING IN TO TRY TO BE.
RESPECTFUL OF THAT. AGAIN WE
ARE WITH THIS ONE PERSON
TALKING AT A TIME- THERE'S ONLY
SPEAKING AT THE DíAS STILL BE
TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND
YOU'LL HAVE YOUR TIME. SO- IS
GOING BACK TO THE TO THE HOT
SPOTS- I KNOW THAT THERE WAS
THE- DISCUSSION OF THE INCREASE
TO FOCUS ON CERTAIN EQUITY- ZIP
CODES SO IN A IN A PARTICULAR
ZIP CODE YOU KNOW HOW MANY ZIP
CODES FOR ROUGHLY IDENTIFIED-
ACROSS THE STATE. FOR SORT OF
STANDING INCREASES A
VACCINATION FOR AN INCREASES OF
ACCENTS. HOW MANY ARE IN THE
LOWEST QUARTILE IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE ASKING. I THINK IT'S
ROUGHLY AROUND FIVE HUNDRED.
FIVE HUNDRED TO CODES. IN
INDIGO RAFI OF ROUGHLY THE
PERCENT INCREASE IN THE
VACCINES THAT THEY ALL GOT. IT
WOULD BE SO 80% IS DISTRIBUTED
ACROSS THE BOARD AND THE LAST
20% GOES TO THOSE ZIP CODES.
GOT IT. I KNOW THAT- AS AS I
BAY AREA LEGISLATOR NO THERE'S
CONCERN ABOUT. A LACK OF- BAY
AREA ZIP CODES BEING
REPRESENTED I KNOW THAT WE HAD
REQUESTED THAT CERTAIN CENSUS
TRACTS GET ADDED WAS IT WAS A
REASON THAT- AND I THINK IT WAS
A CONCERN THAT THE ZIP CODES
WERE TOO BIG. ESPECIALLY FOR
BERRY THAT WE HAD A NUMBER OF-
POCKETS OF HOT SPOTS THAT
REALLY WEREN'T SHOWING UP ON
THE ZIP CODE ANALYSIS- AND SO
JUST WANTED TO ASK AGAIN WHY
ZIP CODES WERE CHOSEN VERSUS
CENSUS TRACKS. I'M I THINK ZIP
CODES VOTE ONE FOR BECAUSE OF
OPERAS OPERATIONALIZE ATION
IT'S REALLY HARD TO
OPERATIONALIZE AT THE CENSUS
TRACT LEVEL WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT VACCINATION- AND SO WHAT
WE TRIED TO DO WAS REALLY TO
PINPOINT THAT EXTRA 20% AT
LEAST FOR THE TIME BEING. TO
THOSE THAT CODES THAT ARE MOST
IMPACTED SO THESE ARE THE-
STATEWIDE THE ONES THAT ARE
MOST NEGATIVELY IMPACTED AND
REALLY WANTING TO YOU SEARCH
AND PROVIDE YOU KNOW SOME
SATURATION TO THOSE ZIP CODES
FIRST BEFORE WE SORT OF GO BACK
TO MAYBE A AB. I'M MORE EQUAL
IT WAS THE AND LIKE WE'RE WE'RE
FOCUSING ON THE EQUITY PIECE OF
THIS MANY OF THESE AREAS AND
RURAL CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE
BENEFITTED FROM THE US OR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. I'M IN
SOME OTHER PLACES OTHER THAN LA
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO LIKE THE
FEMALE SITES TO USE SOME OF
THESE BIGGER EVENTS THAT ARE
HAPPENING THAT ARE BRINGING IN
EXTRA DOSES TO THE BAY AREA
THAT ARE BRINGING IN EXTRA
DOSES- IN SOME OTHER LOCATIONS
THAT WERE TRYING TO LEVEL THAT
OUT A LITTLE BIT. AND DO A TIME
LIMIT I THINK I AM FOCUSED ON
TO ADDRESS THE EQUITY IN THESE
WERE MOST IMPACTED
JURISDICTIONS AND- ACROSS THE
STATE. THANK YOU SUIT COULD YOU
DESCRIBE TO ME WHAT WAS SO
DIFFICULT ABOUT OPERATIONALIZE.
IN CENSUS TRACTS. I THINK IT'S
GETTING IT SO I THINK
OPERATIONAL IT IT'S HARD TO
EVEN UP THE ZIP CODE LEVEL TO
OPERATIONALIZE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE NOT ONLY. I'M
GETTING THE VACCINE I THE
RIGHT PLACE TO DO THAT BUT ALSO
GET ATTRACTING PEOPLE. TO COME
TO THOSE SITES- WITHIN THOSE
JURISDICTIONS AND SO HAVING A
KNOCK ON BAXEEN AND I'M NOT FOR
OF A REACH THAT THEY COULD HAVE
THESE CLINICS REALLY BE
WORTHWHILE AND VACCINATE. A
NUMBER F PEOPLE AT THE SAME
TIME BECAUSE AGAIN WITH LIMITED
VACCINE WE ARE TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE PUTTING BACK SEEN IN
PLACES THAT I AND WE CAN USE
THAT AND GET ENOUGH PEOPLE IN
TO BE VACCINATED. OKAY THANK
YOU. SIR SO JUST GO BACK TO THE
20% BY ZIP CODE- IT WOULD YOU
KNOW IF YOU SO IF YOU WERE A
PARTICULAR ZIP CODE WHAT WHAT
PERCENT INCREASE WOULD YOU
ROUGHLY. BE ABLE TO SEE. IF YOU
WERE WILL. WALK YOU THROUGH THE
ALLOCATION FORMULA AND THAT
MIGHT HELP A LITTLE BIT SO.
FIRST OFF WHAT WE'VE TRIED TO
DO WAS ONE WE'RE FOCUSING FOR
THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS ON THOSE
OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY FIVE AND
THE THREE SECTORS THAT ARE BEEN
PRIORITIZE FOOD IN AG EDUCATION
AND EMERGENCY SERVICES AND SO.
WHAT WE DID WAS TAKE A
CALCULATION OF THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT WERE ELIGIBLE- IN
EACH ZIP CODE BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF SIXTY FIVE PLUS YEAR
OLDS. AND THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
EMPLOYED BY THOSE THREE.
INDUSTRY SECTORS THAT BEN
CALCULATES A NUMBER FOR THE ZIP
CODE THE ZIP CODE IS THEN
GROUPED INTO ONE OF THE
QUARTILES AND THEY GOT THAT
PROPORTIONATE SHARE. OF THE
DOSES THAT HAVE 20% OF THAT I
WAS SAYS AND IN EACH OF THOSE
COURT TRIALS SO. THE 80% IS
ADEQUATE TO BELIEVE- EQUALLY
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS BASED ON
THOSE FACTORS NOW WE WILL AT
SOME POINT BE MOVED TO A BIGGER
POPULATION BASE WHICH WILL BE
YOU KNOW. WILL SPREAD THAT I'M
VACCINE OUT EVEN MORE- BASED ON
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE IN EACH I'M
JURISDICTION BUT RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE THE FOCUS WAS ON SIXTY
FIVE PLUS AND WHILE ON B. AND
SECTORS IT WAS TRULY BASED BY
ZIP CODE ON THOSE FORMULAS. GOT
IT SO JUST BASED ON POPULATION
BASED ON THAT SO. SOME SOME ZIP
CODES COULD HAVE GOT MORE
VACCINE JUST BECAUSE THEY HAD
MORE OF THOSE. INDIVIDUALS
LIVING IN THERE'S A CUTS.
CORRECT GOT A OKAY- MISTER.
YEAH GOOD MANAVALA QUESTION FOR
THAT TRIP. SO PART OF THE ISSUE
THE- THE SUPPOSED VERSUS. IS
THAT I KNOW IN MY AREA FOR
EXAMPLE IN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FIFTY ONE IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WE HAVE AN UNDERCOUNT. AND WE
KNEW THAT BECAUSE THESE THESE
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED. COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
THAT ARE ALSO- MAKE STATUS
HOUSEHOLD WITH A LOT OF
UNDOCUMENTED ESSENTIAL WORKERS
AND SO TAKING THAT INTO ACCOUNT
WE KNEW THAT WE WERE GOING TO
HAVE A SHORT. IN OUR CENSUS
COUNT IN FACT ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FIFTY ONE IN NEIGHBORING
DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN. MOST
IMPACTED BY COBIT. UP POSITIVE
CASES AS WELL AS SOME OF THE
LOWEST COUNTED. REGIONS ACROSS
THE STATE SO I WOULD JUST URGE
YOU TO RECONSIDER- HELD THE
DISTRIBUTION IS BEING DONE
BECAUSE SIP CODE ALLOCATION
BASED ON POPULATION IS NOT.
ACTUALLY ACCURATE DATA FOR
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
COUNTED UP AS AS WELL AS THEY
SHOULD BE AND WE TRIED THE AS
VERY HARD AS WE COULD A MEDICAL
BED. AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS WERE ALSO
INCREDIBLY INVOLVED- BUT THERE
IS A DISCREPANCY AND THERE
ISN'T A LARGER DISCREPANCY IN
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES- TO ED AND
MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SOME GALS DISTRICT ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO. OUR OWN
HOUSE- NEIGHBORS WHO DON'T HAVE
A HOME TO BE CONSIDERED UNDER
THAT THE CENSUS COUNT AND WERE
UNDERCOUNTED IN THE OVERALL.
NOT ESTIMATE SO AGAIN I WOULD
JUST URGE YOU TO RECONSIDER AND
REIMAGINE THAT THE NUMBERS THAT
YOU MAY SEE ON PAPER ARE NOT
ACTUALLY REFLECTIVE. OF WHAT'S
GOING ON ON THE GROUND. IN THE
EMPLOYMENT SECTORS WE DID USE
EMPLOYMENT DATA SO THAT HELPS
TO GET OUT SOME OF THOSE
POPULATIONS THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THAT MAY BE- UNDERCOUNTED
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT I MEAN WILL
TAKE THAT BACK. ON THANK YOU
FOR THOSE COMMENTS. GREAT THANK
YOU SO THEN I'M GOING TO GO TO-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA WHO HAVE
BEEN ON WEBEX SO SHE WENT YOU
START SPEAKING YOU'LL COME OFF.
TO JUST THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
IT- THANK YOU THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE HERE TODAY I AM IN A
NEIGHBORING DISTRICT TO MISS
CARILLO ARE HIGHLY IMPACTED
COMMUNITY WHERE WE HAVE HIGH
RATES AND AFFECTIONS HOUSE
RESERVATIONS AND THAT'S AND
WE'VE HAD THE LOWEST RATES OF
VACCINATION ABOUT THEIR AND SO
AS WE LOOK AT EQUITY- YOU KNOW
THIS IS AN AREA THAT CONTINUES
TO BE HARD HIT I'M- A NUMBERS
HAVE IMPROVED SOME BUT WE'RE
STILL IN THE LOW IS VACCINATED.
COMMUNITY MEMBERS HIGHEST RATES
WE ARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS THAT
CAN STAY HOME- WE ARE THOSE MEN
THAT HOUSEHOLDS AS WELL AS YOU
KNOW EVERY SUMMER TO MISS
CORREOS DESCRIPTION OUT THERE
AND SO AS WE ARE LOOKING AT
EQUITY. I GUESS. WHY ARE WE NOT
LOOKING AT EXPANDING THE
ELIGIBILITY WITHIN WITHIN THOSE
EQUITABLE COMMUNITY DONE WITHIN
THOSE 20% YOU KNOW THE FOLKS AT
AGAIN TWENTY OF US BECAUSE I
THINK. THE SIP OF THE THIRD
QUARTER HAVING THEIR REGIONAL
APPROACH IS HELPFUL WE'VE HAD
NINE CITIES WORKING HERE
TOGETHER- THEY'RE ALL YOU KNOW
IN THAT LOWER 25% FOR IT HELLO
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING TOGETHER
IS THAT IT JUST WENT CITY OF
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO
FILL SLOTS AND WE DON'T. WILL
HAVE EXCUSE GOING TO WASTE ON
INTO HAVING SOMETHING A LITTLE
BIT BIGGER HAS BEEN HELPFUL BUT
IF THESE ARE THE HIGHEST ARE
HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES. AND WE
WANNA HELP CONTROL THE
SITUATION THERE WHY ARE WE TO
NOT VACCINATIG COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THERE AND I KNOW WE
HAVE A SUPPLY ISSUE BUT- IF
THESE ARE HOT SPOTS WHY ARE WE
PUTTING. WHY ARE WE PUTTING ANY
SORT OF LIMITS ARE AND NOT JUST
SAYING THIS IS BACK FROM THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. I WHAT. I'LL
DO SAY WE MAKE THOSE VERY. YEAH
WE'RE HAVING THE VERY. TO SEE
HOW WE MIGHT ACCOMPLISH THAT
BEFORE WE OPEN IT UP. TO THE
WHOLE POPULATION. I'M AND SO
MORE TO COME ON THAT WE ARE
SERIOUSLY TAKING. YEAH LOOKING
AT THAT AND UNDERSTAND THAT IF
WE CAN SATURATE THOSE
COMMUNITIES WHERE WE KNOW WE
HAVE THE BIGGEST. IMPACT OF
COVENT. THEN THAT WILL HELP US
ALL AND HELP THOSE. THOSE THAT
ARE. MOST I'M AT RISK OF SEVERE
DISEASE- AND THEN THE LAST
THING I WILL SAY FROM TALKING
ABOUT CENSUS TRACTS AND- US
THAT BECAUSE PRICES ARE JUST
YOU KNOW HOW WE TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE BEING
EQUITABLE. ACROSS THE STATE ARE
OUT THERE AND I THINK THERE'S
THAT'S THAT THAT WE'RE ALL
GOING TO ADVOCATE FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THAT'S WHAT WE
GOT ELECTED TO AYE BUT THEN
THERE'S A SPACE AND HOW DO I%
MAKE SURE I'M STILL BEING FAIR
AND EQUITABLE TO THE REST OF
THE STATE OUT THERE. I THINK WE
NEED TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT
BECOMING TOO NARROW I IT'S IN
MY EXPERIENCE NOT EVEN WHEN I
HAVE THE ZIP CODE AND GET THE
CITY OF CONTENT COMPLETELY
CONTAIN WHAT THE ZIP CODE.
OFTENTIMES IT'S COMMUNITIES OF
INTEREST AND IT'S BIGGER THAN
THAT AND COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE
AND SO. I THIK WE NEED TO BE
CAREFUL AS WE TRY TO IMPROVE ON
OUR METRICS I'M NOT. SAYING
THAT IT'S PERFECT AND THERE'S
SPACE FOR IMPROVEMENTS BUT I
THINK WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL
THAT WE'RE NOT PUTTING UP THE
SITUATION TO FILL OR THAT WE
HAVE. A LOT OF OTHER
INDIVIDUALS- THAT ARE NOT FROM
COMMUNITIES COMING INTO TAKES
LOTS BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T HAD THE
TIME. TO GET OUT THERE OR WILL
YOU KNOW IT'S STILL TO BRIDGE
IT UP WE CAN SIGN UP. ON IN
UNTIL WE CAN SIGN UP FAMILIES
IN COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE
THERE'S GOING TO BE A TRUST
ISSUE. BUT IF I HAVE A FAMILY
COMING INTO A HUSBAND AND A
WIFE IT'S A LOT EASIER TO
CONVINCE THEM TO TAKE THE
VACCINE WHAT I'M HEARING I WAS
LIKE. WELL MY WIFE CAN GET
VACCINATED SONS IS GOING TO
WAIT- EVEN THOUGH I'M ELIGIBLE
OUT THERE AND SO JUST JUST
WANTED TO BE MINDFUL AS WE ARE
DISCUSSING EQUITY ACROSS THE
STATE. OUR THAT WE KEEP. THE
CLOSER THAT'S WHAT IT IS BUT WE
KEEP IT BIG ENOUGH THAT
COMMUNITIES WILL BE ABLE TO USE.
THOSE VACCINES FOR THEIR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. THANK YOU
ONE AMBER. THIS THE VARIOUS.
AND WE- TAKE THEM VERY. THANK
YOU. AND I KNOW I HAVE A STAFF
MEMBER CAROLINE KURTZ TRYING TO
GET ON WITH IT SO SHE CAN TALK
ABOUT MORE SPECIFICS ON THE
EQUITY PLAN. THAT WOULD BE
GREAT. SO SHE SHOULD BE SIGNING
ON ANY MINUTE OKAY- BUT ALL OF
MY QUESTION AND WAIT HOPEFULLY
BY THEN YOU'RE YOU'RE A STAFF
MEMBER WILL BE ON ONLINE- I
GUESS THAT WOULD REQUIRE THE
QUESTION IS JUST A FOLLOW UP ON
MY COLLEAGUES GARCIA'S QUESTION
IS- WHAT WOULD YOU DO THESE
EVENTS BY ZIP CODE I MEAN WE
HADN'T EVENT IN WEST OAKLAND
BECAUSE AT A CHURCH BUT THEY
DISCOVERED THAT OVER HALF THE-
HAVE TO SIGN UP FOR. FROM THE
ZIP CODE AND FRANKLY FROM WELL
OUTSIDE THE ZIP CODE OR EVEN
THE SURROUNDING ZIP CODES. SO
HOW DO YOU ENSURE THAT EVEN IF
YOU'RE HAVING THE EVENT. IN A
PARTICULAR ZIP CODE THAT IT'S
ACTUALLY BENEFITING. THOSE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS IN THE ZIP
CODE YOU'RE REALLY TRYING TO
FOCUS ON I THINK ONE
PARTICULAR. SUGGESTION OR IDEA
THAT YOU REALLY SHOULD THINK
ABOUT IS WHAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
MOM DEL RECOMMENDED IS JUST YOU
KNOW PERHAPS FOR THAT
PARTICULAR EVENT IF YOU'RE
HAVING AN EVENT JUST TO. YOU
KNOW JUST A- THAT. BE MORE OPEN
ABOUT WHO CAN WHO CAN GET
VACCINATED JUST. THE LEVEL OF
TRANSMISSIONACROSS THE BOARD
IN THAT PARTICULAR COMMUNITY
BUT WOULD LIKE TO HEAR SORT OF.
AS AS YOU'RE ROLLING OUT THESE
EVENTS IN THESE. HOT ZIP CODES
HOW DO YOU ENSURE THAT IT'S
ACTUALLY. HITTING THE YOU KNOW
HE CAN DELIVER MORE. SO WHAT
I'M A COUPLE OF- TOOLS THAT WE
HAVE IN PLACE AND THEN MORE TO
COME ONE IS THAT THEY CAN ISSUE
CODES AND SOMETIMES ISSUE CODES
TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHERS WHO
CAN HELP PEOPLE TO GET NAVIGATE
TO THOSE APPOINTMENTS SO WE'RE
SETTING ASIDE POINTS FOR THAT
EXACT POPULATION THAT WE WANT
TO SERVE IN THOSE CLINICS I'M
THERE ARE WAYS TO DO CLOSE
CLINICS AND TO PLACE THE
CLINICS AND- STE EMPLOYMENT
SITES OR COULD BE SCHOOLS COULD
BE DIFFERENT PLACES WHERE. WE
COULD YOU KNOW ATTRACT. PEOPLE
BECAUSE THEY FEEL IT'S ON SAFE
SIDE OR TRUSTED SITE- AND THEN
WE ARE LOOKING AT WAYS TO
CORDON OFF- BY COUNTY OR BY ZIP
CODE SOME OF THAT TIME. CLINICS
AND SO MORE TO COME THERE WE'RE
WORKING WITH OUR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WE HAVE I'M
LOOKING FOR MORE TOOLS AS WE
ALL MOVED TO THE MY TURN SYSTEM
I'M TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
PEOPLE HAVE THE TOOLS OUT THERE
HE AT HAND TO MANAGE THOSE WE
DO HAVE WAYS OF GETTING PEOPLE
ON BOTH SIDES THE WEBSITE SO
USING THE TELEPHONE NUMBERS AND
OTHER WAYS TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WE ARE NOT ONLY PLACING THESE
CLINICS AND A JURISDICTION
WHERE WE WANT BUT WE'RE
ACTUALLY GETTING THE PEOPLE
FROM THOSE COMMUNITIES. INTO
YOU'VE GOT TAX ON IT AT. THANK
YOU JUST TO. LITTLE JUST TO
REITERATE MY MCAULIFFE LA'S.
COMMENTS BEEN DEDUCTED CLINICS
ARE ARE SO. IMPORTANT
ESPECIALLY AS YOU HAVE- NEED TO
REACH THE HARDER TO REACH
COMMUNITY MEMBERS BECAUSE
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS THERE THEY'RE
TRYING TO. GET THEIR MORE
TRUSTED THAN THE LOCAL PHARMACY
THE MORE TRUSTED THAN THEIR
HEALTH PLANS. I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO BE WORKING
THEY THEY NOT ONLY ARE CLINICS
BUT THEY HAVE. STAFF MEMBERS
WHO WORK IN THE COMMUNITY
BECAUSE THEY CONSTANTLY HAVE TO
DO OUTREACH SO IT'S DIFFERENT.
IT'S A DIFFERENT KIND OF
LEVELED OUT FOR EACH THAN ANY
OF THEM YOU KNOW ANY OF THE
INSURANCE PLANS WOULD HAVE I
WOULD HAVE KAISER BLUESHIELD
WHO OBVIOUSLY DO. NOT HAVE OR
HAVE NOT REACHED AFTER IS JUST
IS VERY VERY DIFFERENT-
DIFFERENT LEVEL AND IT'S A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF CLIENTELE AND
SO I THINK IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR YOU ALL TO. ON
FIGURE OUT HOW DO YOU WORK SOME
OF THESE VERY TRUSTED PARTNERS.
NOT JUST MODERN MEDIA POINT OF
VIEW BUT REALLY MAKING SURE
THAT THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS. ARE
GETTING CONTACTED DIRECTLY
BECAUSE THEN BECAUSE THEY HAVE
THEIR THEIR CLIENTELE AND
THEY'RE THEY'RE THE ONES WHO.
AND WE KNOW HOW TO REACH. AND
THE LOCAL EQUITY PLAN DOES TAKE
ZIP CODE BY ZIP CODE IN THOSE
MOST IMPACTED ZIP CODE AND TELL
US WHAT CBO IS THEY'RE WORKING
WITH WHAT PROVIDERS THEY'RE
WORKING WITH TO SERVE EACH
OTHERS IT CODE SO I THINK
THAT'S BEEN YOU KNOW BACK
THINKING AND THAT SORT OF. WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE TO REALLY MAKE
SURE WE HAVE ACCESS IN EACH ZIP
CODE I'M I THINK WILL WILL HELP
US TO GET THERE WE WHICH IS AN
EDWARD I DID NOT FIND ANY GAPS
WILL BE HELPING WITH RESOURCES
TO. MEET THOSE GAPS THANK YOU
WHICH IS A PERFECT SEGUE
HOPEFULLY YOUR STAFF PERSON IS
ON THE SHOWN YEP SHE SAYS SHE
IS ON PERFECT CAROLYN. CAROLYN
YOUR INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND YOU
CAN JUST START TALKING AND. YOU
WILL. MAGICALLY APPEAR ON OUR
SCREEN. THANK CAN ANYONE HEAR
ME WE CAN HEAR YOU YOU HAVEN'T
APPEARED YET BUT WE CAN HEAR
HAVE AS WE DON'T SEE YOU BUT WE
CAN HEAR YOU SO WE CAN LEAST
BEGIN- I THINK COULD BE
HELPFULL WE HAVE TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM L. A. COUNTY
MAYBE YOU COULD JUST WALK US
THROUGH THE THROUGH THE L. A.
COUNTY EQUITY PLANTS WE CAN GET
A BETTER IDEA FROM GRANULARITY
WHAT WHAT IT REALLY SOUNDS LIKE
FOR SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES I MEAN
WE HEAR FROM A HIGH LEVEL WHAT
THE GOALS ARE BUT I THINK- YOU
KNOW WE'RE HEARING I HEAR FROM
MY COLLEAGUES THEY THEY FEEL
LIKE THEY HAVEN'T REALLY FELT
THE IMPACT YES WOULD REALLY.
LIKE TO HEAR FROM YOU SOME OF
THE SPECIFICS AROUND L. A.
COUNTY- INTO JUST TO UNDERSTAND
BETTER HOW IT'S- HOW HOW DO L.
A. COUNTY IS GOING ABOUT
ATTACKING THIS ISSUE. SURE I
HOW MY IN THE SHOWS THAT I'M ON.
BUT CERTAINLY HAPPY TO WALK YOU
THROUGH. THANK YOU. OKAY I AM
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO WALK YOU
LA'S EQUITY PLAN. SO WHAT HAS
BEEN DESCRIBED- IN TERMS OF
LIKE ON THE GROUND ACTUAL WORK
THAT'S TAKING PLACE RIGHT NOW.
IS AND IT'S AN OVERSTATEMENT
AND ENGAGEMENT LOCAL COMMUNITY
AND FAITH BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND PUBLIC HEALTH INITIATIVES
AND- THEY HAVE A- VERY ROBUST
REGIONAL APPROACH WITH REGIONAL
HEALTH OFFICERS THAT ARE
ASSIGNED TO OVERSEE EACH OF
THESE DIFFERENT AREAS- THEY
HAVE MEANINGFUL AND- COLLISIONS
ARE WORKING GROUP'S WITH GROUPS
SUCH. AS THE CENTER FOR HEALTH
EQUITY MATERNAL TOWN OUT OF
THIS ADOLESCENT HEALTH ASTHMA
COALITION- THEN GAUGE WITH A
LARGE NUMBER OF CBS AND FBOS AN
OVER ARCHING VACCINE
WORKGROUPS. INTO SPECIFICALLY
I'M TRYING TO WALK THROUGH EACH
OF THE DIFFERENT BUT GETS ON
THERE ARE THERE IS A VERY
ROBUST COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER
PROGRAM AND RIGHT NOW. AND.
THEY HAVE THE- APPROXIMATELY.
WHO THIS OP REALLY QUICKLY SAID
PARDON. AND THEY HAVE. PARKS
ABOUT AND FIVE HUNDRED
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER THAT
ARE TWENTY TO SERVE THIS
INITIATIVE- WHERE THEY'RE
WORKING AND RIGHT NOW OVER A
SPAN OF THREE HUNDRED CITY
BLOCKS- THERE IS A- DEVELOPED
SOCIAL MEDIA APPROACH. I'M
PUSHING CONTENT TO- FOR BOTH
THE BLACK AND LYFT NEXT
COMMUNITIES AND THERE IS ALSO
AND- BRADBURY IS TOWN HALL Q.
AND A SESSIONS AND THAT OUR
PLANET CONDUCTED ON A REGULAR
BASIS. THEY ALSO DO WEEKLY
PRESS BRIEFINGS THREE TIMES A
WEEK TO SHARE ALL OF THE LATEST
DATA AND SCIENTIFIC INFORMATION
THE VACCINE FACTS ON TO UPDATE
ON THE PROGRESS THAT THE COUNTY
IS DOING. I'M PAID MEDIA AS
ALREADY DISCUSSED IN TERMS OF
THE PLAN AND THEN FAITH BASED
ORGANIZATION OUT REGION
PARTNERSHIP. I'M IS I KEEP MY-
HELLER AND I'M THEIR VACCINE
EQUITY PLAN. WE DO COMMUNICATE
AND PRINTS TO QUITE A BIT
VACCINE NEWSLETTERS THAT ARE
DISSEMINATED TO ALL THE
DIFFERENT PARTNERS AND
COMMUNITY GROUPS ON A BI WEEKLY
BASIS- AS WELL AS YOU KNOW I'M
A NUMBER OF EARNED MEDIA I'M
WITH THE BLACK AND WHITE NEXT
MEDIA OUTLETS. I'M SPECIFICALLY
OUT AND UPDATES ARE SEN
DIRECTLY TO THE BLACK IN
SPANISH LANGUAGE MEDIA OUTLETS
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE WEEK. AND
SO THERE'S A LOT THAT STAND
THERE THERE ARE OTHER AREAS OF
PRIORITY POPULATIONS- SUPPORT
AND GOT. LA IS VERY FOCUSED ON
THOSE THAT ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OF COURSE AND
MIGRANT POPULATION THE
UNDOCUMENTED. THE INCARCERATED
AND DETAINED AS WELL AS THE
TRIBES INDIGENOUS POPULATIONS-
AND THEN I THINK YOU KNOW GIVEN
THE GEOGRAPHY AND I'M L. A.
COUNTY REALLY FOCUSING ON THOSE
THAT ARE GEOGRAPHICALLY
CULTURALLY AND TECHNOLOGICALLY
ISOLATED AS WELL. I AM. SO IN
LOOKING AT AND THEN THERE'S
ALSO A FOCUS ON HEALTHCARE
WORKERS THE DISABLED STATE WITH
EACH OF THESE ELEMENTS AND
WITHIN THAT THE VACCINE EQUITY
PLAN THAT LA HAS AND- PUT
TOGETHER AND PROVIDED TO THE
STATE. I'M REALLY OUTLINES WHAT
THEY'RE ALREADY DOING BUT ALSO.
WHAT ARE THE AREAS IN WHICH AND
THEY COULD SPAN UP ON THOSE ON
ORDER TO FURTHER READ THE
COMMUTE. I THINK YOU'RE GOING
TO GO TO CALL MISTER. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MAY CHAIR CAN YOU CAN
YOU WILL US THROUGH WHAT STATE
FEMA CORDONING COORDINATION
LOOKS LIKE FOR THE MOBILE
CLINICS AND WHO EXACTLY- IS
RUNNING THAT PROGRAM AND HELD
THAT PROGRAM IS BEING
ADMINISTERED ON THE GROUND. I
BELIEVE IT'S CARILLO YES BUT IN
MY CONVERSATIONS WITH- THAT
PLAN IT SEEMS. IT SEEMS LIKE
IT'S THE UCONN'S A CONSTANT
SHUFFLING OF HOW THE PLAN IS
BEING EQUITABLY DISTRIBUTED
ACROSS THE STATE SPECIFICALLY
I'M YOU KNOW I'M ALWAYS OF
COURSE ADVOCATING FOR MY
DISTRICT AND- I'M GLAD THAT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. CRISTINA GARCIA
IS ALSO ON THE LINE WE ARE WE
ARE NEIGHBORS IN IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND WE ARE SEEING
THE DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT OF
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE IN IN MY
EXPERIENCE WITH- ONE CLINIC RUN
BY FEMA AND HELLO YES- IT
WASN'T- NECESSARILY WELL.
PLANNED OR THOUGHT OUT AND SO
PEOPLE WERE TURNED AWAY- AND
AGAIN AS I MENTIONED IN MY
COMMENTS EARLIER SENIOR
CITIZENS WHO TOOK THE BUS WHO
SPOKE SPANISH WHO HAD NO OTHER
AXES WERE TURNED AWAY JUST
BECAUSE OF A LACK OF. PLANNING
AND SO CLEARLY WHAT THAT
DEMONSTRATED TO ME WAS THAT ONE
DAY WAS NOT ENOUGH AND IN MY
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
PERSONNEL ON THE GROUND THEY
AGREED. AND SO HOW IS THAT
INFORMATION BEING- TRACED UP
AND THEN TRICKLE DOWN IN TERMS
OF ACTUAL PLANNING AND HOW IT'S
HOW IT SHOULD WORK SO THAT WE
ARE. NOT TURNING ANYONE AWAY.
IT IS RUN BY HELLO YES WE DO
HELP ON THE GROUND THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH WITH
SOME OF THE CLINICAL EXPERTISE-
BUT WE'D HAVE TO CHECK WITH
THEM I KNOW WE ARE DOING BETTER
WITH COORDINATING WITH OUR
LOCAL PARTNERS ON SOME OF THE
SITES AND IN THE BEGINNING IT
WAS A LITTLE BIT OF A ROCKY
START. BUT WE WILL TAKE BACK TO
CALLAWAY ASKED SORT OF THE LOOK
AT YOUR WEATHER A MOBILE SITE
SHOULD BE MULTIPLE DAYS AND I
THINK WE'RE TRYING TO DO OUR
BEST WITH THE VACCINE
AVAILABLE- AND THERE HAVE BEEN
TIMES WHERE MORE PEOPLE SHOW UP
THEN WE HAVE BAXEEN AVAILABLE
SO. TRYING TO CARVE OUT AND
SOME EXTRA FOR WALK INS AND
OTHER THINGS SO THAT WE DON'T
RUN RUN INTO THAT SITUATION
AGAIN BUT THEY ARE LED BY FEMA.
HELLO YES. SO I GUESS MADE MY
QUESTION OR FOLLOW UP IF I MAY
MISTER CHAIR IS. I WOULD REALLY
LOVE SPECIFICALLY IN IN THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AND IN IN
MY AREA SPECIFICALLY AS I'M
SURE MY COLLEAGUES WHO ARE
NEIGHBORING. DISTRICTS AND HAVE
BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED WANT TO BE A PART OF
THOSE CONVERSATIONS BECAUSE- WE
KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE ON THE
GROUND THESE ARE OUR
COMMUNITIES. THESE ARE- OUR
CONSTITUENTS. AND I GO TO THE
CLINICS I GO TO THE SITES AND I
SEE. WHAT'S WORKING AND WHAT'S
NOT AND I'M NOT SURE ACTUALLY
WHO I CAN BE SPEAKING TO TOOT.
AB PROVIDES INSIGHT. TO HOW IT
CAN FUNCTION BETTER WHICH IS
ULTIMATELY. OUR GOAL HOW DO WE
MAKE THE PROCESS OF EQUITABLE
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION OF WORK.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT AND
CHALLENGING I IMAGINE TO BE IN
SACRAMENTO AND TRYING TO
IMPLEMENT PROCESS SEES ACROSS
THE STATE. BUT WE ARE A PARTNER
WITH THESE ARE OUR COMMUNITIES-
AND I'M STILL UNCLEAR AS TO WHO
MY CONTACT IS. A CALLOW YES
THAT I CAN SPEAK TO AND I'VE
TRIED. WE'VE CALLED WE'VE HAD.
EMAIL EXCHANGES WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS AND- IT SEEMS TO
KIND OF. GO AROUND ABOUT IN
CIRCLES. AND SO I'M I'M CURIOUS
AS TO WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR MY
AREA THAT CAN BE MY MAIN
CONTACT. THAT I CAN HAVE.
CONVERSATIONS WITH AND CREATE A
PLAN THAT'S MORE EQUITABLE IN
TERMS OF LIKE WHAT REALLY IS
GOING ON ON THE GROUND. SO THAT
WE CAN WORK TOGETHER TO ENSURE
THAT AS MANY. AS MANY PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE- WHO LACK. ALL THE
ACCESS THAT I SPOKE ABOUT
EARLIER. HAVE ACCESS TO THE
VACCINE. AND WE CAN CONNECT YOU
WITH CALLAWAY ASKING LORENA
ZERO FROM CALABASAS LEADING THE
EFFORT ON THESE FEMA SITES AND-
HAPPY TO CONNECT YOU WITH HER.
THANK YOU. I'M GONNA MISS
GARCIA. THANK YOU SO WE HAVE
DIFFERENT BUCKETS OF VACCINES
THERE'S THE FEMALE OF BUCKETS
THERE'S STUFF GOING TO THE
COUNTY THEIR STUFF GOING
DIRECTLY TO THE CLINICS AND
I'VE HAD THE LUXURY MAYBE OF
WORKING WITH FOLKS AT DIFFERENT
LEVELS AND THERE'S NOT
UNIFORMITY- ACROSS THE BOARD ON
HOW WE SIGN PEOPLE UP AND SO
WHEN WE FIND SOMETHING THAT
WORKS IT'S NOT BEING REPLICATED
ELSEWHERE. WHAT IS THE ROLE OF
THE STATE IS PLAYING IN HELPING
TO INFORM CLINICS AND COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE YOU KNOW OF
BEST PRACTICES- SO THAT THE WE
ALSO THREE TO ELIMINATE THE
MOTHER CONFUSION THAT THAT
THERE. SOMEWHERE MEAN FOR
ARTISTIC AND EVERYBODY USING MY
TURN INTO THE FUTURE- AND
CONNECTING SO THAT WE HAVE ONE
SOURCE ACROSS THE STATE IT'S
EASY TO EXPLAIN TO THE PUBLIC
ON HOW TO GET AN APPOINTMENT
AND REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
YOU'RE GOING TO GET VACCINATED
BY A FAMOUS I AND- COMMUNITY
CLINIC. HEALTH YEAH THERE
SHOULD BE A ONE STOP SHOPPING
PLACE AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
MOVING TOWARD. I'M WE DO WORK
WITH OUR LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS AND SHARE BEST
PRACTICES WE HAVE CALLS WITH
THEM SEVERAL TIMES A WEEK AND
VACCINE IS ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE ADDRESS AND EVERYONE OF
THOSE CALLS. WE DO HAVE A
PROVIDER TRAINING CALL ON ME
AND THE T. P. A. WILL BE DOING
EVEN MORE WORK AS THEY TAKE ON
THE NETWORK- PROVIDERS I DON'T
KNOW. IF YOU WANT TO STILL ON
IF SHE WANTS TO COMMENT ON THAT
AS WELL. GREAT I THINK CAROLINE
WANTED TO RESPOND IF YOU FORGET
JUST TO JUMP IN AS WELL. THIS.
I'M SORRY THE LAST PART OF THE
QUESTION. I'M SORRY ZERO SIX
ZERO STILL WORLD WANTED TO. AT
THE- BOND I DON'T MORE SO MY
QUESTION. I'M SORRY. MR THIS IS
A FAMILY MEMBER GARCIA- ADD
MORE LAYERS TO MY QUESTION THAT
I CAN CONTINUE TO EXPAND WHILE
WE FIGURE OUT WHO THEY'RE
PERFECT FOR SENATE FOR GRANT.
SO YOU KNOW YOU SO THE GOAL
HERE IS THAT YOU HAVE VERY WHEN
USING MY TERM BUT WE'VE HEARD
FROM COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE. I
HAVE PERSONALLY DEALT WITH IT
THAT MIGHT TURN CREATES
BARRIERS IN THESE COMMUNITIES
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO EQUITY
AND SO FOR EXAMPLE WHEN I'M
TALKING TO A FRUIT VENDOR- AND
WE ARE USING MY TURN TO SIGN
THEM UP AND I. HAVE TO ASK HIM
ABOUT INSURANCE EVEN THOUGH
THAT THEY DON'T GET IT WHAT'S
AND THAT'S THAT'S THE QUESTION
THAT LIKE WE DON'T WANT TO TALK
ANYMORE WE NEED THE VACCINE- OR
YOU KNOW I WE HAVE TO GO
THROUGH MY TURN. AND THERE'S A
LOT OF DIFFERENT QUESTIONS IN
THEIR IN THE MOMENT THAT THERE
LIKE IN THE MIDDLE OF WORKING
BECAUSE MOST OF THE TIME WHEN
WE'RE TARGETING FOLKS ARE ARE
WORKING. BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE THE LUXURY TO BE AT HOME
OR OR WHATEVER CENTRAL WORKERS
OUT THERE. AND SO THEY'RE LIKE
WELL I DON'T HAVE TIME FOR THIS
IS THE WAY TOO LONG ON MY TURN
INTO MY INTERNET BECOME A
BARRIER. FOR OUR EQUITY
COMMUNITIES AS WE'RE TRYING TO
YOU KNOW GET THOSE FOLKS SIGNED
UP AND SO DO WE HAVE. A SYSTEM
TO WORK AROUND AROUND THAT BACK
CAN BE. DONE ACROSS THE STATE.
AND IF NOT CAN I PROVIDE YOU
ONE. IT MAKES. WE WERE
CERTAINLY LIKE TO HEAR YOU OF
IDEA WE ARE ALSO ARE PUTTING IN
PLACE A COMMUNITY NAVIGATOR
PROGRAM BY WHICH PEOPLE CAN
HELP TO SIGN PEOPLE UP EVEN VIA
THE PHONE OR NAVIGATE MORE
QUICKLY THROUGH- THE MY TURN
APPLICATION BUT I'M WE'LL TAKE
THAT BACK IN TERMS OF AND
WHETHER OR NOT WE CAN SKIP SOME
OF THOSE QUESTIONS SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN GET SIGNED UP MORE
EASILY BUT IF THERE ARE OTHER
IDEAS WE ARE CERTAINLY OPEN TO
THEM. MAKING IT TO EXAMPLES WE
WORK WITH THE CLINIC THIS LAST
WEEKEND. NINE TWELVE
ORGANIZATIONS DEVELOP AT
THOUSAND SLOTS ON AND IN THIS.
UNITIES THAT ARE STILL IMPACTED
AND IT WAS GOING TO THE
TRADITIONAL MY TERM PROCESS AND
YOU KNOW WE HAD COULD SET ASIDE
TO WE WERE GUARANTEED SLOTS BUT
WE STILL HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THAT LONG PROCESS- IN IN WE HAD
ABOUT FIFTY PEOPLE WORKING ON
THIS WE HAVE FIFTY COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WHO WERE TRUST THAT OUT
THERE WORKING. AND IT WAS
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO FILL UP AT
THE SITES AND THAT THE SLOTS
AND SO WE PUT IT ON THE
INTERNET AND WE ENDED UP WITH A
SITUATION LIKE YOU HEARD IN
OAKLAND WHERE HALF OF THE FOLKS
ONE UP IN THE COMMUNITY GETTING
THE VACCINES. ON ITS A SEEMS TO
BE COUNTER TO OUR GOALS SAYS
THE WEEK PRIOR WE HAD A
DIFFERENT SYSTEM WHERE WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE FACT THIS QUOTE
WE CREATED A GOOGLE DOCUMENT
WITH SOME BASIC QUESTIONS TO
SIGN PEOPLE UP WE TALK TO THEM
ABOUT DOCUMENTATION THAT THEY
MIGHT NEED TO YOU KNOW TO BE TO
BE PREPARED FOR AND WHAT MIGHT
MIGHT NOT WORK- BUT IT WASN'T
TILL THEY WERE THERE ON SITE.
AND THEIR FOCUS WITH GETTING
THE VACCINE THAT WE DID AND WE
COMPLETED THE MY TURN
APPLICATION THERE ARE INTO ACT
IN AND THAT WAS A FAMOUS LIFE
YOU MIGHT AGREE TO HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF FLEXIBILITY WITH
US- AND WE HAD THREE AT THE END
OF THE DAY. 95% OF THE
CONSTITUENTS THAT CAME TO GET
ONE OF TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
MAXINE'S WAR FROM EITHER WORKED
OR LIVED IN SOUTHEAST L. A.
COUNTY ON OVER 90% OF THEM OR
OR LIGHT AND NEXT OUT THERE-
WHEN YOU WALK WHEN YOU WALKED
IN IT WAS COMMUNITY MEMBERS
EVER STOP BEING. THAT SAME
TRUSTED FOLKS THAT SIGNED THEM
UP FOR THEIR TO TALK TO THEM
AND MAKE SURE THINGS RUN
SMOOTHLY FOR THEM AND ANSWER
QUESTIONS THEY WERE
TROUBLESHOOTING- BUT IT WAS OUR
ABILITY TO HAVE A LOOK AROUND
IN THE BACK AND- THAT ALLOWED
THEM TO GET THEIR TO THEN HAVE
THE PATIENCE TO SIT WITH A
NAVIGATOR TO FINISH THE MY TURN
APPLICATION. THAT WAS THE ONLY
FOCUS AT THAT POINT THEY WERE
THERE THEY WERE THERE TO GET
THE VACCINE SO THEY WERE GOING
TO GO AHEAD AND HAVE PATIENCE
WHAT THIS DEBATE IS THAT
PROCESS OFF. ON AND SO I FEEL
LIKE IT'S MY TURN IS THAT AT
THE BEGINNING WE HAVE TO USE
YOUR SETTING THIS UP FOR
FAILURE SAID BUT NOW I'VE HAD
FIVE DIFFERENT OF THESE POP UPS
AND ONLY ONE HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL AND IT'S BEEN THE.
ONE OR WE HAVE A WORK AROUND TO
BEGIN WITH. OKAY THANK YOU ARE
PRE. THOSE AND WE'LL- THAT BACK.
AND CERTAINLY THAT IS OUR- FOR
COMMUNITY ALLIGATORS. AS TO HOW.
SOME FLEX. AROUND HOW WE GET
PEOPLE INTO THE VACCINATION
SITES FOR THESE COMMUNITIES SO.
WE'LL TAKE THAT BACK AS A BEST
PRACTICE AND SEE IF THERE ARE
OTHER THINGS WE CAN SHARE
ACROSS THE STATE. YEAH I JUST I
MEAN THIS. IS SO IT'S HARD TO
CREATE THEM UNIFORMITY ACROSS
THE COUNTIES- IT IS.
FRUSTRATING WHEN YOU HAVE
COMMUNITY NAVIGATORS HAVING TO
ADJUST EVERY DAY IF IT'S THE
COUNTY OF ITS BE Mà IF IT'S A
CLINIC. TO HOW WE DO THIS AND
SO- YOU KNOW WE TIME IS OF THE
ESSENCE ADHERENCE SO WE COULD
TALK ABOUT WHAT THE BEST EQUITY
METRIC IS BUT WE'LL DO WHATEVER
OF THAT METRIC WHERE YOU SEEN
AS MAKE SURE IF. WE'RE REMOVING
ALL THE BARRIERS POSSIBLE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. THANK YOU.
MISCREANT THANK YOU. MR THREE
ARE YOU DONE. I SHE SAID I
THINK SHE I THINK SHE SAID I
JUST WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF MY CALLING FROM OUT OF THE
SOUTHEAST L. A. COMMUNITIES IN
THAT. IF WE ARE PARTNERING WITH
COMMUNITY CLINICS I WILL GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE COMMUNITY
CLINICS HAVE ACCESS TO THE
EXACT RESIDENTS THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO GET TO. MEDIC CAL
RECIPIENTS LOW INCOME
ESSENTIAL. WORKERS AND ELDERLY
FOLKS THAT. TRADITIONALLY I
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN IMPACTED BY
VARIOUS ISSUES. AND MIGHT TURN
AN ACCESS TO THE INTERNET IS
NOT AVAILABLE TO THEM. SO YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE STAFF LIMITED
STAFF FROM CLINICS FROM
COMMUNITY CLINICS. THAT ARE
TRYING TO DO THE APPLICATIONS
FOR THEM. SO WHAT DOES THAT
LOOK LIKE IT LOOKS LIKE THEY
ARE LITERALLY CALLING THESE
RESIDENTS BY PHONE MAKING THE
APPOINTMENT GOING ONLINE. AND
DOING THE APPOINTMENTS
THEMSELVES FOR THE CONSTITUENTS
THAT THEY SERVE THAT TAKES TIME
IT TAKES RESOURCES IT TAKES
COMPASSION IT TAKES
UNDERSTANDING OF THE LANGUAGE
BARRIERS AND OTHER BARRIERS.
AND SO IT CANNOT BE TURNED
AROUND FROM ONE DAY TO THE NEXT
IN NEEDS A MORE THOUGHTFUL.
THOUGHT OUT PROCESS IN TERMS OF
HOW IT ACTUALLY WORKS FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO REGISTER COMMUNITIES
THAT AGAIN DON'T HAVE
TRADITIONAL AXIS. AND SO WHEN
YOU WHEN WE HAVE A NOTIFICATION
OF LIKE WE'RE GONNA DO A FEMA
SITE. THIS WEEKEND. IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO TURN AROUND SO
QUICKLY. BECAUSE THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE TRYING TO
IMPACT. AND DON'T HAVE THE
ACCESS SO. THE ONE THAT MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER A
GARCIA JUST MENTIONED WE KNOW
WHAT WORKS ON THE GROUND. HELP
WAS REIMAGINE AND RETHINK THIS
FORMULA BECAUSE OUR COMMUNITIES
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET OR SMARTPHONE TO DO
THEIR OWN APPLICATION AN
APPOINTMENT. ON MY TURN IT
TAKES. DIFFERENT INDIVIDUALS TO
CALL AND ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO COME IN THAT THEY'RE
REGISTERED AND THAT WHEN THEY
SHOW UP. THERE ON THE MY TURN
APP IF THAT'S THE CASE IT IF
THEY HAVE TIME TO DO THAT AND
IF THEY DON'T HAVE TIME. THEN
WE NEED TO ENSURE A PROCESS IN
WHICH- FOLKS CAN SHOW UP. AND
BE REGISTERED AT TO GET THE
APPOINTMENT SO THAT YES I AGREE
THE DATA CAN BE COLLECTED
THROUGH MY TURN AS A ONE HOP
STEP. BUT WE JUST NEED A
DIFFERENT PROCESS IN TERMS OF
HOW IT WORKS. IN HOT SOUNDS
THAT HAVE YET TO BE- THAT HAVE
YET TO RECEIVE THE EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE VACCINE SO
I JUST WANT TO ECHO THOSE
SENTIMENTS AND HOPE THAT. YOU
KNOW WE CAN ALL WORK TOGETHER
TO ENSURE THAT. THE PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE EXISTED THUS FAR IN
THE PROCESS THAT HAS EXISTED AS
FAR IS RECOGNIZED AS SOMETHING
THAT MAY NOT WORK AND HAS NOT
WORKED IN CERTAIN COMMUNITIES.
AND THAT WE NEED TO RETHINK A
DIFFERENT APPROACH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THOSE
COMMENTS AND YES THAT IS THE
IDEA BEHIND OUR NAVIGATOR
PROGRAM WE ALSO. PROVIDING
FUNDING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TWO
YOU. INCREASE AND- COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS PRESENT SO
THAT WE CAN REALLY HAVE THOSE
TRUSTED MESSENGERS ON THE
GROUND HELPING TO GET PEOPLE
SIGNED UP. AND I KNOW THERE ARE
SOME INCENTIVES AND SOME
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO COMMUNITY
CLINICS AS THEY- PROVIDE YOU
KNOW. MAY OF THE SERVICES THAT
YOU HAVE OUTLINED AND THE
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD THAT. IT
TAKES TO GET PEOPLE SIGNED UP
AND VACCINATED. SO JUST TO
FOLLOW UP I THINK JUST IN ORDER
FOR MY COLLEAGUES IF THEY WANT
TO KNOW HOW. L. A. COUNTY IS
DOING AND WHO TO WORK WITH TO.
WORK ON SOME OF THE CHANGES IN
THE TERMS OF THE UNDERGROUND
DISTRIBUTION. IS THAT WORKING
GIRL. THAT WORKING WITH YOUR
OFFICE MISS FINELLI OR THE
BETTER OFF WORKING WITH THE
COUNTY. I THINK THAT PART
WASN'T NEARLY AS THE LOCAL ON
THE HEALTH. WHO'S THE EPICENTER
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE
GROUND- BUT IT'S ALSO THE T. P.
A. IN TERMS OF THE PROVIDER
ALLOCATIONS AND YOU KNOW WHERE
THE VACCINE IS GOING AND TERMS
OF THE COMMUNITY CLINICS ON
OTHER SITES BUT THAT IS WE ARE
WE'RE BRINGING THOSE PEOPLE
TOGETHER ON THE GROUND TO MAKE
SURE THAT. THEY'RE WORKING IN
THE SAME WAY AND TO ADDRESS THE
POPULATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS SO I
THINK THE STARTING PLACE IS
PROBABLY THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT AND IF- WE NEED TO
CONNECT YOU WITH THEM OR WE CAN
BE OF ASSISTANCE IN THAT EFFORT
YOU KNOW HAPPY TO DO SO. GREAT
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
MY COLLEAGUES. GREAT HEY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND ALSO
APPRECIATE YOUR- STAFF MEMBER
FOR JUMPING ON SO QUICKLY
QUICKLY- WE'RE GONNA GET READY
TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER. TWO
WHICH IS THE CODE NINETEEN
EXPENDITURE PROPOSAL. I BELIEVE
WE HAVE MISTER BENSON FROM
FINANCE. IT MORNING YES SIR
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE THIS
IS STEVEN BENSON WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE- SO IT IS
YOU TO THE ADMINISTRATION.
PROPOSAL FOR FUNDING COBRA OR-
IN THE BY YEAR SO. I SINCE THE
OF THE PANDA CAL HAS BEEN FROM
RIGHT SO THAT WE READING HELP
MAKE A THE IN ENTRANCE OF
NINETY. AND USED IF UNDER THE
EMERGENCY THAT AND OTHER LAWS
GOVERN PUBLIC HEALTH AMERICA.
IT'S REALLY DRIVING BY CALLAWAY
AND HOW INSURANCE AGE. WHO WITH
LOCAL. WITH THE FOR STATE
USUALLY AND PRIVATE SECTOR
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT. COMMUNITY
RESPONSE. AND AS YOU ARE WELL
AWARE OF THE RESPONSE. YOU HAD
A LOT DIFFERENT AFTER INCLUDE
NH<c.cyan> OTHER PARTS. HOSPITAL MY</c>
SIR STATEWIDE TESTING CONTACT
TRACING. A VARIETY OF NON
CONGREGATE SHELTERING PROGRAMS
AS WELL AS THE PROGRAMS THAT
WERE. DESIGNED TO HELP- SUPPORT
THE MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
AND OF COURSE MOST RECENTLY THE
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION
MINISTRATION EFFORTS THAT WE
JUST YOU KNOW HAD A GREAT
CONVERSATION ABOUT- SO IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REFLECTED
APPROXIMATELY THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS AN ESTIMATED. DIRECT
CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY
RESPONSE COSTS. AN ESTIMATED
GENERAL FUND IMPACT ABOUT
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION. AND NOT JUST THIS LAST
TUESDAY BINANCE RELEASED ITS
MARCH THIS BILL UPDATE AND THEN
UPDATE REFLECTS APPROXIMATELY
FIFTEEN POINT ONE BILLION IN
TOTAL ESTIMATED DIRECT COVERT
NINETEEN BRIDGES HE RESPONSE
COSTS WITH A GENERAL FUND.
MANAGER OF AN IMPACT THAT IS
NOW SITTING AT APPROXIMATELY
ONE POINT NINE BILLION SO
DECREASE OF ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
MILLION SINCE JANUARY IN TERMS
OF GENERAL FUND IMPACT. I MOST
NOTABLY CHANGING SINCE THE
GOVERNOR BUDGET OF CALL IS A
THIS BACKS DISTRIBUTION IS ACT.
WE'VE JUST BEEN TALKING ABOUT-
SO OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW THAT THE
NUMBERS EVERY TIME ABOUT IN
TERMS OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL ARE BASED ON THE
JANUARY. INFORMATION THAT WE
RELEASED WITH THAT WITH THE
PROPOSAL THESE WILL BE UPDATED
AS WE MOVE INTO THE MAYOR
OCCASION TO REFLECT- HAVING OUR
MOST RECENT COST ESTIMATES. ARE
FACTORED INTO THE FRAMEWORK
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSED REDRESSING COVERT
NINETEEN IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
BUT USING GIVEN THE PROPOSAL IS
WHAT POINT IN TIME AS OF
JANUARY THAT'S KIND OF THE
NUMBERS ALL TALK TO. SO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL- AS A
MENTIONED THERE'S ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS OF
ESTIMATED COST. FOR FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. EXCUSE
ME. OF THAT. WE PROPOSE TO PUT
Y. POINT BILL. DIRECTLY INTO
NINE SPECIFIC I FOR PREPARATION
WITH AN INDIVIDUAL. BUDGET
THREE FOUR HUNDRED. R. FOR
ACTIVE. THAT AT THE TIME WERE
IN A REAL TO HOSPITAL MEDICAL
CONTACT OTHER RESPONSIBLE COST
WHERE IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT TO
DETERMINE RECISELY WHICH
AMOUNTS NEEDED TO BE ALLOCATED
TO WHICH DEPARTMENTS. SO THAT
MONEY WAS. LEFT ASIDE IN
ESSENTIALLY TO BE ADMINISTERED
THROUGH THE DRILL PROCESS LIKE
WE HAVE BEEN DOING THROUGH ALL
OF THE CURRENT YEAR. AND THAT
REALLY GETS INTO WHAT WE
PROPOSED TO CONTROL SECTION
ELEVEN POINT NINE TWO BUT I'LL
GET ON JUST A MINUTE BUT THAT%
WOULD BE A MECHANISM THAT WE
WOULD USE TO ADMINISTER THAT.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO GET IT TO
THE RIGHT DEPARTMENTS WHEN IT
IS DETERMINED PRECISELY WHO
NEEDS TO MAKE THE EXPENDITURES.
SO TALKING BRIEFLY ABOUT THE
CONTROL SECTIONS. THERE ARE TWO
OF THEM- LEVIN POINT NINE ONE.
IS SET UP TO HELP FACILITATE A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT- TOOLS TO
HELP US RESPOND TO CRITICAL
NINETEEN RESPONSE AS AS IT
EVOLVES THE FIRST COMPONENT OF
THAT CONTROL SECTION. IS
SPECIFIC TO THE FUNDING THAT I
JUST MENIONED BEING PROPOSED
INDIVIDUAL DEPARTMENT BUDGETS.
THE FIRST. OF THE CONTROL
SECTION WOULD ALLOW US TO EAT
TO DECREASE. ANY OF THOSE ITEMS
APPROPRIATIONS IF IT BECOMES.
WE'RE THAT SOMEBODY
EXPENDITURES NEED TO BE MADE
BECAUSE OF WHATEVER- EVOLVING
SITUATION I THINK OKAY. IT ALSO
WOULD ALLOW US TO TRANSFER%
FUNDING BETWEEN. POSTCODE
NINETEEN SPECIFIC ITEMS OF
PREPARATION SO THAT IF IT
BECOMES APPARENT THAT SAY YOU
KNOW STAFFING CONTRACT FOR
EXAMPLE NEEDS TO BE. EXECUTED
IN THE MINISTRY BY CDPH
INSTAGRAMS ARE VICE VERSA WHICH
GIVES US THE ABILITY TO MOVE
THE FUNDING TO THE ENTITY. THAT
ACTUALLY NEEDS TO MAKE THE
EXPENDITURE. THE SECOND COMPLY.
WAS REALLY PUT IN PLACE.
DISSIPATING WHAT ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL AND PRIVATE FUNDING MAY
BECOME AVAILABLE NOW IT'S
SIMILAR TO THE STREET FRAMEWORK
AND STRUCTURE CONTROL SECTION
TWENTY EIGHT IN TERMS OF THE
CRITERIA THAT NEED TO BE IN
THAT BUT IT WOULD ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
CREATE. A NEW FEDERAL TRUST
FUND ITEMS THE CORPORATION AS
WELL AS AUGMENT EXISTING ONES
SO THAT AS ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDING OR PRIVATE FUNDING
BECOMES AVAILABLE WE COULD GET
THAT MONEY INTO DEPARTMENTS
BUDGETS IN AVAILABLE FOR
EXPENDITURE IN THE QUICKEST WAY
POSSIBLE- WE PROPOSE THAT. WITH
THAT RECOGNITION THAT LARGELY A
FREQUENTLY SOMEBODY'S FEDERAL
FUNDS COME TO US WITH A VERY
SPECIFIC PURPOSES AND SO- BEGAN
USING THE FRAMEWORK OF SECTION
TWENTY EIGHT WHERE WE'RE SAYING
THE FUNDING HAVE TO BE
SPECIFICALLY FOR COVERT
NINETEEN WE HAVE TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH STATE LAW. NOW
THEY NEED TO BE USED FOR YOU
SPECIFICALLY FOR OVER NINETEEN
RESPONSE RECOVERY AND THOSE ARE
KIND OF CRITERIA THAT WOULD BE
AND THEY HAVE TO- IF YOU'LL
ACCEPT THE FUNDS WITHOUT BEING
A TO COMMIT ADDITIONAL STATE.
FUNDING INSTEAD EXPAND THE AND
SO THOSE GREAT. HELP US TO CAN
MAKE SURE IT'S MORE FOR. IN HOW
TO COPE WITH IT IN AND USE A
TWO X. TO MEET EXPENDITURE ON
THE NEEDED. ACTIVE AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE. CONTROL SEXUAL
LEVEL NINE TWO. IS THE SECOND
TIME THAT BRIEFLY. A MINUTE AGO
IT SET UP BASICALLY TO ALLOW
FOR THE CAN. USE OF THE DESERT
RISK EMERGE ARE. THAT CAN.
AFTER JUNE THIRTY OF TWENTY
ONE. AND WAY THAT RELY OR DOES
FOR PROJECT PERSON TO COME. IS
SET UP IN SUCH. WE WILL NO
LONGER HAVE ACCESS TO A FOR
NIGHT. RESPOND AS OF JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY ONE. I WITHOUT.
WHEN SIMILAR WE HAVE A CONTROLS
ELEVEN NINETY. AND AGAIN BIG IS
REAL. IN PLACE THE- BUDGET YOUR
FRAMEWORK TO HELP US TO GET. TO
RESPONSE AT. WE'RE WE DON'T YET
KNOW THE WITH PERSON HOW MY THE
FUNNY NEEDS TO GET. TO SPECIFIC
OR GIVE US ABILITY TO GET THE
FUNDING TO THE RIGHT. WHEN NEED
TO MAKE NEXT. SO THAT'S GOING
TO GO ABOVE- OF THE INDUSTRY
FROM. ALL JUST ADD THE THAT WE
X. THAT WITH ME REVISION WITH
OUR NEXT UPDATE OF. COSTS WE
WILL UP TO. THE SPECIFIC
DOLLARS THAT THAT WOULD THAT
FRAME IN TERMS OF HOW MUCH CAN
PUT INTO THE PARTNER BUDGETS.
AND HOW MUCH WE STILL EXPECT ME
TO MINISTER THAT GENERAL. NOW
I'M GENERAL ON THE. GREAT THANK
YOU HI I FORGOT TO ASK- MISS
FANATIC. IF STILL A THE LINE IF
NOT THAT'S FINE. BRITISH STILL
ON THE LINE. I AM STILL ON THE
LINE GREAT THANK YOU SO I WOULD
LOOKING THE EVE. FROM I GUESS
THE IS THE FEDERAL.
ANTICIPATING BY THE OF APRIL
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN THAT
THE WEEK OF THAT THE WAY ENDING
APRIL FOURTH WE'RE GONNA GET
ONE POINT EIGHT. WILLIAM
VACCINES LIKE THE THOUGHT WAS
AT SOME POINT WE'RE GOING TO BE
GAY. POSTED FOR VACCINES DE. DO
YOU DO YOU KNOW WE CAN
ANTICIPATE THAT I GUESS IS A
THE JOHNSON JOHNSON BACK COME
OR- WHAT WOULD BE THE UP TO IN
THE TO GET TO FOR ME. WHATEVER
THAT UP COULD BE. AND SO THINK
WE'RE EXPECT THAT NUMBER RISE
OVER THE SIXTY WEEKS MAYBE BE.
BEFORE MILLION BY- MAY- AND
THAT WILL. THE G. AND THAT
NUMBER IN. BOTH FIRST IN SECOND-
SAYS. GOT IT SO I THOUGHT I
HEARD EARLY APRIL SO MORE. MADE
GET TO THE MILLION. YEAH I YOU
KNOW IT'S A LITTLE UP THE AIR
WERE HOPING THEY IT'S GOING TO
GROW. IN TO FORMALLY. I'M SO
WAS TO SEE. ABOUT IN EARLY
APRIL. I BUT I DON'T WE'LL
REACH THAT TOLD FOR MANY BY-
EARLY APRIL I THINK THAT'LL-
BUILDING. VERY GOOD OKAY THREE
YOU SO MUCH. SURE WE'RE GOING
TO GO BACK THE- TOP MISTERS.
AND BENSINGER RIGHT. YEAH FOR
QUESTIONS BUT REPRESENT FIRST.
IS DONE VERY GOOD. SO FROM L.
L. THROUGH SORT OF A WHAT AND
ARE SOMEWHERE COMING THROUGH
OKAY. AMONG YOU'RE COMING
THROUGH GREAT. GREAT THANK YOU-
MY COMMENTS TODAY FIRST TALK
AND- CONTROL SECTION A LOT
POINT NINE ONE SPECIFIC TO FOR
CAN OF CONTROLS ALL OF POINT
ONE THAT ALLOWS THE IN THE- TO
SHIFT THE FUNDS BUT BUT FOR CO
NINETY WAS FAR BETWEEN TWELVE
THE- ARE WE THINK IT'S REASON.
TO PROVIDE THE ADMIN. WITH LOTS
OF TO SHIP SPONSOR THE- HOWEVER
WE ARE GOING TO BECAUSE WE FIND
THAT THE SECTION PROVIDE SOME
MORE TO. THAT'D BE DIFFICULT
FOR THE MUCH TO KNOW MUCH FONG
WILL BE USED. OR EVEN WHICH
DEPARTMENTS ULTIMATELY RISKS
THE- AS THE US WHERE NO
LEGISLATIVE NO. WHEN TRANSFER
ARE. WE NEED THE SEX ALSO FOR
TO BE SHIFTED THREE TO THE
GOVERNOR OFFICE IN PLANNING IN
RESEARCH EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES. AND THE ONLY
DEPARTMENT WHOSE RESPONSE HAVE
YET TO BE TO TRY. AS SUCH IF
ONE WAS SHIFTED THESE THE ARE
BE UNCLE TO THE- EXACTLY THE
WOULD BE USE. ACCORDINGLY WE
WRECK MODIFYING THE SEX TO RID
THE ADMIN. TO NOTIFY THE
LEGISLATURE FUNDS ARE BEING
TRANSFERRED. THE SECOND. FROM.
ELEVEN POINT NINE ONE YOU
ALLOWS THE ADMIN TO. RECEIVE
AND- FEDERAL CRIED FARM SOME TO
THE AUTHORITY THE- MINISTRY
ALREADY UNDER CONTROL SECTION
TWENTY EIGHT. MORE RECOMMENDING
REJECTING THIS COMPONENT OF
CONTROL SECTION ELEVEN POINT
NINE ONE AS I REPRESENTS A
SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION OF THE
PRODUCT ALREADY ALREADY
PROVIDED TO THE MINISTRATION
UNDER CONTROL SECTION TWENTY
EIGHT THE PRIMARY DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TWO CONTROL
SECTIONS IS THAT CONTROL
SECTION TWENTY EIGHT. REQUIRES
A NOTIFICATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE. FOR AUGMENTATIONS
UP BOB AS THRESHOLD. ALL RIGHTS
ARE UNDERSTAND OF YOU KNOW AND
PER THE SECOND COMPONENT OF
CONTROLS ONE POINT NOW ONE IN
ORDER TO ACT THE PROCESS OF THE-
FEDERAL OPEN FARMS TO DEPART-
WE NOTE CAN SECTION EIGHT IT
HAVE THAT NOTE OR THAT I DON'T.
ON CAN BE EXPERT AND IN FACT
ALLEGE HOW EXTRA THAT ON
SEVERAL DIFFERENT OCCASIONS
AFTER OF THE MINISTER OF
VICIOUS REALITY FUNDS CORPORATE
RESPONSE SO WE THAT THE EXIST
CONTROL SECTION TWENTY EIGHT
ALREADY PER THE ADMINISTRATION
ENOUGH MY AND PROVIDE MORE
OVERSIGHT. WITH RESPECT TO IT
WOULD RESPECT TO CONTROL
SECTIONAL WE NINE TWO WOULD
ALLOW THE ADMIN. TO CONTINUE TO
USE THE- TRIO OF. BY TO ARE YOU
FUNDS IN OUR BOB HONG KONG.
NINETY THAT THE EXISTING
FRAMEWORK THAT PROVIDES THE
ADMINISTRATION EMERGENCY
SPENDING AUTHORITIES REALLY
LACKS SUFFICIENT CHECKS AND
BALANCES AND DOESN'T PROVIDE
THE LEGISLATURE WITH SUFFICIENT
ABILITY TO OVERSEE. OUR
EMERGENCY EXPENDITURES AND SUCH
WERE RECOMMENDING A REFORM OF
EMERGENCY SPENDING AUTHORITIES
THESE REFORMS REPLY NOT ONLY TO
THE COMMON NINETEEN PANDEMICS
BUT TO EMERGENCIES MORE
BROADLY. AND SPECIFICALLY WHAT
WE'RE RECOMMENDING IS THAT ALL
EMERGENCY AUGMENTATIONS BE
PROVIDED THROUGH INJURY ALL OF
THIS WOULD ENSURE THAT ALL
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS ARE
SUBJECT TO THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS AND CARRIED OUT
THE SAME WAY UNDER CURRENT LAW
THERE DIFFERENT EMERGENCY-
SPENDING AUTHORITIES THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL USE.
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT WHICH
WOULD ALLOW THE ADMINISTRATION
TO OPT PROVIDE FUNDS
DEPARTMENTS WITH NO LEGISLATIVE.
NOTIFICATION OR OVERSIGHT. ON
THIS. CHANGE THAT RECKONED IS
THE ONE TO ESTADO AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE AND THEN MOUNT-
IN THE- THIS WOULD GIVE THE
LEDGER. THE ABILITY TO HAVE IN
AND THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING AND
THEY'LL FOR SPENDING I WOULD
HOME. THE CHANCE THAT EMERGENCY
SPENDING ULTIMATELY UNDERMINES
THE STATE BUDGET STRUCTURE OR
CONDITION. WE'RE ALSO
RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ON REQUIRE THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PROVIDE
ADVANCE NOTIFICATION WHEN IT
WANTS TO PUT ADDITIONAL FUNDS
INTO A THREE HOUR. SO IN SOME
YEARS B. ADMINISTRATION MIGHT
NEED TO SPEND MORE ON
EMERGENCIES THAN WAS BUDGETED
WITH ANDREA AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE YEAR AND SO TO ENSURE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE IS PART OF THIS
DECISION. WE'D RECOMMEND
REQUIRING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROVIDE ADVANCE
NOTIFICATION FOR JAIL BC THIS
ADVANCE NOTIFICATION COULD BE
STRUCTURE BASED ON VARIOUS
FACTORS FOR EXAMPLE THE
LEGISLATURE CURRENT. ESTABLISH
SHORTER NOTIFICATION PERIODS OR
SMALLER TRANSFERS THAT ARE TIED
TO ONGOING EMERGENCIES FOR
EXAMPLE- REQUIRING SEVENTY TWO
HOUR NOTIFICATION WE THINK A
SHORTER NOTIFICATION PERIOD-
FOR THIS TYPE OF TRANSFER OF
THE APPROPRIATE. BECAUSE THE
AMOUNT BEING TRANSFERRED WITH
THE SMALL EMERGENCY WOULD BE
AREN'T GOING AND THEREFORE THEY
EXPENDITURE LIKELY MORE
PRESSING NEED. AND IT WOULD BE
ACCOMPANIED BY SUFFICIENT
DETAILS TO ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE. TO- DO AN
EXPEDITED REVIEW. THE PROPOSAL.
FOR HOWEVER FOR LONG LARGER
TRAIN WE RECOMMEND REQUIRE A
LONGER TIMES A IS VERY OR FORTY
DAYS- THIS WOULD BE- PUTTING
PLACE TO ALLOW THE LARGEST-
GREATER TRYING TO CONSIDER IT
AND I TO DO OVERSIGHT
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS- BRINGING
TOGETHER AN OVERSIGHT HEARING
TO CONSIDER WHETHER OR NOT. THE
TRANSFER IS APPROPRIATE.
HOWEVER WE CONTINUE WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDED THE ADMINISTRATION THE
ABILITY TO WAIVE THE
NOTIFICATION- REQUIREMENT AND
URGENT SIR THE CIRCUMSTANCES-
IN THIS CIRCUMSTANCE IT WOULD
BE UP TO THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT TO APPROVE THE
WAY BURKE AND ONCE THE WAIVER
WAS APPROVED THE- EMERGENCY
TRANSFER INDUSTRY A LOT COULD
TAKE PLACE IMMEDIATELY. OR UPON
WHATEVER SHORTER TIME THE JAIL
B. C. APPROVED. WE ARE
RECOMMEND REQUIRING MORE
REPORTING ON EMERGENCY-
SPENDING AND ALLOCATIONS FROM
REAL HARM I DO WANT TO NOTE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
PROVIDED THE LEGISLATURE WITH
INFORMATION ON EMERGENCY
STANDING AND IN FACT MORE
INFORMATION THAN IS CURRENTLY
REQUIRED BY STATUTE. DESPITE
THIS FACT DESPITE THE FACT THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS REALLY
GONE ABOVE THE REQUIREMENTS OF
STATUTE WE STILL THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS MORE
INFORMATION TO BE ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY CONDUCT OVERSIGHT.
ON PASSAGE WHAT WE'RE
RECOMMENDING IS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRED THE
ADMINISTRATION TO NOTIFY IT
WHEN. ALLOCATIONS FROM DARIO
ARE BEING MADE TO DEPARTMENTS-
THIS WOULD TAKE PLACE AT THE
TIME OF THE ALLOCATION IS
TAKING PLACE. AND THE
NOTIFICATION WOULD INCLUDE
DETAILED INFORMATION ON HOW THE
FUNDS ARE ACTUALLY GONNA BE
YEARS. WE ALSO RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRE MONTHLY
REPORTS ON EMERGENCY SPENDING.
THIS WOULD BE AN ONGOING
REPORTING REQUIREMENT THAT
WOULD APPLY TO ALL EMERGENCIES
AND THE MONTHLY REPORT WOULD
INCLUDE ALL PLANNED AN ACTUAL
EMERGENCY SPENDING BY STATE AT.
LEAST INCLUDING EXPENDITURES OF
FUNDS FROM THE TRIO OF FEDERAL
FUNDS PRIVATE FUNDS AS WELL AS
EXPENDITURES OF FUNDS BUDGETED
FOR EMERGENCY RESPONSE FOR ONES
THAT ARE BEING REDIRECTED- FROM
ELSEWHERE IN THE STATE BUDGET
TOWARDS EMERGENCY RESPONSE. R.
AS WELL AS WELL AS SPECIFIC
INFORMATION ON HOW THE FUNDS
ARE GOING TO BE IS ARM. SO THE
LEGISLATURE WORK TO IMPLEMENT
THE REFORMS I OUTLINED ABOVE WE
THINK THAT IT COULD BE
APPROPRIATE TO APPROVED.
CONTROLS ELEVEN POINT ZERO THE
ADMIN. TO YEARS ALL THE RULE. I
JUST THIS- THROUGH THE BUDGET
YEAR PROGRAM NINETEEN HOWEVER
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT- YOU
GREATER CAN OVER THE LEVEL OF
NAY IT'S- IN ITS- WHAT. COULD
BRIDGE CONTROL SUCH ELEVEN NINE
TWO AND CREATE A BUDGET CONTROL
SECTION. SPECIFIC MICROBE
NINETEEN EXTENDED. ARE THIS
CONTROL SUCH. RUSSIFIED THE
TOTAL AMOUNT OF THE FOR COVERT
NOW EXTENDED IN THE BUDGET. AND
IN ACROSS TO REQUIRE THE LEAD
BEING. BEFORE MONEY IS ALEC
FROM CONTROLS TO THE PARTNER.
WE WILL THAT THE AMOUNT SPENT
ON WHO NINETEEN IN THIS CASE
COULD ONLY BE INCREASED WITH AN
AMENDMENT TO THE BUDGET ACT. SO
AT THIS POINT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS OR OTHER
QUESTIONS LEGISLATURE. GREAT
THANK YOU- MISS MISTER
SODERBERG JUST- SO FISHY YOUR
LAST COMMENT BECAUSE I DIDN'T
SEE THAT IN THERE- BECAUSE WE
WHICH I THINK RIO ON- IS AN
EFFECTIVE TOOL FOR EMERGENCIES
BUT I DON'T THINK WE EVER
ANTICIPATED AN EMERGENCY THAT
WAS GOING TO TOUCH EVERY FACET
OF THE STATE AND- COULD BE IT
COULD BE USED TO JUSTIFY
FRANKLY ANY EXPENDITURE IN THE
STATE BUDGET- FOR WELL OVER A
YEAR NOW. SO ON. BASED ON THAT
CONCERN I THINK WHAT WOULD YOU
DID YOU DID YOU LOOK AT-
ACTUALLY. DOING A REGULAR
SUNSET OF DRILL LAW SAYING
INSTEAD OF PRE AUTHORIZING IT
FOR JUNE JUST MAYBE AUTHORIZING
A FOR EVERY THREE MONTHS OR
MORE SO SPECIFIC PERIOD- ORDER
OR DID YOU. PREFER YOUR
RECOMMENDATION AROUND BUDGET
CONTROL SECTION VERSUS
SOMETHING THAT WOULD NATURALLY
ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE TO RE
AUTHORIZE- THE- CONTROL. FORTY
IT. WOULD ON THAT WOULD HAVE BE
AN OPTION AVAILABLE TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN OUR
RECOMMENDATION WE ENVISIONED
APPROVING OUR CONTROL SECTION
ELEVEN POINT NINE TWO WHICH
WOULD AUTHORIZE IT FOR THE
ENTIRE BUDGET YEAR BUT THERE'S
NO REASON THAT TH LEGISLATURE
COULDN'T MODIFY THAT AND
AUTHORIZE IT FOR A SHORTER
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY AN OPTION THAT WOULD
BE AVAILABLE. IS THERE ARE PROS
AND CONS TO DOING OF WHAT WERE
THE OTHER FROM AND WHAT WHAT'S
WHAT'S THAT WE WOULD BE THE PRO
GOING FOR THE BUDGET CONTROL
SECTION. THE PRO OF- IT ON A
SHORTER TIME. IT ABOUT WOULD.
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE WITH
NATURAL POINTS AWAY IN. ON THE-
THE POTENTIAL CON OF THAT WOULD
BE IF THE SECTION EXPIRED AT
ANY POINT IN TIME WHERE IS
DIFFICULT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO ACT ON IT- IT COULD DELAY
THE ABILITY OF THE FUNDS TO BE
AVAILABLE. BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING OBVIOUSLY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD KNOW IN
ADVANCE AND SO ARE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD PLANT PLAN
AROUND THAT FOR EXAMPLE YOU'D
WANT TO ENSURE THAT THE-
AUTHORITY TO- USE TRIO IT
DIDN'T EXPIRE WHILE THE
LEGISLATURE WAS SAY OUT OF
SESSION AND- MAKE IT DIFFICULT
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO RE
AUTHORIZE IT. BUT THERE COULD
BE WAYS. TO WORK OR TO WORK
AROUND THAT. WE'LL SEE FOR THE
DID THE YEAR WE KNOW WE AND SO-
SEPTEMBER. SO WE COULD. HOW
AUTHORS IN THE BUDGET GOING TO
HEALTH FIFTEENTH. AND THEN
SEEING WHAT. SEE WHAT HAPPENS
AFTER THAT. THAT WOULD
ABSOLUTELY- THAT THAT
ABSOLUTELY. THAT COULD NOT WORK
WELL FOR THE LEGISLATURE GREAT
GO GO BACK TO MISTER BENSON-
COULD COULD YOU- LET US KNOW
WHY YOU CHOSE JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO FOR CONTROL
SECTION ELEVEN DOT NINE TWO. I
DO ANTICIPATE THAT WE'RE STILL
GOING TO BE IN A STATE OF
EMERGENCY THE POINT. I THINK
PART OF THE CHALLENGE THERE IS
I DON'T KNOW IF ANYBODY HAS A
REAL FIRM GRASP ON WINDY
EMERGENCY WILL AND CERTAINLY
BACK WHEN DECEMBER. DECEMBER
WHEN THE BUDGET WAS BEING PUT
TOGETHER IN PROPOSED THERE WAS
EVEN LESS INFORMATION AVAILABLE
TO TRY AND MAKE. AN EDUCATED
ESTIMATE ON THAT SO OUR THOUGHT
WAS TO EXTEND IT THROUGH THE
BUDGET YEAR I THINK WE'RE
CERTAINLY OPEN TO AND
RECOGNIZING THAT OUR PROPOSALS
HAVE A STARTING POINT WE'RE
GOING TO BE GIVING UPDATES IN
THE REVISION. WILL HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE BEST
WAY TO HANDLE THAT I THINK OUR
PRIMARY CONCERN. CONCOURSE IS
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO RESPOND IMMEDIATELY
IN THE IN THE SPECIFIC
SITUATIONS WHERE IMMEDIATE
RESPONSE IS NECESSARY I THINK.
WHAT WE WHAT YOU KNOW I HOPE
FOLKS RECOGNIZING IS THAT WHEN
WE HAD OPPORTUNITIES TO BRING
ISSUES LIKE. THE RECENT- RE
OPENINGS SAFE YOU KNOW WE THAT
WAS DONE THROUGH EARLY ACTION
AS OPPOSED TO JUST SOMETHING
DOWN THREE THREE OH SO WHEN
THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES TO DO
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO GET
DONE QUICKLY. BUT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY NEED TO BE DONE
IMMEDIATELY WE TRY AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN USE THOSE
APPROPRIATE CHANNELS. I WOULD
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT IN
CASES WHERE SOMETHING DOES NEED
TO GET DONE IMMEDIATELY THE
FLEXIBILITY IS THERE TO DO THAT
SO AS LONG AS- BACKS ACCOUNTED
FOR THAT I THINK WERE YOU
CERTAINLY HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING
HOW TO DO IT. I ALSO WANT TO
JUST INCREASE ELIASSON ALSO
MEANT THAT. THE MINISTRATION
HAS BEEN PROVIDING. I REGULAR
UPDATES. AND INFORMATION AND
JUST YOU KNOW LOT OF SNOW THAT
WE IN. TO CONTINUE TO DO THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING A- AND EVERY
TWO MONTHS. GOOD OF OUR UPDATES
LOOK AT TO PROVIDE UPDATES THAT
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE-
LEGISLATURE TO C. WERE RAT WAS
KIND OF ONE TIME. INS AND ALSO
JULIAN ON. INFORMATION IT'S
THAT'S AVAILABLE WITH THOSE
UPDATES. THANK YOU COULD YOU
ALSO ADDRESS I THINK ALEJO'S
CONCERNS REGARDING THE- LACK OF
DETAILS AS WELL AS THE LACK OF
LEGISLATIVE NOTIFICATION IN THE
PROPOSAL. INFRASPECIFIC THE
LACK OF DETAILS WHERE THERE IS
THIS YOUR FIRST IT DIFFICULT
PREPARATIONS TO A LOT OF
DEPARTMENTS- ISN'T NOT NOT VERY
MUCH DETAIL FRANKLY VERY LITTLE
RESTRICTION. AND THEN I GUESS
THERE WERE- BUCKETS OF. MONEY
OR LABRADOR THERE WERE BUCKETS
OF MONEY GOING TO CERTAIN
DEPARTMENTS THAT THE L. A. O.
NOTICED THAT THERE WEREN'T ANY
SPECIFIC ROLE FOR THOSE
DEPARTMENTS IT WAS UNCLEAR WHAT.
WHAT THE FUNDING WAS FOR. YES I
THINK WHAT- MISTER SORT BURKE
WAS REFERRING TO IS IN CONTROL
SECTION ELEVEN POINT NINE ONE
THERE ARE THREE DEPARTMENTS
LISTED ON OUR LIST OF
DEPARTMENTS WERE FUNDING COULD
BE TRANSFERRED INTO THAT DO NOT
HAVE A SPECIFIC APPROPRIATION
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET SO THAT
IT'S NOT THAT THEY HAVE A POT
OF MONEY AND WE HAVEN'T IN FIVE
WORDS FOR. ITS THAT THERE IS NO
PART OF MONEY AND SO I THINK
WHAT MR SERVERS TRYING TO
REFERENCES THAT SAY WE NEED TO
TRANSFER MONEY FROM CDPH TWO OH
YES- HIS BIGGEST POINT WAS
RIGHT NOW THERE'S NO PROPOSED
EXPENDITURE- PRO YES SO WHAT
THE MONEY WOULD BE SPENT ON
WHEN IT'S TRANSFERRED OVER YES
IS WHERE HE FELT IT WAS
UNCERTAINTY. OUR PERSPECTIVE IS
THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED IN THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL THE ACTIVITIES
THAT EACH OF THOSE DEPARTMENTS
WILL BE USING THE FUNDING FOR
SO FOR EXAMPLE- YOU D. G. S.
THEIR THEIR AMOUNT THAT'S IN
THE PROPOSAL TALKS ABOUT
SPECIFIC HOTELLING PROGRAMS
LIKE THE HOTEL STRUCTURE WORKER
PROGRAM. IF FOR SOME REASON WE
NEED TO TRANSFER MONEY BACK IN
BETTER PREPARATION TO DIFFERENT
APARTMENT IT WILL BE BECAUSE
THEY'RE DOING THE SAME ACTIVITY
BUT THE EXPENDITURE NEEDS TO
GET MADE BY A DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENT SAME WOULD APPLY FOR
WHEN I WAS A C. P. H. THEIR
SPECIFIC AMOUNTS OF PROPOSED
FOR CITY PH THAT ARE RELATED TO
STAFFING. WORK SEARCH AND GO AS
WE UPDATE LIKELY IT WILL
INCLUDE STAFFING FOR
VACCINATION VACCINATION SITES
IF WE'RE GOING TO MOVE MONEY.
PROGRADE FOR THAT DEPARTMENT IT
WOULD BE TO DO THE SAME
ACTIVITY BUT IN RECOGNITION
THAT A DIFFERENT APARTMENT. IS
GOING TO BE MAKING THE
EXPENDITURE SO. YOU WOULD KNOW
WHAT IS TO BE SPENT ON BECAUSE
WE WOULD STILL. ON SAME ACTIVE.
IT JUST IT DIRECT.THAT IT
BACKS. MAY NEED BE MADE BY INTO.
THAT DOES NOT WORK ON. I'M I
THINK I THINK IT HAS A THINK
THERE STILL- THE LACK OF DETAIL
REGARDING THE ONE POINT FOUR
LEARN- JOINT DOLLAR EXPENDITURE
I THINK IT'S DIFFICULT TO.
PROVED THAT KIND OF
APPROPRIATION- GOING INTO A
YEAR WHERE WE HOPE THAT WE WILL
BE. HOPEFULLY WE HAVE BEEN DOWN
A PANDEMIC OR YOU KNOW COMING
OUT OF THE PANDEMIC SO ON. I
THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO HAVE
MORE DISCUSSION YOU KNOW IN MAY
REGARDING THAT FINAL NUMBER I
THINK WE ARE GOING TO NEED MORE
SPECIFIC DETAIL. AND- I DON'T
THINK THAT WE CAN HAVE
SUPPORTED AT LEAST IN THIS
COMMITTEE- ON THE JUNE
THIRTIETH THE DATE IN SELL
EITHER- I THINK I WOULD URGE
THE ADMINISTRATION TO TAKE A
LOOK AT EITHER- A SHORTER TIME
FRAME. WHERE THE AVAILABILITY
TO RENEW OR MOVING TOWARDS WHAT
THE L. L. SUGGEST TO WHICH IS
MORE OF A BUNCH OF CONTROL
SECTION. ROSS SO ANY OTHER PLEA
THE QUESTION MARK COLLEGE.
MISTER BONDAGE BROKE SO I THINK
WE AGREE WITH YOU SO THE
SPECIFIC YOU HAVEN'T FOR OF YOU
ARE WILL PREPARED IN THE FOR
THE BY I THINK THAT OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCE RECOVERED WAS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN ANSWER THESE
RESTAURANTS ARE BASED ON NEEDED
LIKE HOSPITAL MEDICAL SURGEON
CERTAINLY NEED KNOWLEDGE THAT
IN MAY REVISION WE'RE GOING TO
THE UNIVERSITY BE ESTIMATED
ACTIVITIES AND COSTS FOR ALL OF
THOSE AND A BIT OF IT IS WE
WOULD MEAN WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ANTICIPATE HAVING CAN YOU CAN
CONVERSATIONS ON- WHAT SPECIFIC
ACTIVITIES. AND THEREFORE ARE
SEPARATELY BOTH THOSE
ACTIVITIES AND I AGREE I
APPRECIATE THAT KNOWLEDGE MAY I
JUST WOULD URGE YOU- GIVEN THE
CHANGING NATURE OF THE
PANDEMIC- THERE'S GOING TO NEED
TO BE GREATER LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT AND MORE LEGISLATIVE
CONTROL OVER THE EXPENDITURES
AND SO- I REALLY WOULD URGE
THAT THAT FEEDBACK TO. IN. THE
MAY REVISED PROPOSAL. THANK YOU.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO TO HANDLE
THREE IS AN ON FEDERAL FUNDS
FROM THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
RESCUE PLAN AMOUNTS BUT I EVERY
WHO'S SPEAKING OF THE COULD
PLEASE MUTE ONLINE. WE WILL NOW
GO- THIS GOING AHEAD WITH LEO.
THANK YOU MISTER SHE CARE AND
HOLLINGSHEAD OF LETTERS ANALYST
OFFICE. I MAY BE SPEAKING YOU-TODAY FROM HANDOUT YOU SHOULD
IN FRONT OF YOU- AND FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO ARE FOLLOWING-
REMOTELY YOU CAN FIND OUR HAND
OUT AT ILIO DOT CA DOC OF. I'M
SO I'M JUST GOING TO GIVE A
PRETTY BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN AND IN
PARTICULAR- THE FISCAL
IMPLICATIONS OF THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN FOR CALIFORNIA- SO
I HAVE THREE DIFFERENT PARTS TO
MY PRESENTATION FIRST ALL TALK
ABOUT THE ISSUES THAT HAVE.
SORT OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
BUDGETARY IMPLICATIONS FOR THE
STATE AND IN PARTICULAR PLACES
WHERE THE LEGISLATURE IS GOING
TO HAVE TO MAKE SOME COICES.
ABOUT HOW TO ALLOCATE FEDERAL
FUNDING. SECOND I'M GONNA
DISCUSS. THE FUNDING THAT IS
GOING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DIRECTLY TO
INDIVIDUALS AND BUSINESSES IN
THE SALE TALK ABOUT KIND OF THE
MAJOR CATEGORIES OF FUNDING
THERE. AND THEN FINALLY ALL
DISCUSS- SOME PROGRAMMATIC
AMOUNTS- IT AND IN PARTICULAR
SOME OF THE LARGER DOLLAR
AMOUNTS THAT ARE GOING TO. SOME
STATE PROGRAMS. SO WITH THAT I
WILL TURN TO THE FIRST PAGE. SO
V. LATELY MOST MAJOR ISSUE FOR-
THE LEGISLATURE AS A RESULT OF
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN KIND
OF THE AREA WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE IS GOING TO HAVE
THE MOST CHOICES TO MAKE IS
ABOUT THE ROUGHLY TWENTY SIX
BILLION DOLLARS IN FISCAL
RELIEF FUNDS THAT WERE PROVIDED
AS PART OF THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN OR OR ALSO KNOWN AS A. R.
P. THIS MONEY IS. RELATIVELY
DISCRETIONARY THE LEGISLATURE
DOESHAVE SOME FLEXIBILITY IN
HOW IT CAN BE USED BUT THERE
ARE KIND OF FOUR BUCKETS- THAT
THE FUNDS HAVE TO FALL INTO SO
THE FIRST IS THAT THEY HAVE TO
BE USED FOR- CORONAVIRUS
RESPONSE EITHER YOU KNOW
DIRECTLY LIKE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY RELATED STUFF OR-
INDIRECTLY- SUCH AS RESPONDING
TO THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF KOBE
NINETEEN. THE SECOND IS THAT
THE FUNDS COULD BE USED TO
BACKFILL REVENUE LOSSES AND
THAT HAVE OCCURRED SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC.
THIRD OF THE FUNDS CAN BE USED
TO SUPPORT ESSENTIAL WORK AND
FOR THE FUNDS CAN BE USED- FOR
UTILITY TYPE EXPENDITURES TO-
FOR WATER SEWER AND BROADBAND
THOSE KINDS OF UPGRADES- THERE
ARE TWO NOTABLE RESTRICTIONS ON
THE USE OF FUNDS. FIRST OF ALL-
IF THE STATE ACCEPTS THE FUNDS
THAT ESSENTIALLY AGREES NOT TO
USE THEM TO REDUCE TAXES AND-
WE'RE STILL WAITING ACTUALLY
FOR SOME TREASURY GUIDANCE
AROUND THERE- KIND OF EXACTLY
WHAT THAT MEANS AND WHAT THE
DIFFERENT- RESTRICTIONS WILL BE
THERE SO RIGHT NOW WE KIND OF
ONLY HAVE A GENERAL IDEA OF
WHAT THIS RESTRICTION IS BUT
ONCE WE HAVE MORE TO MORE
GUIDANCE FROM THE U. S.
TREASURY WILL. WELL NO MORE
AND- THE SECOND RESTRICTION IS
THAT THEY CANNOT BE USED THE
FUNDS. CANNOT BE USED FOR
SUPPLEMENTAL PENSION PAYMENTS.
THERE GOING TO BE A BILL UNTIL
THE- TWENTY TWENTY FOUR SO THEY
DON'T HAVE TO BE SPENT IN THIS
BUDGET YEAR EVEN NEXT BUDGET
YEAR- THAT THEY ARE GOING TO BE
AVAILABLE OVER THAT MULTI OR
PER. I'M NOT YEAR PERIOD TO THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ACTUALLY A GOOD
AMOUNT OF FLEXIBILITY THERE-
SECOND IN FISCAL RELIEF TO THE
STATE. THERE ARE ABOUT SIXTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDS THAT
ARE GOING TO GO DIRECTLY FROM
THE FEDERAL GVERNMENT TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. ALL COUNTIES AND
CITIES WITH POPULATIONS OVER
FIFTY THOUSAND WILL RECEIVE
THEIR FUNDS DIRECTLY FROM THE
FUNDS. AND THAT AND THOSE
CITIES WITH POPULATIONS LESS
THAN FIFTY THOUSAND WILL GET
THEIR ALLOCATIONS INDIRECTLY TO
THE STATE WILL GET THE MONEY
FIRST AND THEN IT'LL DISTRIBUTE
THOSE FUNDS TO THE CITY'S- BUT
THE LEGISLATURE WON'T HAVE
DISCRETION THERE THE FUNDS WILL
HAVE TO BE ALLOCATED ACCORDING
TO A FORMULA PROVIDED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. SO THEN THE
SECOND CATEGORY IS RELATED TO
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS- B. A.
R. P. PROVIDED ABOUT. THESE ARE
ESTIMATES- SO THAT THESE
NUMBERS ARE STILL SUBJECT TO
CHANGE BUT ABOUT TWO POINT TWO
BILLION. FOR RENTAL ASSISTANCE
WHICH IS SORT OF A CONTINUATION
OF THE FUNDS. THAT WERE
PROVIDED IN DECEMBER THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ALREADY ALLOCATED
IN EARLY ACTION AND THEN ABOUT
A BILLION DOLLARS IN HOMEOWNERS
ASSISTANCE- BUT WHICH ARE FUNDS
THAT WOULD. GO TO QUALIFYING
HOMEOWNERS AREN'T TO HELP OF
MORTGAGE PAYMENTS UTILITIES
PROPERTY TAX PAYMENTS AT THAT
TRACK. SO THOSE MONIES- THE
LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT ROLE TO PLAY IN IN
DETERMINING HOW THEY'RE- HOW
THEY'RE ALLOCATED. AND THEN
FINALLY THERE'S FIVE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION FOR CAPITAL
PROJECTS. THOSE SORT OF
SUPPORTING THE INDIRECT EFFECTS
OF THE PANDEMIC- SO. DO REMOTE
WORK SCHOOL AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND SO AN EXAMPLE FOR EXAMPLE
WOULD BE LIKE USING THE MONEY
FOR BROADBAND- AND OTHER
SIMILAR PROCESS. FROM SO
TURNING TO THE NEXT PAGE ON
MAJOR SYSTEMS CATEGORIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND BUSINESSES.
THESE ARE REALLY JUST THE
LARGEST FUNDING AMOUNTS THAT-
WE ARE VERY ROUGHLY ESTIMATING
AT THE FEDS ARE GOING TO DIRECT
YOU CALIFORNIANS DIRECTLY IF
THE LEGISLATURE WON'T HAVE A
ROLE TO PLAY AT ALL IN THESE
ITEMS. I'M THERE'S AN ESTIMATED
FORTY BILLION DOLLARS AS A
RESULT OF THE EXTENSION OF THE
ENHANCED UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS-
AND THAT IS AGAIN OVER A VERY
ROUGH ESTIMATE BUT BUT- WHAT WE
HAVE TO DO IT THERE'S THIRTY
FIVE BILLION ESTIMATE FOR CASH
ASSISTANCE TO INDIVIDUALS THESE
ARE THE FOURTEEN HUNDRED DOLLAR
CHECKS THAT MOST QUALIFYING
TAXPAYERS ARE GOING TO RECEIVE.
THERE'S ABOUT FIFTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS GOING TO CALIFORNIANS
AS A RESULT OF THE I. T. SKI
THE CHILD CARE TAX CREDIT AND
THE CHILD TAX CREDIT
EXPANSIONS- AND THEN FIVE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
BUSINESS SUPPORT WHICH WILL
MOSTLY FOCUS ON THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY. TURNING TO THE THIRD
AND FINAL- TEXT PAGE OF THIS
HANDOUT. THE PROGRAMMATIC
FUNDING AMOUNTS THERE'S NEARLY
SIXTEEN BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S
GOING TO GO TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. AND THIS IS TO
REOPEN SCHOOLS THAT ALSO TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT LEARNING
LOSS- THAT HAS OCCURRED AS A
RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC. FIVE
OF HIGHER EDUCATION ABOUT HALF
FOR EMERGENCY GRANTS- FOR
STUDENTS AND THAT ABOUT HALF
FOR CAMPUS OPERATIONS- TO
BACKFILL REVENUE LOSSES AND
THEN TO MAINTAIN CAMPUS- CAMPUS
OPERATIONS. NEARLY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR A VARIETY OF PUBLIC
HEALTH- INITIATIVES ARE OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THIS NUMBER
PARTICULAR CONTINUES TO CHANGE
AS WE GOT. ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT-
BUT THIS IS FOR DISTRIBUTION OF
VACCINE- AND THEN ALSO CONTINUE
TO TESTING CONTACT TRACING ITS
ULTRA. FOUR BILLION DOLLARS TO
TRANSIT AGENCIES AGAIN TO BACK
FILL REVENUE LOSSES MOSTLY- AND
THEN IT NEARLY FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS TO CHILD CARE AND HEAD
START PROVIDERS- THAT- WITH THE
INTENT OF SERVICE CONTINUING TO
FOCUS ON OPERATIONS- SUPPORT
PAYROLL EXPENDITURES FOR
EXAMPLE OR OR- RENT AND
MORTGAGE PAYMENTS. SO THE LAST
COUPLE PAGES OF THE HAND OUT-
JUST HAVE A FEW TABLES WHERE
WE'VE TRIED TO SUMMARIZE THE
TOTAL- THE TOTAL AMOUNT EIGHT
KIND OF FROM THE LARGEST
BUCKETS OF FEDERAL RELIEF SO
THIS IS. IN GENERALLY SPEAKING
ITEMS THAT ARE FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS OR MORE THERE'S
ACTUALLY QUITE A BIT THAT ISN'T
INCLUDED IN THIS TABLE SO IT'S
DEFINITELY NOT COMPREHENSIVE-
BUT WE WANT TO TRY TO GET AS
MUCH ON THIS LIST AS WE COULD-
AND SO IT'S DIVIDED BY THE%
ENTITY THAT IS GOING TO RECEIVE
THE FUNDING- AND THEN
DISTRIBUTE THE FUNDING OR OR
JUST RECEIVE IT TO USE. THE
DESCRIPTION AND THEN AT THE
POTENTIAL LEGISLATIVE ROLE I'M
SO HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS OR-
KNOWER AND WHATEVER TO PROGRAM.
THANK YOU LET'S GO TO MICHELLE
THàNH FROM FINANCE. HEY
KRISTIN SHELTON FROM DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND I THINK THE L.
A. O. DID A REALLY NICE JB OF
PROVIDING A BROAD BRUSH
OVERVIEW FOR YOU ON AND THE
ESTIMATES RAIL RELATIVE TO THE
FEDERAL- I'M AT AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN. AND WE ARE ALSO DOING THE
SAME COMPILATION OUR NUMBERS
ARE VERY VERY COMPARABLE TO THE
LEDGE ANALYST'S OFFICE FROM A
PRELIMINARY STANDPOINT- NEW
GUIDANCE COMES OUT EVERY DAY
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR
AN UPDATE- DURING THAT TIME
FRAME AS AS THAT DATA BECOMES
AVAILABLE. I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE ANY.
MR TRUMP. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MAYBE THIS COULD BE THE I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCER OR WHAT THE
L. A. L. L. I WANT TO DELVE
DEEPER INTO THIS THE GUIDANCE
IN TERMS OF THE USE FOR- SMALL
BUSINESS RELIEF- CERTAINLY AS A
LEGISLATURE WHERE WE'VE BEEN
GRAPPLING WITH TRYING TO GET
PPP CONFORMITY- DONE- IT WAS
KIND OF ON TRACK AND THEN IT
WILL. IN AND NOW IT'S NOT HEY
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR MORE
CLARITY- CAN YOU KIND OF GIVE
ME A LITTLE MORE SPECIFICS IN
TERMS OF WHAT THE PACIFIC
SPECIFIC ISSUE IS THAT THAT THE
STATE HAS THE USE STATE FUNDS
AND THEN I CAN'T USE THE
FEDERAL FUNDS THAT ARE COMING
TO THE STATE TO DO THAT- AS YOU
CAN. AS YOU PROBABLY ALREADY
KNOW YOU ALREADY KNOW THE
DEADLINE JUST RECENTLY PASSED
THERE'S A LOT OF ANXIETY- YEAH
WE WERE TRYING TO GET THIS
COMPLETED BEFORE THAT THE
FILING DEADLINE SO CAN YOU HE
SAID SOME LIGHT AND SO. THAT
THE THINKING AT WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION. SURE CHRIS
SCHULTZ AGAIN AND SO FIRST WHAT
WE WOULD SAY IS WE CERTAINLY
FAIR SHARE YOUR CONCERN-
RELATIVE TO THE WAY IN WHICH
THE LANGUAGE IS CRAFTED. AND WE
ARE STILL KIND OF ASSESSING
WHAT THIS MIGHT MEAN- BUT KIND
OF A BOTTOM LINE THAT IF- THE-
TREASURY GUIDANCE DOES NOT GIVE
ANY KIND OF FLEXIBILITY AROUND.
ITEMS RELATED TO CONFORMITY. IT
WOULD. IT WOULD BASICALLY BE
TWICE THE COST OF WHAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY BEING CONTEMPLATED
AND DELIBERATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE SO. THE VALUE OF
THAT TAX CONFORMITY WOULD ALSO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT AT THE TWENTY
SIX BILLION LEDGER ANALYST
MENTIONED. THAT WOULD COME TO
THE STATE SO. THAT WOULD BE.
KIND OF TO IMPACTS- WE- WE ARE
OBVIOUSLY- WORKING CAREFULLY
AND CLOSELY TO- TRY TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THAT UNCERTAINTY. WE
DON'T WE DON'T KNOW IF THAT AND
CERTAINTY IS. GOING TO BE
INTERPRETED THE SAME WAY- AS-
AND KIND OF IT MAY LOOK ON THE
SURFACE SO REALLY. IS GOING TO
DEPEND ON THEIR INTERPRETATION
AT THE TREASURY LEVEL. WHAT
OPTIONS AND THE STATE HAS
RELATIVE TO THE USE OF THE
FUNDS. AND WE'RE REALLY HOPING
TO GET MORE CLARITY THROUGH
THAT FEDERAL GUIDANCE IN THE
COMING WEEKS AND ARE WORKING
WITH. OUR CALIFORNIA LEADERSHIP
AS WELL AS VARIOUS ASSOCIATIONS
TO KIND OF FRAME OUR CONCERNS-
AND WE KNOW THAT WE ARE NOT
ALONE ACROSS MANY STATES.
INCLUDING THOSE THAT
AUTOMATICALLY. CONFORM TO SOME
OF THESE PROVISIONS. CAN YOU
YOU EXPLAIN HOW HOW WOULD IT
DOUBLE THE COST. OF THE- OF THE
PROPOSAL. SURE SO AND THAT YOU
WOULD TAKE YOU WITH AND HAVE
THE REVENUE REDUCTION THAT WAS
CONTEMPLATED- THROUGH NOT
CONFORMING SO THAT THAT WOULD
BE AN IMPACT ON THE REVENUE
SIDE AND THEN THE TWENTY SIX
BILLION THAT WAS ALLOCATED FOR
CALIFORNIA OR IS ESTIMATED FOR
CALIFORNIA IN THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN WOULD GET REDUCED
BY AN EQUIVALENT AMOUNT. SO TO
THE I GUESS THEN THE NEXT
QUESTION WOULD BE. IF WE WERE
TO USE THE STATE. WINDFALL AND
NOT ACCESS THE ARE NOT UTILIZED
TO THE FEDERAL FUNDS TO DO
CONFORMITY IS THAT ALLOWED. I
WOULD PRESUME THAT IT IS IT IS
IT'S NOT ACTUALLY. SURE SORRY
ABOUT THAT- IT'S NOT ACTUALLY
ABOUT AND USING THOSE FEDERAL
FUNDS IT'S MORE THE PERCEPTION
THAT THE FEDERAL FUNDS IS
PROVIDING- RELIEF TO. ALL
GOVERNMENTS AND THAT THOSE
FUNDS WOULD THEN BE USED TO
SUBSIDIZE ACT TAX CUTS THE
GENERAL FUND- UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT SOME OF THE FEDERAL
THINKING WAS AT THE TIME THAT
BILL WAS PASSED. AND I THINK IT
WOULD HAVE TO BE STRUCTURED
VERY DIFFERENTLY AND NOT TAKE
THE SHAPE OF A TAX REDUCTION OR
REVENUE PRODUCTION TO BE ABLE
TO- IMPLEMENTED IN A WAY THAT
DOESN'T DOESN'T HAVE THAT
DOUBLE AND- IMPACT AND WHAT I
WOULD SAY THOUGH IS THAT. YOU
KNOW IDEALLY WHAT WE WOULD DO
IS WORK WITH THE TREASURY AND
GET MORE CLARITY ON WHETHER THE
PROVISIONS THAT WERE ENACTED R.
AS RESTRICT AS THEY MIGHT BE
BEING PERCEIVED AT THIS POINT
SO I THINK FIRST STEP IS TO
WORK WITH. US TREASURY AND THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION. TO GET
MORE CLARITY AROUND THE ISSUE.
I GUESS I AM I BY APPRECIATE
THAT I GUESS THE QUESTION IS
THERE IS THERE. REMAINING FUNDS
IN THE STATE SURPLUS TO DO
CONFORMITY THAT WOULD AND SO
THAT WE WOULDN'T HAVE TO
UTILIZE. THE FEDERAL FUNDS I
GUESS MAYBE THAT'S A BETTER
QUESTION TO ASK. I AM SO YOU
WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT INSTEAD
OF REVENUE RELIEF AND AN
EXPENDITURE THAT WOULD PROVIDE
COMPARABLE OR SIMILAR AMOUNTS
OF RELIEF TO THOSE BUSINESSES
ADAM RIGHT TO TAKE THAT THE CAT
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE TO TAKE
FUNDING IN THE STATE. THE STATE
SURPLUS NOT INTERVIEWS THE TO
USE THAT FOR CONFORMITY AND I
THINK THAT WAS THE ORIGINAL
INTENT RIGHT I THINK I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE IS ASKING- IF WE
UTILIZE. THE STATE'S MONEY. FOR
THE- RELIEF- WOULD THAT BE
ALLOWABLE AND I THINK I THINK
MIGHT. MY UNDERSTANDING IS.
THAT IF WE DID DO THAT RENO TAX
RELIEF THROUGH DOES MATTER IT'S
ALL IT'S ALL IT'S ALL IT OUT OF
OUR GENERAL FUND- DAD MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THAT OUR
ALLOCATION FROM THE FEDERAL%
GOVERNMENT WOULD BE REDUCED
COMMENSURATELY SO FOR EXAMPLE.
IF IT WAS YOU KNOW SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS OF TAX RELIEF
WE WOULD LOSE SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN RECOVERYFUNDS FROM.
WASHINGTON OKAY THAT'S IT YEAH
SO IS IT IS IT JUST THE FACT
THAT WE'RE DOING RELIEF THAT
THAT'S WHAT'S THE TRIGGER TO
REDUCE. THE AMOUNT FROM THE
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
NOT NOT HOW WE USE THAT RECORD
NOT APPLYING THE MONEY TO TWO
DIFFERENT THINGS. YEAH THE MAIN
TRIGGER IS- I'M TAKING
IMPLEMENTING A LAW IN
CALIFORNIA AFTER MARCH THIRD
THAT HAS A NET REDUCTION IN THE
STATE'S OVERALL REVENUE I'M
FRAMEWORK SO. AND EVEN AND THIS
IS A CAN ASSIST POTENTIAL SO WE
DON'T KNOW WITH CERTAINTY AS
YACHTS AND- THE GUIDANCE IS
GOING TO BE FRAMED BUT IF YOU
DO SO AND THEN IT HAS THOSE
PENALTY KIND OF. BUILT INTO IT
SO IF YOU DON'T DO THAT THEN
YOU DON'T HAVE THE PENALTY- BUT
IF THERE IF THERE IS A REVENUE
ACTION THAT WOULD CAUSE THE
REDUCTION AND I IN CAN BE CASH
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WOULD BE PROVIDED TO US SALAS I
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR.
CLARIFYING SO IT'S NOT THAT THE
USE OF THE IT'S NOT HELD THEM
WHICH WHICH- WHERE THE FUNDS
COME FROM IT'S THE ACTUAL
ACTION OF DOING. TAX RELIEF
THAT IS CREATING V. THE
UNCERTAINTY OR THAT THAT NEEDS
CLARITY IS THAT IS THAT IS THAT
IS THAT ACCURATE TO SAY. YES
THE WAY IN WHICH THE FEDERAL
STATUTE WAS FRAMED IS CREATING
THE UNCERTAINTY I AM I THINK
YOU KNOW BRADLEY IT IS OUR
INTENT TO ULTIMATELY USE
GENERAL FUND TO DO SOMETHING IN
THAT- THE REAL QUESTION IS
ABOUT THE APPROACH AT THIS TIME
AND TELEMARKETER. THIS ISSUE I
JUST GOT OFF AN EXAMPLE OF
SOMETHING WE JUST DID SO WE
PROVIDED- A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF-
TAX AND FEE RELIEF TO SMALL
BUSINESSES AT THE SAME TIME WE
DID. ALSO A TWO BILLION DOLLAR
GRANT PROGRAM SO BASED BASED ON
OUR INITIAL READING I'M NOT
SAYING THIS IS WHAT THE FINAL
READING WILL BE BASED ON THIS
INITIAL READING. THE TWO
BILLION DOLLAR GRANT PROGRAM
WHERE WE ARE AGAIN EXPANDING
MONEY. WOULD SEEM TO BE AN
APPROPRIATE USE OF FUNDS WILL
ALLOW THE USE OF FUNDS. BUT
THE- FEE AND THE TAX REDUCTION
WHICH IS A REVENUE REDUCTION.
WOULD NOT BE IS THAT IS OUT OF.
FAIR COMPARISON I GUESS I'M A
FINANCE EARLIER. YES THE STATE
WOULD HAVE MUCH MORE LATITUDE
IN TERMS OF HOW WE STRUCTURE
THE GRANT PROGRAM WITHIN THE
FRAMEWORK THERE'S IN FACT BROAD.
FLEXIBILITY IN THE FORT CARE
ACT CATEGORIES THAT THE LEGEND
ALMOST DESCRIBED RELATIVE TO
PROVIDING KIND OF GRANTS AND
ASSISTANCE TO SMALL BUSINESSES
AND OTHERS AFFECTED BY KOPEN.
SO I I'VE I'VE I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THIS YEAR'S- EXAMPLE
AYE AYE IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE
ANY SENSE. TO BE ABLE TO
HAMSTRING A STATE'S ABILITY TO
DO TECHNICAL CORRECTIONS OR DID
TO DICTATE OUR OWN TAX POLICY
TO PROVIDE RELIEF. TO OF ALL
THINGS TO SMALL BUSINESSES
STRUGGLING TO THE PANDEMIC THAT
WOULD BE THE ONE THING I WOULD
THINK THAT THE FUNDS SHOULD BE
USED FOR. IS TO ACTUALLY HELP
SMALL BUSINESSES ESPECIALLY
WHEN I DON'T THINK THE CITY
CALIFORNIA I DON'T BELIEVE THE
POSITION OF THE ADMINISTRATION.
IS THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SHOULD BE GENERATING REVENUE ON
EMERGENCY RELIEF PROVIDED THE
PPP LANDS AND MY- I'M AGAIN I
WOULD HOPE THE GOVERNOR WOULD
SHARE THAT POSITION. IS THAT IS
THAT TRUE. CERTAINLY I THINK
GIVEN THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE
COLLECTIVELY WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOD THAT IS NOT
AN ACCURATE. SO THE SO THE GOAL
IS OBVIOUSLY TO DO P. B. P.
CONFORMITY BUT WE'RE TRYING TO
GET CLARITY ON WHETHER WE CAN
DO IT. WITH THIS LAW BEING
PASSED IS THAT CORRECT. YEAH WE
DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH INFORMATION
RIGHT NOW ABOUT AND WHAT WHAT
IT MEANS EXACTLY RELATIVES OF
THE FEDERAL GUIDANCE BUT I
THINK THAT THE CONTINUED
COMMITMENT TO SPARE. SO I AND I
GUESS THIS IS THE HYPOTHETICAL
BUT I'LL HAVE TO ASK IT BUT
INSTEAD GAVE IF THE LAW IS
CLEAR THAT IT DOESN'T ALLOW US
TO DO IT. WOULD WE APPEAL THAT
IT WOULD BE WOULD WE SUPPORT
LEGISLATION- TO TRY TO ALLOW US
TO DO THAT. WELL THAT'S IT SO.
RIGHT SO OUR OUR FIRST- KIND OF
EFFORTS- WHICH ARE ALREADY
UNDER WAY ARE SEEKING
ADDITIONAL CLARITY RELATIVE TO
THE GUIDANCE AND WE ARE WORKING
AGAIN THROUGH VARIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS ARE CALIFORNIA
DELEGATION I'M BACK IN
WASHINGTON DC TO FRAME OUR
CONCERNS HIGHLIGHT WHERE THERE
IS CLARITY NEEDED- FOCUSING ON
THE DISPARITY BETWEEN STATES
THAT WOULD AUTOMATICALLY
CONFORM TO FEDERAL TAX- CHANGES
VERSUS STATES THAT HAVE TO KIND
OF PRO ACTIVELY TAKE A STAB AND
IMPLEMENT- STATUTORY CHANGES TO
DO SO WE THINK IT YOU KNOW
THERE'S THIS BIG. DISPARITY IT
IT IS UNCLEAR THAT THAT WAS THE
INTENT IT'S JUST THAT- IN IN
DRAFTING I THINK THAT THEY WERE
TRYING TO SOLVE ONE PROBLEM AND
PERHAPS CREATED A DIFFERENT
PROBLEM FOR STATES AND SO WE'RE
WORKING AND TIRELESSLY TO BE
ABLE TO GET BACK CLARITY AND-
HELP TO GET IT AND THE COMING
WEEKS. THIS ONLY RAISES A LOT
OF CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTIONS TO-
WHICH I KNOW A LOT OF OTHER
STATES ARE PROBABLY GOING TO
EXAMINE I HOPE THAT WE WOULD
JOIN- THOSE- THOSE THOSE LEGAL-
EFFORTS TO IF NECESSARY- DO YOU
HAVE A TIME LINE IN TERMS OF
WHEN WE WOULD GET THAT CLARITY
I MEAN I KNOW THAT A LOT OF
FOLKS OF ASK FOR EXTENSIONS
BECAUSE MONDAY WAS- THE TAX
DEADLINE- SO. IF YOU DO YOU
HAVE A SENSE OF WHEN WE WOULD
GET THAT TYPE OF CLARITY SO
SAID THAT ARE SMALL BUSINESSES
COULD. PLANT A PATH FORWARD. WE
HAVE NO. NO SIGN ARE. WHEN THE
FEDERAL GUIDANCE WILL BE ISSUED
WE DO NOTE THAT THE ALLOCATIONS
HAVE A DEADLINE WITHIN THE-
AMERICAN RESCUE PLANNED- WHICH
IS SIXTY DAYS FROM THE DATE OF
AN ENACTMENT DOT DOT IS THE
ONLY THING WE DO KNOW- RELATIVE
TO WHAT. WHAT STEPS WHAT
TIMELINE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WILL PURSUE THEIR OKAY- I JUST
WANNA GET UP IN THE L. A. O.
DID DID THAT IF THE IF THEY
WANTED TO OPINE ON THIS ISSUE.
AND DO YOU HAVE A- PERSPECTIVE
ON THIS. RIGHT NOW I THINK I
WOULD JUST ECHO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE COMMENTS THAT WE- WE
TWO WERE EAGERLY AWAITING THE
U. S. TREASURY GUIDANCE- AND
ARE CAREFULLY MONITORING THE
SITUATION- IT TO. THE TOP OF
THE TUBE TRANSITION TO THEM TO
THE L. A. O. AND TERMS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE YOU YOU
MENTIONED THAT THE IN YOUR- AND
YOUR ANALYSIS IS JUST FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR CAPITAL PROJECTS. YOU KIND
OF. BREAK THAT DOWN A BIT MORE
IN TERMS OF WHAT THOSE PROJECTS
WOULD BE. HELLO ARE ELIGIBLE TO
DO IT IS IN EDUCATION HEALTH
MONITORING IT DOES A VERY BROAD
WORK I MEAN IT'S VERY BROAD
ARRAY BROAD BUCKETS. THE OTHER
LANGUAGE APPEARS RELATIVELY
FLEXIBLE AGAIN I THINK WE'RE
GONNA WAIT FOR MORE GUIDANCE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF TRADE OR
FROM THE US DEPARTMENT OF
TREASURY- THE BY BUT IT DOES
HAVE TO BE SORT OF TANGENTIALLY
RELATED TO CORONA VIRUS SO
EXAMPLES ARE- BROADBAND OR
UPGRADES CHIU- HEALTH- I. T.
SYSTEMS. YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE BUT THEN YOU
KNOW I THINK THERE'S PROBABLY
EXAMPLES OF OTHER YOU KNOW KIND
OF MORE BROADER CAPITAL OUTLAY
KIND OF PROJECTS THAT COULD
ALSO BE ELIGIBLE BUT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WERE YOU KNOW
CAN HAVE TO KIND OF CONTINUE TO
EXPLORE. OKAY AND THEN IN TERMS
OF. THE EDUCATION THEY DESERVE
THE SERVICES THERE'S A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF FUNDS ARE GOING
DIRECTLY TO SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES CAN YOU IS ARE
THERE TO THOSE FUNDS OF THE USE
FOR PARTICULAR THINGS WHEN IT
COMES ADVOCATION. HI MY
COLLEAGUE EDGAR CABRAL HERE AND
I THINK THAT HE'D BE BEST
SUITED TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
I'M GOING THE POINT IF THE
FUNDING OVERALL- FIFTEEN POINT
SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING
FOR K. TWELVE EDUCATION. MOST
OF THE ACT OF THIRTEEN POINT
SIX BILLION DOLLARS WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED DIRECTLY TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- RETALIATES ACCORDING
TO CHARTER SCHOOLS. BASED ON
THE TITLE ONE FORMULA THIS IS
THE FINGERPRINTS THAT DONALD
GENERAL. THE FIRST TWO ROUNDS
OF FUNDING HAD DONE SO BROWN'S
BUDGET OPENING IT'S GOING
DIRECTLY. TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS A
MALPRACTICE PROVIDING YOU GET
UNDER THE PARAMETERS WHICH ARE.
ESSENTIALLY ANYTHING RELATED TO
SCHOOL RE OPENING LEARNING OFF
ISSUES- AND THEN ANY SORT OF
FEDERALLY RELATED PROGRAMS FOR
SPECIAL STUDENTS FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS. THERE IS A ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION SO 10% OF THE
TOTAL PART OF THAT BUT THE
BIGGEST CHUNK IS. IT'S SORT OF
LIKE A STATE. NO PROBLEM MOST
ABOUT IT HAS TO BE SPENT
HUNDREDS FROM SOME RESTRICTIONS.
I'M HALF OF THAT HAVE TO BE
SPENT FOR EARLY LOS ACTIVITIES.
AND THEN- WHAT ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION AND
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IS TO BE
USED FOR SUMMER ENRICHMENT
PROGRAMS AND THEN A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION FOR.
COMPREHENSIVE AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS SO THERE IS A
POSSIBILITY FROM THE STATE IN
TERMS OF HOW YOU WANT TO
STRUCTURE ARE YOU WANT TO USE
IT BUT- BUT THAT'S-
RESTRICTIONS THERE ARE TONS OF
USED. THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
FROM PREVIOUS- OUR PREVIOUS ARE
AROUND THE FUNDING WHERE THE
STATE COMING WITH QUICKLY.
BENEFITS THE LEAVE ARM ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY ONE DOLLARS.
THAT THE STATE WOULD HAVE MORE
DISCUSS FOR DECIDING HOW TO USE.
THIS IS SO CAN I ASK HOW DOES.
THIS ADDITIONAL SO. FUNDS HOW
DOES IT INTERACT. THE RECENT
ACTIONS BY THE LEGISLATURE IN
TERMS OF. IN PERSON LEARNING
AND LEARNING AND ADDRESSING
LEARNING LOTS OF ACTIVITIES
THAT THE STATE DID IS IT IS IT
ON. IT ON TOP. OF HOW DID HOW
DO THEY INTERACT WITH EACH
OTHER. IMAGINE THERE IS A
REQUIREMENT THAT 20% OF THE
FUNDING THAT IS DISTRIBUTED
DIRECTLY TO LOCALS TO LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS GOING TO BE USED FOR MY
LEARNING OFF ACTIVITIES SO
THERE WILL BE A SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF FUNDING AVAILABLE
THAT THEY COULD BE USE THOSE
PURPOSES THE PERFORMING WHILE A
FEW MORE YEARS A BIG IN IN- THE
TIMING ALLOWS- SCHOOL DISTRICT
HAS BEEN OUT OVER A LONGER
PERIOD OF TIME SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT- THEY WOULD HAVE
TO TAKE A COUPLE MINUTES. AND
THE OTHER THING I WOULD NOTICE
THAT THE DISTRIBUTION FORMULA
WITH DIFFERENT AMOUNTS OF THE
FEDERAL FORMULA WHICH IS
USUALLY THE TITLE ONE FORMULA
IS NOT PROVIDES A SUBSTANTIALLY
MORE FUNDING FOR WORK- SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE A HIGHER
PERCENTAGES OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS IT'S NOT. THE STATE
FUNDING WAS DISTRIBUTED VIA OF
THE ACROPOLIS ALSO DOES PROVIDE
FROM ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE ALREADY MEMBERS
WOULD NOT CONSIDER BECAUSE
WE'RE BUT THE FUNDING IF.
PROVIDER A GREATER DIFFERENCE
IN TERMS OF THE LOWER- HI
INCOME AND LOWER SCHOOLS. OKAY
SO THE FIRST THE FUNDING
STREAMS ARE DEAF BUT IT TO THE
C. AREA SO IN PER LEARNING
LEARNING LAW SO THIS AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAVE DID.
FOLLOW THE DIFFERENT FORMS AND
DID PAD. IT'S GOES TO THE SAME.
ISSUE EVERY OPENING SCHOOL AND
LEARN LAWCENTER ELSE. AND IF I
DON'T. YES IN THE CATEGORIES
ARE BROKEN UP BECAUSE- WE KNOW
THAT IT'LL BE SIX OH ARE
REQUIRED THAT. THE SECOND ROUND
OF FEDERAL AND THE DVDS IT'S TO
BE A- REGARDING HOW TO USE THE
FUNDS I THINK IT WELCOME USED
ON THURSDAY DIFFERENCES
IMPOSSIBLE CATEGORY ARE IN SOME.
RESTRICTIONS THEY ARE IN OF
THOSE CATEGORIES THAT YOU MAY
THAT OF THE CAN. TO PLAN INTO
ONE OUT. THE FUNDING OVER THE
NEXT YEAR. AND THE ASSISTANCE
AND THE REST SYSTEM- THE
LEGISLATURE HAD ACTED AS WELL
AND AN ESTABLISHED- OF THOSE
OF. ITS OWN SYSTEM TO
DISTRIBUTE AN IN ADDITION TO A
WHAT OTHER LOCAL LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE DOING. DOES
THAT MONEY. IS THAT MONEY GOING
INTO THE SAME. THE POT THANK
YOU THE MONEY THAT WAY. GOOD
FOR YOU JUST GATED HANSON WE
ARE DID OR- WITH THIS WOULD THE-
LEGISLATIVE TAKE. SEPARATE
ACTION AGAIN DID THIS THIS
MONEY. AND ON HOMEOWNERS
DISTANCE AND- AND THE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE. YES I AM CALLING
SAID LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- YES THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD HAVE TO TAKE SEPARATE
ACTION- TO ALLOCATE THESE FUNDS
BUT THEY ARE THE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE IN PARTICULAR IS
VERY SIMILAR TO YOU KNOW IN
TERMS OF WHAT THE FUNDING WAS
PROVIDED FOR IS VERY SIMILAR TO
THE FEDERAL MONEY THAT WAS
PROVIDED IN DECEMBER THAT YES
AS YOU NOTED. OF THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY
ALLOCATED SO- IF LEGISLATOR
WANTED TO USE A SIMILAR SYSTEM
IT COULD OR A DIFFERENT SYSTEM
THAT WOULD ALSO BE AVAILABLE TO
HOMEOWNERS ASSISTANCE- IS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THAN. THAN
WHAT HAS BEEN PROVIDED. OKAY
OTHER WHAT ARE THE BUDGET
IMPLICATIONS TO THIS DECISION
MONEY ARE THERE ANY BUDGET
IMPLICATIONS FOR US AND MAKE IT
A CALL BACKS IS THERE CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS STRINGS ATTACHED
TO THESE THAT THESE FUNDS THAT
WE HAVE TO BE AWARE OF. TO THE
HOMELESSNESS AND HARMONICIST
I'M JUST IN GENERAL IN GENERAL
BUT I GUESS YOU COULD WE COULD
TALK ABOUT THAT IS THE TWENTY
SIX BILLION IN THE RECOVERY BUT
IF THERE ARE OTHER. STRINGS I
GUESS. WE APPRECIATE THAT.
INFORMATION HE ADDED SIX
BILLION IS THE AMOUNT THAT HAS
THE MOST DIRECT SORT OF FISCAL
OR BUDGETARY IMPLICATIONS FOR
THE STATE I MEAN I THINK THE
QUESTION IS STILL AROUND. HOW
MUCH THIS IS GOING TO REPLACE
START OF EXISTING EXPENDITURES-
FOR THE STATE AND PROVIDE
FISCAL RESPONSE THIS GOAL-
FLEXIBILITY AND NOT RESPECT OR
HOW MUCH OF IT IS BASICALLY
JUST GONNA HAVE TO BE SPENT ON
NEW PURPOSES- GIVEN THAT B. R.
REVENUE LOSSES ARE DEFINED
RELATIVE TO EIGHTEEN NINETEEN I
THINK WE STILL HAVE TO KIND OF
UNDERSTAND WHAT ALL. WHAT YOU
KNOW OR IS THIS ALL FUNDS IT
JUST GENERAL FUND FOR EXAMPLE-
IT'S THAT WOULD BE THE KIND OF
KEY CRITERIA WHERE THERE WOULD
BE. AN OPPORTUNITY FOR ON THE
STATE TO USE THE FUNDS IN A WAY
THAT YOU KNOW SORT OF
SUPPLANTED EXISTING
EXPENDITURES AS OPPOSED TO JUST
BEING A SUPPLEMENTAL AMOUNT-
AND GIVEN THAT THE THAT THE
STATE'S REVENUE PERFORMANCE FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY. FOR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO- IT LOOKS
LIKE IT'S GOING TO BE ABOVE THE
PRE PANDEMIC LEVEL AND THEN IT
IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT THERE WILL
BE THAT THE STATE'S GOING TO BE
ABLE TO KIND OF USE THAT
MECHANISM THAT VERY MUCH SO.
THERE'S STILL KIND OF QUESTIONS
AROUND HOW MUCH THIS IS GOING
TO PROVIDE KIND OF. FISCAL
RELIEF IN THE SENSE THAT YOU
WOULD THINK- IT IS KIND OF A
SUB PLANTATION OF FEDERAL OF-
EXISTING STATE EXPENDITURES
VERSUS MORE OF A SUPPLEMENTAL.
PAYMENT WHERE THE STATE HAS YOU
KNOW THE OPPORTUNITY
ESSENTIALLY TO SPEND THE MONEY
ON NEW PURPOSES. OKAY AND THEN
OF COURSE- THAT WITH THE NOT
BARRING THAT THE CLARITY THAT
WE NEED FOR THE RELIEF I GUESS
THAT'S THAT THE OTHER BIG- DIED
IN THAT WE NEED TO GET. A
ANSWER ON YES. YES YES. I THINK
WE'RE MUCH. THANKS FOR ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
NO GREAT REALLY VERY VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION
FROM LA- INFO FROM THE FINANCE
SOUNDS LIKE WE STILL HAVE QUITE
A LOT OF QUESTIONS THAT WE NEED
ANSWERED AND WILL BE ON EAGERLY
AWAITING- GREATER FEDERAL
GUIDANCE SO WITH THAT I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO
PUBLIC COMMENT DOES ANY PUBLIC
HERE IN THE ROOM WHICH CAN
ACCOMMODATE. PLEASE STEP
FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE. GO
AHEAD AND START. I NEED MY
GLASSES I FIVE EXTRA SECONDS
WOULD HELP ME YOUR SUPPORT LINE
TO CONTROLLED VACCINE INJURED
WOMAN WHO KEEPS COMING BACK. SO
WHAT I'M GONNA DO TODAY WITH MY
VERY GENEROUS MINUTES OF TIME.
IS START TO READ A LETTER BY
ROBERT F. KENNEDY WRITTEN TO
JOE BIDEN. DEAR PRESIDENT BIDEN
WE RIGHT TO ASK YOU TO FIX THE
H. H. S.'S CATASTROPHICALLY
INEFFICIENT SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM
FOR VACCINE INJURIES GENUINE
TRANSPARENCY ROBUST SCIENCE TWO
ONE MICROPHONE. UNBIASED DATA
GATHERING AND ANALYTICS AND A
FUNCTIONAL SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM
ARE THE ONLY WAYS TO END
WIDESPREAD VACCINE HESITANCY
AND TO BUILD PUBLIC TRUST FOR
THE COVERT NINETEEN VACCINE
PROGRAM. THE WARP SPEED VACCINE
PROGRAM ALLOWED PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES TO ABBREVIATE
CLINICAL TRIALS AND RUSH
EXPERIMENTAL I'M A LICENSED E.
U. WAY EMERGENCY USE
AUTHORIZATION VACCINES TO
AMERICANS IN WHAT HEALTH
OFFICIALS ACKNOWLEDGE IS A
POPULATION WIDE EXPERIMENT. HHS
REGULATORS JUSTIFIED THE SHORT
CUT BY PROMISING TO IMPLEMENT A
POST LICENSING SURVEILLANCE
SYSTEM THAT WOULD DETECT
VACCINE INJURIES AND ALLOW
PUBLIC HEALTH AUTHORITIES
PHYSICIANS AND AMERICANS TO
UNDERSTAND THE RISKS AND
BENEFITS FOR EACH OF THE
VARIOUS VACCINES HOWEVER HHS
OFFICIALS ARE INSTEAD ADOPTING
PROCEDURES DESIGNED TO HIDE
COALBED VACCINE INJURIES
PARTICULARLY DEATH. FOR THE
PUBLIC TO OBSCURE SAFETY AND
RISK PROFILES. THIS IS NOT A
VACCINE YOU ARE EXPERIMENTING
ON CALIFORNIANS AND YOU KNOW
THE TRUTH AND YOU'RE STILL
DOING ACT. PEOPLE ARE FLEEING
THIS STATE. HAS A VACCINE
MANDATES YOU COULD ROBERT
PLEASE THANK YOU. I WAS ALMOST
KILLED BY A HEPATITIS B.
VACCINE TWENTY YEARS AGO SB TWO
SEVEN SIX WHAT. YOU KNOW SOME
MANDATED MEDICINE IS COMMUNISM
EXPERIMENTING ON PEOPLE. GIVING
THEM INFORMATION YOU HAVE BEEN.
THANK YOU WE ARE. YEAH. THANK
YOU OPERATOR WE GO TO THE QUEUE
PLEASE. PHONE YOU MAY PRESS THE
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOUR OF
MY NUMBER YEAH MY COMMAND AS A
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE'LL GO
TO OUR FIRST COMMENT IN Q. AND
THAT'S LINE FIFTEEN ONE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RONALD KOEMAN'S HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA AT THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK HERE TO OFFER COMMENTS
ON ISSUE ONE SEAPLANE IS PROUD
TO BE AMONG A DIVERSE GROUPOF
MEMBERS ON THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
COMMUNITY VACCINE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. FIVE EIGHT STATEWIDE
HELP ABIT ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
FOCUSED ON RACIAL AND- ETHNIC
HEALTH DISPARITIES WE KNOW WE
WILL HAVE TO OVERCOME MISTRUST
AND SKEPTICISM AND IT JUST.
OCCURRED TO ME NEW YORK
BARRIERS TO CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY COMPETENT
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION WE
BELIEVE CALIFORNIA HAS SET UP
TO DO THIS. AND WE KNOW THAT
WE'RE READY FOR THIS TASK. FOR
TO BUILD TRUST NOW AND FOR
DECADES TO COME SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF A PANDEMIC
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
ADVOCATES OF SOUNDED THE ALARM
CALIFORNIA TAKING GREAT STEPS
AND ENSURING COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT IN LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY THEY'RE CENTERED IN
THE STATE'S RESPONSE FROM
INCORPORATING AN EQUITY METRIC
INTO RE OPENING PROTOCOLS. TO
STRATEGIC LOCATIONS FUNDING AND
RESOURCING OF TESTING SITES WE
ALONGSIDE OUR PARTNERS
ADVOCATED FOR THE STATE TO TAKE
A PLACE BASED APPROACH TO
TARGET THE HARDEST HIT
COMMUNITIES WE'RE GLAD THAT THE
STATE HAS TAKEN STEPS TO LISTEN
TO DISABILITY ADVOCATES. AND
ADDING THOSE WHO ARE HIGH RISK
TO THE PRIORITY LIST WE THANK
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
LISTENING TO IMMIGRANT
ADVOCATES IN ADDING IN PEOPLE
IN CONGREGATE SEVEN COLLECTED
TENSION TO COMMITTEES. AND
HOMELESS SHELTERS TO THE
PRIORITY TEARS BUT WE AGREE
WITH MANY OF THE COMMENTS FROM
THE LEGISLATURE THAT WE NEED TO
DO MUCH MORE TO ENSURE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO VACCINES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT COMMENT HELLO TWENTY
THREE TO THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THERE SORRY- MY NAME'S
AMY COMBS. AND I'M AN
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENTIST- I WORK
FOR THE STATE. I'M I'M A MOTHER
OF TWO SONS IN MY CHILDREN WILL
NEVER RECEIVE THIS EXPERIMENTAL
VACCINE. I WILL NEVER BEFORE
TAKE A GENE THERAPY SHOT TO
MODIFY THEIR GENES FOR A
DISEASE OF THE 99% SURVIVAL
RATE- I REMOVE MY CHILDREN FROM
SCHOOL THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE L. L. NEVER
RETURN TO THAT FORM OF
EDUCATION AGAIN. MAINLY JUST
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT. TO BE
FORCED TO. GIVE MEDICINES THAT
I DON'T WANT THEM TO TAKE OR
DON'T HAVE A CHOICE IN.
DECIDING THAT IT'S FOR YOU KNOW
IN THE END UP BEING REQUIRED-
SO I BASICALLY JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I HìNH. THE ONLY THING I
CAN DO AS A AS A- YOU KNOW I'M
A SINGLE MOTHER I. I WORK I
HOME SCHOOL MY KIDS NOW. THE
ONLY THING I CAN DO NOW IS JUST
KIND OF. DO OUR REACH TO TRY TO
HAVE OTHER PEOPLE- BUILD COOPS
AND- EDUCATE OTHER PEOPLE ON
WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING WITH
THIS I HOPE THAT. THIS DOESN'T
BECOME SOMETHING THAT IS
MANDATED. I WILL ALL I DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IF
THAT EVER HAPPENS I'M NEVER
TAKING IT I DON'T KNOW WHERE
I'D GO BUT MY KIDS ARE NEVER
GOING TO HAVE TO DO ANYTHING.
HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH THIS
SO. THAT'S ALL I CAN SAY. THANK
YOU X. X. COLOR. NEXT COMMENT
IT'S FROM LINE TWENTY FOUR TWO
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS CAROLYN AND- I LIVE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- I'M A COOK
BY TRADE AND I JUST RECEIVED AN
EMAIL FROM MY- PREVIOUS COMPANY
WHICH I- WORKED FOR. THAT IS A
STAFFING COMPANY FOR CLOUGH AND
THEY'RE BASICALLY SAYING THAT.
MOST OF THEIR CLIENTS THAT
THEY'RE FILLING- BUT ORDER ARE
REQUIRING THE WORKERS THE FOOD
SERVICE WORKERS TO HAVE THIS
VACCINE OR THEY WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO ACCEPT THE ASSIGNMENT.
I HAVE ALREADY NOT WORK FOR A
YEAR DUE TO THIS WHOLE PANDEMIC
BECAUSE EVERYTHING GOT SHUT
DOWN AND THEN THE MAP SCHOOL
THE WERE REQUIRED AND I AM
UNABLE TO WEAR A MASK AND I AM
UNABLE TO WEAR BACK TO GET A
VACCINE BECAUSE I AM BACKING
INJURED MY CHILDREN OF VACCINE
INJURED. AND I JUST WANTED TO
DISCUSS A FEW OF THE ISSUES-
WITH THE MASS DISTRIBUTION OF
VACCINE- WE DON'T EVEN KNOW THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS THERE ARE
ISSUES WITH ANTIBODY DEPENDENT
IMMUNE AND HAMPP MEANT. THAT
THIS WAS A PROBLEM WITH THE
DANG FEVER VACCINE AND ALSO IN
THE ATTEMPT TO MAKE THE START
COLBY AND MURDERS KOBE BAXEEN-
AND ALSO. THERE IF YOU LISTEN.
TO- AND- BY DEAR THEY ARE BY.
WHO IS A TOP THAT ALL HE IS THE
STUDY KEEP SCIENTIFIC ARE- OF
UNIVAC HE TALKED ABOUT MUNIS
DATE AND BY ALL STEP WHICH HAS
POTENTIAL IMPLICATIONS. FOR
CAUSING MORE SEVERE INFECTIONS
THESE ARE. THESE ARE PROBLEMS
WITH THE FACT TEAMED UP WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT BECAUSE
THESE ARE NOT IMMEDIATE
REACTION THESE ARE LONGER TERM
THE ACTION THANK YOU AND PLEASE
REPLY WITH THE FACT IN. YEAH
WITH THE FACT THE IN WE HAVE
ALREADY ELIMINATED THE CONTROL
GROUP WE WILL NOT KNOW THE LONG
TERM EFFECTS OF THIS VACCINE IT
IS STILL UNDER A MAJOR
EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZATION.
AND TO EVEN THINK THAT WE
SHOULD BE DISTRIBUTING THIS
VACCINE ON A MASS SCALE- TO
ANYONE AND ESPECIALLY THE
CHILDREN THAT'S IT'S JUST
REPREHENSIBLE- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
OUR NEXT. MINE TO FIVE TO
FELINES OPEN. HI MY NAME IS AT
ITS AND I GREW UP IN COMMUNISM
AND I AM A CITIZEN AND I'M A
REGISTERED WATER I AM ALSO A
MOTHER OF FOUR CHILDREN.
INCLUDING ONE THAT IS A VACCINE
INJURED AND I JUST WOULD LIKE
TO SAY THAT THE CALL WHICH SHOT
IS NOT A VACCINE. IT IS HARD TO
LABEL IT AS A VACCINE IT IS AN
EXPERIMENTAL GENE THERAPY AND
THEY ARE USING OUR BODIES FOR
THAT EXPERIMENT. WE DON'T GIVE
OUR CONSENT TO YOU WITH OUR
BODIES AND OUR CHILDREN'S
BODIES FOR BIG PHARMA AND THE
GOVERNMENT EXPERIMENTS. YOU
ALSO FIND THIS EXPERIMENT BY
OUR MONEY THE TAXPAYERS MONEY.
YOU ARE SPENDING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF. OUR MONEY TO USE IT
AGAINST US. STOP THE SIX. STOP
IN OCULAR OUR CHILDREN IN POSH.
AND STOP SATELLITES US OUR CHOI.
STOP LYING TO THE PUBLIC THE
CALL THE CHART IS A DANGEROUS
SHOT. AND WE THE PEOPLE DON'T
WANT IT IT'S TIME FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO LISTEN TO THE
PEOPLE THEN YOU FOR CEMEX
NATION ON PEOPLE THAT IS
COMMUNISM I KNOW WHAT COMMUNISM
IS LIKE I LIVED IN ITS I
EXPERIENCED IT AND THAT IS KIND
OF THEM AND YOU DON'T GET
PEOPLE ON. THE OPTION TO CHOOSE
SO STOP- TAKING THAT OPTION
AWAY FROM US AND START
LISTENING TO THE PEOPLE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER.
LINE TWENTY TWO TWO TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES HELLO MY NAME
IS STACY HELLO I'M A LIFELONG
SACRAMENTO SAN AND I'M CALLING
BASICALLY TO FOLLOW UP WITH
WHAT THE OTHER VERY INTELLIGENT
WOMEN- CITIZENS HAS STATED I
HAVE TWO CHILDREN IN THE FACT
THAT HE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND IF IT BECOMES MANDATED THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO FORCE THIS
STATE AND DOCUMENTATION M. R.
N. EIGHT INTO MY HEALTHY BODY
CHILDREN WITH COMPLETE.
CONFIDENCE IMMUNE SYSTEM TAX
CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
WILL NEVER SEE THEM AGAIN I
WILL ALSO STAND STRONG AS A
PETITION AGAINST THE MOVEMENT
IN SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA TO TRY
TO MAKE THE LABEL EVERY PERSON
THAT DEMANDS INFO. CAN SET WE
ARE NOT ANTI BAXTER. WE ARE.
THAT WAY INFORMATION. IS A- I
CAME FOR SACRAMENTO I THINK
YOU'RE THE MAY INDUSTRY I. I'M
WE DO NOT YOU FACE COULD CHANGE.
ON A EIGHT WILL HAPPEN YOU
RIGHT ON HAND YOU BETTER BE
PREPARED I DIDN'T RECALL WHAT.
CALIFORNIA. THE LINE IS SHALL
GO TO THE NEXT ON YES. THANK
YOU LINE EIGHTEEN ONE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO HELLO
GO AHEAD. BOB HI MY NAME IS
LIBERTY WE THE PEOPLE DO NOT
CONSENT TO HUMAN TRIALS THE
PEOPLE DO NOT CONSENT TO
EXPERIMENT ON OUR CHILDREN AND
THE ELDERLY WE THE PEOPLE DO
NOT CONSENT TO BE SILENT ABOUT
THE ALAMO TRIALS BECAUSE IN THE
PREVIOUS CORONAVIRUS TRY ALL
ANIMALS DIED. MEDIA PEOPLE DO
NOT CONSENT TO MAKE US THINK
THIS IS A VACCINE WHEN IN
REALITY MADERA NOW FIZER
CREATED A GENE THERAPY
TECHNOLOGY FROM DEADLY
SYNTHETIC MATERIALS. WE DO NOT
CONSENT TO BE HOLD INFORMED
CONSENT. READ DO NOT CONSENT TO
HAVE AN AWFUL ACCIDENT AND THAT
AS AN UNDISCLOSED SIDE EFFECTS
THANK. KING ARE YOU READY TO
OFFER YOUR TWO GIRLS TO THE
GREATER GOOD. OR ANY OF THE
OTHER LARGE LEGISLATORS ARE
YOU. V. PEOPLE DO NOT CONSENT
TO HUMAN TRIALS ON OUR CHILDREN
AND AS A SIDE NOTE ANTIBODY
TEST FOR ANYONE ARE AVAILABLE
FOR TEN DOLLARS FROM LABCORP
FOR THE VIRUS WHICH IS
RECOVERED BY NINETY NINE POINT
NINETY SEVEN PERCENT. THIS
COULD BE YOUR TICKET FOR YOUR
FUTURE. THANKS. FOR THE- LINE
SIXTEEN ONE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI SO THE CHILDREN OF
SATAN STILL DON'T KNOW WHO
THEIR FATHER IS ON. YOU GUYS
KNOW YOU GUYS ARE. ASKING FOR
WAR RIGHT NOW. YOU WANT TO
VACCINATE YOU WANT AN OBJECT
OUR PRECIOUS CHILDREN WHAT IS
THE EXPERIMENTAL DRUG. AND
YOU'RE NOT EVEN GONNA THINK
TWICE ABOUT IT ARE YOU KIDDING
ME THIS IS WHERE WE'RE AT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. YOU KNOW
MANY PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY
DEVELOPED IMMUNITY TO THIS. SO
CALLED PANDEMIC WHY DON'T YOU
GO TALK ABOUT THE ANTIBODY
TESTS. AND ALWAYS FOLKS TEN
DOLLARS TO GO GET IT TESTED
THAT YOU CAN GET THAT ANTIBODY.
THANK YOU BILL NATURAL. THAT
WHY DON'T WE TALK ABOUT THAT.
IF YOU WANT TO JUST INJECT ARE
CHILLED WITH THE POINT AND OR
WHAT. BECAUSE YOUR FATHER IS
THE DEVIL AND YOU WANT TO OUR
CHILDREN WELL GUESS WHAT WE ARE
WRITING. AND YOU GUYS GOT WAR
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE GONNA FIGHT
THAT. WE GET A MOMENT THERE. A
STAR. BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA THE
CHILL. YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GONNA. SO I SUGGEST YOU GUYS
REPENT THANK YOU CALL OUT TO
GOD. IN OUR FINAL COMMENTING
KEY WAS FROM LINE THIRTY THREE
THEY'RE ALL. VERA HELLO. IF WE
CAN ORDER IN THE ARMENIAN
POLICE. MA'AM YOU HAD YOUR TIME
TO TALK WE LIKE YOUR TICKET.
AND THEY WILL HAVE A CHANCE TO
SPEAK NEXT CALLER. HI MY NAME
IS JOANNA HEDRICK I AM
CURRENTLY. AND HAVE ALWAYS
LIVED IN CALIFORNIA THAT I WILL
BE MOVING TO TEXAS IN SEARCH OF
FREEDOM. FREEDOM FROM FOR SAXON
NATION- WITH COERCION MY KIDS
CAN'T GO TO SCHOOL WITHOUT YOU
FORCING THEM TO BE VACCINATED-
REALLY HOPING THAT YOUR FEAR
TACTICS AND COERCION DON'T
SPREAD TO THE GREAT STATE OF
TEXAS SO THAT I CAN ACTUALLY
LIVE MY LIFE. I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW YOU CAN PUBLISH
THIS VACCINE ON ANYONE THAT'S
AN EXPERIMENT LET ALONE FOR
CHILDREN. THEY HAVE SUCH A LOW
RISK OF GETTING CUT OPEN OR
GETTING SERIOUSLY INJURED FROM
COAL BED OR DYING WHY WOULD YOU
PUSH THIS VACCINE ON KIDS THEY
HAVE NOT BEEN INCLUDED IN ANY
OF THE TRIAL. THOSE TRIALS ARE
JUST BEGINNING WHICH TO ME I
CAN'T FATHOM AT THE PIER IT
PUTTING MY CHILD IN AN
EXPERIMENT LIKE THAT AND WHAT
YOU'RE WANTING PEOPLE TO DO IS
AN EXPERIMENT. ANYBODY WHO HAS
TAKEN THE SHOT IS IN A HUMAN
EXPERIMENT. I JUST I CAN'T WRAP
MY HEAD AROUND HOW YOU PEOPLE
THINK THIS IS A GOOD IDEA.
PLEASE JUST COME TO YOUR SENSES
IF PEOPLE WANT TO TAKE IT THEY
CAN TAKE IT GO FOR IT STOP
TRYING TO PUSH IT ON PEOPLE.
WILL BE FREE. THANK YOU MR AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN Q. IF YOU DON'T.
NOT. YEAH. IF YOU HAVE PEOPLE
ON THE PHONE GET THEM ON THE
PHONE WE WERE HERE TO TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT WHERE ARE YOUR
FRIENDS ON THE PHONE.
YEAH.
OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY OTHER
PEOPLE ON THE PHONE. WE DO. WE
DO HAVE ONE MORE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. GO AHEAD. M. THIRTY
FOUR THREE FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PUT ME IN HERE
SO HELLO EVERYBODY MY NAME IS
CHANGING CUT BACK AND I AM
CALLING IN WITH CONCERNS ABOUT
ISSUE ONE DISCUSS TODAY. I AM
CONCERNED THAT THIS VACCINE IS
BEING DISTRIBUTED SO QUICKLY
ACCESS YOU KNOW WITH FAST TRACK
FOR. EVERYBODY WHEN IT STILL IN
EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZATION
THAT'S CONCERNING TO ME BECAUSE
THERE'S JUST NOT ENOUGH SAFETY
TESTING FOR THAT IF PEOPLE WANT
TO GET IT THAT'S FINE BUT THIS
AGENDA TO HAVE EVERYBODY DONE
BY NAY AND THEN FEEDING IT OUT
FOR CHILDREN TOO I THINK THIS
IS JUST NOT SAFE. I THINK
YESTERDAY AT THE THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE DAYS SINCE MY
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GO
TO SCHOOL THEY ARE NOT AFFECTED
BY THIS VIRUS IN THE SAME WAY
AND I JUST I WANT MY KIDS TO BE
ABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL AND WE
HAVE TO JUMP THROUGH SO MANY OF
THESE GROUPS FOR THEM TO BE
ABLE TO GO BACK AND IT JUST. IT
SEEMS LIKE THEY ARE THE
COMMUNITY THAT IS BEING THE
MOST OPPRESSED IN THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE AND BECAUSE OF
THIS AND ALSO MY HUSBAND BEING
A TEACHER WHO CANNOT GO BACK TO
TEACHING NOW BECAUSE OF ALL OF
THIS WE DECIDED TO LEAVE THE
STATE I WANT MY CHILDREN TO BE
ABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL I WANT TO
BE ABLE DECIDE WHAT MEDICAL
TREATMENTS THEY CAN AND CANNOT
HAVE. I WANT MY HUSBAND TO BE
ABLE TO WORK AS A TEACHER AGAIN
I WANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
FREEDOM TO NOT HAVE TO TAKE
THIS VACCINE AND THE AGENDA
THAT'S BEING PUSHED FORWARD IS
CONCERNING FOR ME. BECAUSE IT'S
STILL AN EMERGENCY USE
AUTHORIZATION IT HAS NOT BEEN
TAKEN CAPTIVE ESPECIALLY ON
CHILDREN AND THAT SCARES ME BUT
IF ENOUGH THAT I'M LEAVING MY
HOME STATE. OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK. OPERATOR OF THE OTHER
COLORS. THERE ARE NEXT IN LINE
THIRTY SEVEN THREE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR
ME GO AHEAD. YES HI- MY NAME IS
AMY AND I AM CALLING AND
CONCERN FOR THE SEX SCENE THAT-
YOU GUYS WANT OUR CHILDREN TO
HAVE. SO I JUST WANNA KNOW WHY
WHY ARE YOU FOURTEEN DOWN- A
VACCINE DOWN CHILDREN'S THROAT.
WHEN THEIR SURVIVAL RATE FROM
COLD IT IS NINETY NINE POINT 9%
WHY IT WHY IS IT SUCH A CONCERN
TO YOU GUYS. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME. THIS IS A HOLLOW YOU CAN
CONTINUE WITH YOUR COMMENT. WE
CAN HEAR YOU YES I JUST WANNA
KNOW WHY WHY IS IT SO IMPORTANT
THAT THAT CHILDREN GET
VACCINATED TO YOU WHEN THERE'S
A NINETY NINE POINT 9% SURVIVAL
RATE. TO BE HONEST WITH YOU I
WAS I'M FOUR GENERATIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR GENERATIONS OF
MY FAMILY HAVE BEEN HERE AND I
WOULD RATHER HAVE MY SON GET
COPAYS AND RECOVER THEN GIVE
THEM THIS BACKSEAT. AND I FEEL
LIKE MOST CALIFORNIANS FEEL
LIKE THIS THIS IS NOT OKAY FOR
YOU GUYS TO SHELVE AFFECTING
DOWN CHILDREN GROW. IT'S NOT
OKAY DIRT THEIR THEIR THEIR
SURVIVAL RATE IS NINETY NINE
POINT NINE PERCENT. IT'S LIKE A
COLD ON CHILDREN SO WHY IS IT
SO IMPORTANT TO YOU GUYS.
WHAT'S YOUR AGENDA WHAT IS
BEHIND THE. AND I WANT TO TELL
YOU RIGHT NOW MOST CALIFORNIANS
DO NOT WANT THE SEXY. OKAY
THANK YOU. AND WE DO HAVE
ANOTHER LINE IN Q. X. LINE
THIRTY SIX THREE SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN
WHITE AGAIN I REPRESENT NATURAL
FREEDOM LEAGUE. FIRST OFF I
WANT TO SAY I PERSONALLY DON'T
RECOGNIZE ANY OF EUROPE CORITY
OVER ME IT'S ILLEGITIMATE. THE
FACT THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO PUSH
VACCINES THAT ARE ON APPROVED
ON THE PUBLIC. MAKES YOU
ACCOUNTABLE. IF NOT IN YOUR
CORRUPT LEGAL SYSTEM. IN THE
EYES OF THE CREATOR. AND I JUST
WANT TO LET YOU KNOW THAT WE
ARE WORKING TO CONSTANTLY
INFORM PEOPLE GIVE THEM TRUE%
INFORMED CONSENT THAT THIS
VACCINE IS NOT TESTED. AGAINST
THE TRUE PLACEBO NO VACCINE IS
SO THERE IS NO TRUTH SAFETY
TEST THEY ARE TESTED AGAINST A
COMPARATOR WHICH MEANS ANOTHER
VACCINE WHICH COVERS UP ADVERSE
EVENTS. YOU DON'T TALK AT ALL
ABOUT THE ADVERSE EVENTS THAT
ARE HAPPENING YOU DON'T TALK AT
ALL ABOUT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DYING AFTER THE VACCINE. SO GO
FORWARD WITH WHAT YOU WILL
BECAUSE WE KNOW YOU DON'T
LISTEN TO US. BUT KNOW THAT
THERE ARE MILLIONS OF US WHO
ARE OUT THERE TEACHING PEOPLE
ABOUT THROUGH RIGHTS. AND TRUE
FREEDOM. AND YOU WILL NEVER WIN
THIS BATTLE. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER SPEAKERS HARPER WATER
PUBLIC COMMENT IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. OKAY WE'RE GONNA WAIT-
FEW SECONDS TO SEE IF ANY MORE
PEOPLE POP OFF. WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE LINE IN Q. KERR GO HEAD.
ABOUT LINE IS LINE THIRTY TWO
THREE TWO YOUR LINE OF THE. YES
I JUST WANTED TO SAY AND
REITERATE WHAT MOST PEOPLE HAVE
ALREADY BEEN SAYING IS THAT
THIS IS AN EXPERIMENTAL NOT
EVEN A VACCINE. BUT YOU GUYS
ARE PUSHING IT IT'S NOT EVEN
FTA APPROVED YET SO ANYONE THAT
IS TAKING US WILLINGLY IS THE
EXPERIMENT. THE DATA ISN'T EVEN
SUPPOSED TO BE FULLY COLLECTED
UNTIL THE YEAR. TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWO SO I DON'T KNOW HOW
YOU CAN DO THIS TO OUR CHILDREN
HOW YOU CAN. PARTICIPATE IN
THIS EXPERIMENT KNOWING THIS
WHICH WE KNOW YOU KNOW. AND GET
AWAY WITH IT PEOPLE ARE DYING
THERE ARE TONS OF TESTIMONIES
COMING IN THE PEOPLE WITHIN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS AND AFTER TWO
WEEKS OF DYING ADULTS AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO TRY THIS ON
CHILDREN'S HOW DARE YOU HOW
DARE YOU. THE MOTHERS ARE
FUMING WE SHOWED UP FOR SB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN WE SET UP FOR SB
TWO SEVENTY SIX WE POUNDED ON
THE WALLS IN THE LIVING NOR
DOES YOU HAVE CAST US ASIDE WE
WILL NOT STAND FOR THIS WE WILL
NEVER EVER COMPLY. YEAH.
OPERATOR. ALAINA DROPPED WE CAN
GO TO THE NEXT ONE GOOD. LINE
FORTY FOUR ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M SORRY I JUST WANTED
TO SAY AND- I THINK THE VACCINE
IS LIKE REALLY GREAT. AND IT'S
REALLY BENEFITED MY FAMILY. YOU
YOU HAD YOUR TURN SHE HAS
DIFFERENT. YOU HAD YOUR TURN
HAVE THEIR. YOU HAD YOUR TURN
SHE HAS HER TURN. YOU DON'T GET
A SHOT OVER PEOPLE. I'M SORRY
IF YOU IF YOU WANT TO CONTINUE
I APOLOGIZE ABOUT THE OUTBURST.
LINE FORTY DISCONNECTED IN AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR THERE
ARE NO COMMENTS IN Q. OKAY.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL ADJOURN.